here to
a port city in the deep south and if you
go down dauphin street mobile's old
immigrant and mercantile block where my
grandparents still have a store that
they've been long deceased and then
another family member runs it you'll see
stores that were run by lebanese cubans
greeks uh poles
so i think that's the story that
gradually will get out to the rest of
the country and that is the south and
the gulf coast in particular apart from
stories of race relations hurricanes
mardi gras baseball players is one of
tremendous
cultural diversity too much more subtle
than in the northeast but it's still
there only to be listened look at the
kids have come through this wonderful
bus today
varying backgrounds different
nationalities this is
quietly diverse but it's there
roy hoffman author of back home journeys
through mobile thank you for your time
thank you
philosophy professor a.c grayling
examines the morality of allied air
attacks on civilians during world war ii
in his new book among the dead cities
next he's joined by christopher hitchens
author of love poverty and war to debate
whether the targeting of civilians can
be justified times of war this is two
hours
good evening
raymond let's this work make sure they
do good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the good institute washington
the german cultural center i'm hereby
austrian the director of the good
institute washington
thank you for coming to this evening's
event
a special welcome to our guests ac
grayling
and christopher hitchens who will debate
professor grayling's new book among the
dead cities
and his deliberations on the moral
legacy of allied
area bombings in world war ii
why this debate in a german cultural
institute
i have to admit that i had doubts at
first
that this would be an appropriate venue
for this debate
and there were two reasons for my doubts
first in an emotional reaction
i felt shame
because you see
i think that a person or a group of
persons who committed atrocious crimes
and caused unimaginable suffering to so
many people
should not dwell on their own suffering
secondly
some people might misuse the arguments
and conclusions in professor grayling's
book
as he himself is very much aware of
and in this context some other people
might be suspicious
of our motivation for having this event
here
please let me
be very clear about this
nothing in professor grayling's book can
change
the historical evaluation of and the
judgment on
what germany and germans did
during the third race
modern germany will have to live for a
long time with its past
however
never forgetting the history of the last
century we
and especially we at the good institute
are committed to work for a common
future
hoping
that certain things will never happen
again
to achieve this we want to learn from
the past
and i hope tonight's debate will be one
opportunity to think about
what the moral questions raised in
professor grayling's book
mean for all of us today
i would like to thank walker and company
and the politics and prose bookstore
for suggesting this event and their
cooperation
in organizing it
thank you for your attention and now
please welcome george gibson with walker
and company
[Applause]
save it save it for them
my name is george gibson and i am the
publisher of walker and company a book
publisher in new york city and i also
want to start out by thanking harry
barrett and and the good institute and
the wonderful
local bookstore you have here in
washington dc politics and prose for
sponsoring and hosting this event
we had walker and company have the honor
of this month of publishing ac
grayling's new book among the dead
cities
we have not and i should add at this
point to be fair to all of you but i
should add the word yet we have not yet
had the honor of ever publishing
christopher hitchens
but things in publishing are circular
and one never knows um
[Laughter]
uh
though i like you no doubt have had the
pleasure of reading him for many many
years
what distinguishes anthony grayling for
me anyway
is his desire
and ability to make philosophy and the
the deep and often open-ended questions
it raises both accessible uh to ordinary
people and relevant to their daily lives
i don't know how this evening is going
to go
but i do know that at some point during
this conversation
the allied bombing of civilians in world
war ii more than 60 years ago is going
to be connected to our world today
anthony grayling is a professor of
philosophy at birkbeck college at the
university of london he is the author of
many other books including a biography
of the great french mathematician and
philosopher rene descartes which walker
will publish this october
he is a fellow of the world economic
forum
and he contributes regularly to
a number of publications including the
economist the financial times um and the
observer
and he is also
a member of a regular panel on the bbc
world international
on on international affairs
christopher hitchens i suspect needs
little introduction to the people in
this room
a prolific author journalist and critic
he is famously unafraid to have a strong
opinion
and equally unafraid to change that
opinion over time
when we created a short list of people
we wanted to approach um to have a
dialogue with anthony
he was at the very top of the list and
we're thrilled that he
accepted
um you therefore have before you two of
the most um engaging um and uh and and
interesting minds um in the world today
um and i will now get out of their way
and let you hear them
but before i do um let me just say they
will each speak for about 15 minutes 15
20 minutes um after which i'm sure
they'll they'll interact with each other
and then we'll take questions from the
audience
after that books will be available
outside
and i suspect that if you wanted to
procure a signature or an inscription
you could probably do so if that appeal
to you um could i also ask that you
check to see that all your cell phones
are turned off um and that you refrain
from taking photographs while they are
speaking
and now without further ado anthony
grayling and then christopher hitchens i
think that's the order isn't that thank
you
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed george and
thank you so much to the gertruder
institute for for hosting this um
i must begin by saying uh straight away
picking up a point that uh dr ustrin
made there
about the uh
delicate aspect of this particularly in
a setting like this
from the allied point of view that is
from the point of the western allies the
united kingdom and the united states and
the second world war was a just war a
war that had to be fought
because it was being fought against
aggressors
and uh there were aggressors who um and
was known at the time and uh more fully
known afterwards uh perpetrated some
horrendous atrocities some horrendous
crimes against humanity and one of the
greatest crimes that the western allies
could have committed during the course
of the war would have been to lose it
and that's a point that i'm very
alive to and it's one that we have to
bear in mind when we
pre-sinned from the larger picture of
the wall and look just at our own
consciences on the allied side of the
struggle
to ask ourselves whether everything that
we did in it passes muster from the
moral point of view
is it really the case that all the
endeavors that we made all the decisions
that we made all the actions we took in
the course of that war um are
unquestionably uh good ones from the
point of view of the overall aim of the
war
now i should just say a little bit about
how i came to write the book as it
explains in a way the the the conclusion
that the book comes to at the end and
when i was very small small boy what i
wanted to be was a spitfire pilot in the
battle of britain this is a very common
ambition on the part of small boys in
the decade or two after the second world
war and there were some difficulties
like time travel and better eyesight and
things like that that prevented me from
fulfilling this ambition so i did the
next best thing which was to read as
much as i possibly could about the air
war um first of course about the the
battle of britain itself and then as
time went by i read more and more about
the the bombing war
and
almost immediately noted that there was
a a tone of doubt a tone of uncertainty
in the historical accounts given almost
every historian of the obama war found
it necessary to provide justifications
for one important aspect of it namely
that aspect of it which involved area
bombing of urban centers the deliberate
and systematic targeting
of thousands of tons of bombs indeed
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs
on civilian populations
and uh as soon as i noticed that there
was this uh equivocation it
felt to me as though here was something
that had been too little discussed in a
way too much left to the concluding
chapters of these histories
and then i came across a
remark in one of them which said
this question whether it was right or
wrong
to conduct area bombing as opposed to
tactical bombing specific bombing of
genuine industrial military targets is a
question which we must leave to the
moral philosophers
and i thought well the day will come
when i i'll try to take up that
challenge and that's what i've done in
this book
and in order to take up that challenge
and in order to be scrupulously fair to
all sides of the argument about this i
felt it necessary to talk about the
history of the area bombing campaigns
which i've done in the book also to talk
about the uh intentions and the
knowledge on the power of people who
conducted it and that meant looking at
the discussion about bombing as a weapon
of war in the decades before the second
world war and i mean just to give you an
example one astonishing thing was that
in 1899 at a hague
international conference in the hague on
armaments and peace
it was decided by the international
community present there to outlaw
throwing hand grenades out of balloons
this is before there were aeroplanes
already it was clear coming up on the
horizon that developments in technology
were introducing uh potential weapons
and potential strategies of war that
could be tremendously destructive and so
as early as that as early as late 19th
century uh this endeavor first endeavor
was made
and all during the decades before the
second world war those 40 crucial years
there were repeated debates about
bombing and the experience of bombing
for example in the first world war the
germans launched a bombing campaign
against the united kingdom they sent
over zeppelins and big big airships and
gotha bombers these
gigantic bombing aircraft they killed
about 1500 people mainly as a result of
inaccurate navigation inaccurate bombing
they thought they were bombing a
a munitions factory in liverpool and
actually they were bombing a residential
district in foxton
and
the result in the minds of people in
england itself was to be
horrified at the prospect of bigger
bombers and more of them with more bombs
on them
and the devastating effect that would
have on civilization
indeed so great was the fear at least on
the part of civilian minds that in the
peace conferences in geneva during the
1920s and early 1930s not only was an
endeavor made to ban bombing to outlaw
bombing in war but indeed it was at one
point mooted that flight that airplanes
should be banned on the grounds that if
there was one somebody would throw a
bomb out of it well that didn't uh um
didn't persuade anybody largely because
the militaries at the time had already
grasped the potential of bombing
um after all the british had been using
it very effectively in iraq or during
the 1920s to police the recalcitrant
tribesmen there and the person who was
in command of that bombing endeavor in
iraq was a man called arthur harris
and arthur harris was of that school of
thought initiated by duhay and others
that bombing was an extremely potent
weapon which could bring a war to an end
very swiftly because it would terrorize
the civilian population into persuading
its own government to give up the
struggle
there were quite different thoughts
about about bombing and what bombing was
for and should be for here in the united
states of america prior to the second
world war the united states army air
force had drew up plans for howard would
conduct a bombing campaign if it got
involved
in a struggle in europe and they decided
that with the smaller force and smaller
bombers targeting them their endeavors
at
genuine bottlenecks in transport in the
production of military equipment and
aircraft and very very crucially oil
supplies that they would be able to
strangle the the enemy war effort and as
it turned out and as the bombing surveys
found at the end of the second world war
that was exactly right one of the great
contributions to winning the war in
europe was made by the united states
army air force the mighty eight based in
england and the 15th based in italy
whose most of whose endeavors were
aimed at these bottleneck targets
and for for proof if one needed it one
has only to think of the day on which
the soviet army crossed the vistula
river heading westwards towards berlin
they were met by no fewer than twelve
thousand panzers waiting on the baron
off bridgehead these uh highly
maneuverable fast tanks with the which
packed a lot of punch in which were very
well manned twelve thousand of them
waiting on the baron off bridgehead not
one of them could move because they
didn't have any petrol the fuel supplies
have been had been
severely interdicted by mainly by
american bombing in the uh period
beforehand
now when um the war
uh seemed imminent when people realized
that it was about to break over the
heads of people in europe and this was
from the mid-1930s onwards the anxiety
about the effect of bombing was so great
that all the major governments of europe
put into place plans
for how they would deal with it in
london for example 60 000 additional
hospital beds were provided
um something like a million
uh uh
enough timber to to make a million
coffins
was
set aside and in one of those tremendous
acts of futility that all bureaucracies
go in for uh an extra five million death
certificates were issued to local
authorities and this is a measure in a
way of of what the anxiety was because
of course people thought that on the
very first day of war a mighty fleet
would come across the channel
and would um bomb london flat and there
would be
millions of people trying to stream into
the countryside there would be chaos and
and there would be terror
and as it happened actually that mere
minutes after neville chamberlain
announced that the united kingdom was at
war with germany
the um
air raid alarms went off in london
because a solitary french pilot had
forgotten to file his flight plan on the
way across the channel
but that too was it was a measure of the
anxiety that uh people felt about it
and against the background of that
anxiety neville chamberlain twice in the
house of commons once before the war
began and once in the in the so-called
phony war period between the actual
outbreak of war on the 10th of may when
the the germans attacked in the in the
west that twice said in the house of
commons his majesty's government will
never bomb civilians during the course
of this war
he believed uh on the authority of of
his advisers that it was against
international law because
it was felt uh there
but by chamberlain's government as it
was felt here in the united states of
america that the
discussions that had been held in the
preceding decades in effect amounted to
something close to customer
international law and that it would be a
crime
uh
in that law to bomb civilian targets of
course uh actually the motivation for
chamberlain saying what he did
about um not bombing civilian targets
was that britain was very underprepared
for the war and terrified that a great
assault against the cities of the united
kingdom would be mounted by germany and
so he was trying to
persuade the germans not to do it by
saying that he wouldn't do it so that
was that was an important part of the
motivation but it was sincere enough
for obamacare to be under very strict
instructions
that its aircraft should not cross the
coast of continental europe
in case a bomb fell out of an airplane
and on to a civilian so the bomber
command wasn't even allowed to cross the
coast
uh before the um
attack in the west on the 10th of may
1940 and after that attack and right the
way up until february 1942 and despite
the blitz which um about which the the
certain things would be said because in
fact it wasn't itself a genuine area
bombing campaign it was an attempt to
paralyze the financial administrative
districts of london and to paralyze the
industrial cities like coventry dock
cities like plymouth and so on but even
despite that bomber command was under
orders not to target civilian
populations deliberately
until february 1942
but increasingly in the early years of
the war
there was more and more acceptance of
what we now call collateral damage the
fact that if you're attacking a a
military facility or or a factory in a
city your bombs are going to fall on the
people who live nearby
and the anxiety about doing that early
in the war dissipated as the morning
mist does with the sun coming up so that
by the time
the infamous director of the 14th
february 1942 was sent to bomber command
saying
your primary target from now on will be
the morale of the enemy population by
that time attitudes had changed
and i'd like to mention at this juncture
that uh you know sometimes people say
aren't you isn't this all hindsight
aren't you looking back at the war and
raising questions about it from
the comfort of and relative safety of
your armchair now in the early 21st
century due to my reply is that two and
a half thousand years ago um thucydides
in writing about the peloponnesian war
said
i want to recount the history of this
war in order to show how moral
sensibility is coarsened by war how when
you're engaged in the struggle you care
less and less as time goes by about what
you do he gave as uh
the
sort of killer example of this the
difference between the athenians
attitude to michelini early in the war
maitelini was a city on lesbos which had
breached the treaty that it had with
athens and the athenians discussed the
question whether in punishment they
should massacre the population of
michelini
if they had bombers they would have done
it that way but
in those days they didn't they decided
against it they decided not to massacre
the population mainly for prudential
reasons but the fact that they had the
debate at all uh had behind it a moral
impulse
but 12 years later when the city of
milos wouldn't play ball with athens
there was no debate the population was
massacred and thucydides wanted people
to be alert to this fact of the coarsing
effect of war and it's a lesson that
applies not just to the second world war
into the bomber's story in that war but
uh to us
at all points in our history including
now
anyway 14th of february 1942 the
primary
task of bomber command was to
attack the morale of the enemy
population that meant systematic and
repeated
attacks on urban areas on civilian
populations with the express purpose of
killing and terrorizing as many of them
as possible
because the um
the kind of aircraft like the big
lancaster halifax is sterling
four-engine bombers which could carry
tremendous bomb loads twice the bomb
load of a b-17 flying fortress
and the kind of weaponry because that
was still in in process and it wasn't
really until 1943 that uh sarva harris
had the the weapon that he wanted to
carry out this anti-morale campaign
against the german population it was
only then in 1943 that the really great
raids happened and the first of them was
the
um very aptly named operation gomorrah
which took place in late july early
august 1943 and in which the very first
fire um storm occurred and it's been
very eloquently written about by w.g
zebolt in his uh um essay the natural
history of destruction
and there he points out
how many people of the about 40 000
people who were killed in that one night
were asphyxiated in their cellars and in
their airaid shelters
how many of them caught in in the open
in the firestorm were so severely burned
that their bodies shrank from adult size
to the size of babies or dolls
how many people were picked up by the
firestorm burning and
flung away in the vortex of these
terrible winds these were frightful
frightful effects of the bombing
and the point about them is that they
were deliberate because the royal air
force thought very carefully about what
its bomb load would be like it had 25
percent high explosives 75 percent in
centuries these incendiaries
had an early form of napalm petroleum
jelly phosphorus bituminous substances
and oil soaked rags
and the phosphorus if it splashed as it
did it was designed to splash over a
very wide area if it splashed onto a
human being that person would begin to
burn very fiercely and they might as
thousands of people did in hamburg throw
themselves into the canals to put out
the flames only to find to their horror
that when they got out of the water it
would reignite spontaneously
it was a a terrible
collection of weapons that were dropped
with the aim of doing as much
harm as possible to the civilian
population in those cities
now these facts and that they are they
are terrible facts could be countered by
saying look war is terrible
you know horrible things happen in war
and when it's a war to the death and a
war against the very formidable and
wicked enemy as the nazi regime was
um you know the
the gloves are off
and this has sometimes been very very
well expressed in a chilling phrase by
no lesser person than mao zedong who
once said
war is not crochet
and uh everything that follows from that
follows
and when people say this to me my
response to them is to say
uh
would that mean that it's okay in the
course of a war to bayonet babies
which is a sort of shocking thought a
shocking thing to say and most people
say
well no of course not and most people
would agree that something like milai in
vietnam
was a crime
which implies that there are limits and
that instantly raises the question where
do the limits lie
and it raises the further question
was the systematic bombing of civilian
populations in germany and japan
beyond the limits
and to examine that question and my the
book is dedicated to george and i
haven't got much time but but very very
briefly what i have to do and try to do
in the book is to look at the uh the
argument that says um no it wasn't
belonging but beyond the limits in the
context of the war that is that if there
was a genuine military necessity if it
really helped to win the war then that
fact trumps our moral scruples about
doing this
and so that becomes the key focus of the
discussion really to ask whether it
really did help to win the war
and the answer is
that it didn't
people say that by by bombing the cities
keeping the workers awake when when they
weren't killed uh making life difficult
for
the german population and administration
as a whole because of the disruption
caused by a bombing that it must have
done something to slow down to dent
german production
it must also of course have kept forces
back in germany anti-aircraft forces
troops
and aircraft to defend against these
attacks
the second of those two arguments can be
very quickly and simply met which is to
say that no matter what you were bombing
even if you were bombing transport and
factories and military installations and
roads they would have had to keep back
anti-aircraft guns and aircraft so that
doesn't defend area bombing attacks on
civilians
but as to the the question of industrial
production
industrial production of all kinds not
just military production
increased year-on-year in germany until
the end of 1944.
the german economy which was very very
strong by the time war broke out and
which as a result of conquest in central
and and eastern europe had vast manpower
resources vast natural resources
available to it
following those conquests
was never put on a war footing
it was never the case that a single
german woman was conscripted into a
factory to make weapons as was the case
for example in britain
there was so much labor
that could be drafted in from from
eastern europe slave labor and prisoner
labor that there was never any necessity
for it and production of all things
including luxury items and bubble beds
and flower pots and
all the rest of it went on and on right
until the end of 1944 and what stopped
it was the drying up of fuel coal and
oil
and gas
and that was the result of
attempts at precision bombing tactical
daylight bombing very dangerous by the
united united states army air force
only as it happens uh those of you who
have read about this will know
rarely affected from very late 1943 and
1944 certainly onwards because
of the mustang fighter aircraft
long-range flight of aircraft could fly
all the way from the east uh coast of
england to berlin and back and could
protect the bombers and it was in fact
the mustangs and lightnings that
accompanied the bomber fleets which
fought the luftwaffe out of the sky
and d-day there were something like 12
000 allied aircraft uh in operation over
france and something like um 800
luftbuffer aircraft to defend against
them
and so the the effect that that the
united states endeavors had in the
european theater was a very considerable
one
so that the major argument that the area
bombing that is bombing civilian
populations by night was a major factor
in helping to win the war um looks very
questionable
now just to be brief because i'm sure
i'm running uh over time i must turn
attention to the american endeavors in
the pacific theater
and there i'm afraid the united states
went 180 degrees
in the opposite direction from what
they've done in the european theater
there's no question of precision bombing
in japan once the mariana islands had
been captured and airfields built there
so that the main islands of japan were
within range of the of the pacific
bombing force under the direction of
curtis lemay
a
well-known name i think
there was hardly any japanese air force
left at that time and precious little
anti-aircraft defense on the ground in
mainland japan and so curtis de may told
his flyers to strip out the guns the the
um
defenses
of the aircraft themselves since they
just made the aircraft heavier to fill
them up with incendiary bombs and to
bomb from a low altitude and to burn the
cities of japan and this he did
systematically in the last eight months
or so nine months of the war
and the first great incendiary attack
was on tokyo on the 1910th of march 1945
when 85 000 people were burned to death
in that city
i was told by
an email correspondent just before i
flew over the atlantic to come here
about the work that was done at the
dugway proving grounds in utah near salt
lake city prior to the bombing campaign
over japan where replicas of wooden
japanese houses were built so that they
could test which kind of incendiary bomb
would burn it most effectively and so
the the uh the campaign was of course a
well thought out and deliberate one and
it was a tremendously destructive one
in the um nine months or so of the of
the bombing of japan as many people were
killed and wounded in japan among the
civilian population
as were killed and wounded in germany by
bombing in the whole of the war it's
about 350 000 dead and about 800 000
injured in in both cases although the
figures of course obey approximate
and i suppose the final point about the
united states army air force endeavors
in the in the pacific theater is
that more than four months before the
atom bombs were dropped on the 69th of
august 945
the japanese had begun to make overtures
for a truce for a ceasefire
they were doing it through the russians
who weren't at that time at war with
them the russians only declared war in
japan on the 6th of august 1945 when it
was going to be an easy land grab you
still have some of the japanese islands
as you know
and so the japanese made overtures to
the united states through
through the russians
and there was one condition and that was
that they could keep the emperor
but you may remember that roosevelt and
churchill had decided the casablanca
that there were to be no conditions and
this was used
some people say as an excuse by the
truman administration
not to talk to the japanese about a
ceasefire until the atom bombs have been
dropped
to the very very great credit of a man
called henry simpson who was secretary
of defense in the roosevelt
administration he tried to dissuade
truman from dropping
a bomb on a populated city he said
drop one of them on an uninhabited
island to show what the weapon can do
but his suggestion wasn't taken
and so he struck
the word kyoto off the list of possible
targets of the atom bombs because he
knew of the significance of that city
now i'm looking back on it now from this
perspective and this is my final point
one notices that in the immediate
aftermath of the war
that is in the years of 1945 1949
tremendous endeavors were made by the
international community by the world as
a whole you might say uh to try to push
in place a framework of of law or at the
very least of principles which would
make the things that had happened during
the course of the war impossible i mean
that was the uh that that was the ideal
that people set themselves when they um
wrote and agreed upon the united nations
declaration universal declaration of
human rights for example and it was
certainly the aim of the fourth geneva
convention which was
written and signed in 1949 the
convention on the protection of
civilians in war
that convention in its draft form had in
it some clauses which specifically
protect civilians from attacks by
bombing
and the british and the americans
refused to have those clauses included
because to agree to them would have been
a retrospective admission of guilt
of something that they'd
done during the course of the war
it wasn't until 1977 that a protocol was
added to that convention
specifically outlawing bombing attacks
on civilians
the british government signed it um your
own government um
and i'm not entirely sure of the of the
the technicality it may be that it was
never signed by the united states
government or has not been ratified by
congress but it generated not taken to
be in force from washington's point of
view to this day
which makes this whole question really
about the deliberate and systematic
massacre bombing of civilian populations
uh a live issue still
during the war itself by the way in the
united kingdom there was a very very
vigorous campaign of opposition to
aerial bombing
um questions were asked in the house of
commons and in the house of lords bishop
bell of chichester repeatedly said in
the house of lords we're fighting
barbarians why are we behaving like them
too and the mass observation unit which
was a podium organization in the uk that
kept its finger on the pulse of public
opinion during the war kept on asking
people in all all around the country
what they thought about being bombed and
about bombing and whether we should bomb
in retaliation for the attacks on on us
and people in the
cities that have been badly bombed
majorities of people in cities that have
been badly bombed said no don't bomb
their cities and people in cities that
hadn't been bombed the door said yes
bomb them
and that's a very interesting fact about
attitudes at the time there was full
knowledge of what was going on if you
read newspaper reports now all the way
through 1943 44 and 45 you see that um
there were very explicit reports about
what had been attacked how many bombs
had been dropped there were headlines in
the telegraph newspaper for example
saying last night uh dusseldorf and god
montoyson received 60 coventries
in other words a bomb weight 60 times as
great as had been received in coventry
in november 1940.
so
people knew what was happening at the
time
uh the people who were running the
country had read their thucydides at
school in university and they knew the
arguments from two and a half thousand
years before all the way through the
great tradition of
ethical thinking in in the west
and so
in many ways there are no places to hide
except behind the arguments that i very
briefly alluded to and discussed a much
greater length in the book about the the
military and industrial justifications
that are profited in defense of the area
bombing i don't think those defenses
work and i think therefore
very serious question marks rise above
that campaign
and the reason why it's relevant to
discuss it today is because
although we don't i don't think that
there's much point in pointing fingers
and calling people war criminals now
after the event or indeed impugning the
courage and tremendous sacrifice that
was made by a young airmen in the war
who thought
rightly that they were fighting a just
war and that they had the support of
their majority of their populations
behind them
there's no point in that but there is
every point in trying to draw lessons
from it for now just when in our world
we are beginning to find ways of trying
to enforce
some of these international instruments
that were the result of the second world
war like
a human rights framework and like the
protections of civilians in times of war
which because of the kinds of weapons
that we have now is ever more important
a question
thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
i'd like to thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen for coming my name and
heron i'd like to thank the gerder
institute for
inviting me also
um
i think i too should
respond a little to um
that's to say oh my glasses on my head
they were here a second ago oh you are
so kind thank you
i'm sorry this is not a throat clearing
um it's not a plea for a plea for
sympathy uh
i expected
uh
dr ustrin to say something like
that and for anthony to take him up on
it professor grayling i should say
i think it's time really that we said
look
we have been all of us very impressed by
the extreme seriousness
with which germany has accepted its
post-war responsibilities and discussed
them in public in its own country and in
international fora
there is absolutely no reason at all to
suspect
that any reopening of this discussion
which has already been quite
elaborately
undertaken in germany even gun to grasp
with his new novel of the crab walk
has broken a few things that were once
to do there's no reason at all to
suspect that germany would become
intoxicated by any uh vengeance
uh fantasy or any grievance or any
spurious
moral equivalence there's nothing to
apologize for in other words in the
opening of this
discussion and all of us british and
american i think should have said this a
long time ago
i very much congratulate uh professor
grading on very lucid summary
of his own book that's not as easy to do
actually summarizing your own work as
some people might think um and i don't i
know he won't uh
penalize me for saying that much of the
argument was at least to some extent
familiar to some of you even if not at
the very elevated level
at which he presented it which enables
me to freeze me to
propose a few ironic uh
references
to it
i was going to start where he ended and
i'll be brief by saying that
not only has this argument i mean york
friedrich in his book der brand is only
the most recent in germany but this time
has been going on in britain for a very
long time and did in fact begin i think
rather to the credit of my fellow
countrymen if i may say that
uh during the war not just to bishop
ralph bell chichester who raised the
question in parliament as did others
not just vera britain whose
extraordinary book on the subject is
still very much imprinted very much
debated
but
someone i'm proud to say was a friend of
mine the late tom dryberg actually he
died in noble as lord bradwell
socialist though he was
was at the time a very important
newspaper colonist in london and in his
column in the daily express revealed the
case of a german girl named hilda
who had been orphaned every single
person she knew not just all her family
everyone she knew had gone and been
burned to death
in the german city and he he opened his
collar with a big picture of her and the
question right across the page in 1944 i
think should we be bombing hilda
and this was a live discussion in
parliament in the church
uh in clubs and pubs and places of work
and in bomb cities and it was right to
have all these qualms
and misgivings then and if it was right
to have them then we don't need to
apologize for having them now
oh so sorry zuckerman i remember reading
it this when i was quite young
very shocked
lord charwell's memorandum to winston
churchill
saying i think i've worked out how we
could crack their morale what we need to
do is to find the working-class quarters
of the german cities where the houses
are packed closer together
and where we would get as it were as
americans would now vulgarly say more
bangs for the buck
we can really slaughter them in these
working-class quarters
uh lord charwell's the
chilling memorandum of churchill so
sonny zuckerman one of the other
directors of this program
of bombing after the war wanted to write
a piece about it a reflection on it
for cyril connolly's great cultural
magazine horizon
and he decided on a visit to cologne
which was a city he'd had a hand in
flattening
and he came back and was interviewed
visited by somebody who said
well what about the piece he said i
can't do it
i can't do anything about it i've seen
cologne now and i can't write
so what i can remember is seeing the
total destruction of the cathedral
and seeing a human finger on the
top of a pile of rubble
and i'm i've got writer's block about
the subject um he said i had a title at
least
and the title was going to be on the
natural history of destruction
uh later and next by the great german
writer w g several who and nielsen
mentioned who we were very privileged to
have amongst us in britain for
many decades as a writer and a teacher
uh
i stipulate therefore that i absolutely
know what professor grading's talking
about
and the most haunting thing in his book
i think is the one he didn't draw
attention to
which is this
obama command and to some extent um the
united states army air force did this to
germany in the closing years of the war
for one reason above all
because they could do it
they did it because they could
they weren't able to do it earlier in
the war when it might who knows i'm
going to come to that
have made a difference but by this stage
that was what they knew how to do had
built the equipment for had trained 400
first talk they were going to do it
it's not unlike the very gruesome moment
at the end of the first um
uh gulf war with saddam hussein actually
i believe that that was that's one long
war myself i think it's been going on
since 1991 and only
uh recently been concluded but um let's
call it the first gulf war in 1991 where
saddam's forces were were withdrawing
from kuwait
got themselves trapped in a huge traffic
jam with a lot of other stragglers as
you may remember in the mutlab pass
on the way back to iraq that convoy was
bombed and staffed for days for hours
days by uh
american fighters and bombers who
couldn't believe their luck from
aircraft carriers anchored not far away
including the uss
ranger why did they blast them because
they could they didn't blast the
republican guard was the pity they
didn't take out saddam hussein was the
pity but they could do this to the
iraqis and some kuwaitis too well we
have to live with this
we have to be intensely serious about it
i had to go and give a talk at the raf
club in london the other day on another
matter
and i i felt the qualm i always feel
when i go on to the premises of the ref
the picture of marshall harris on the
wall things of this kind i was brought
up to think of fighter commanders the
heroes as anthony was bomber command
always been a bit more difficult for us
um but i have a i have an anecdote i'm
just going to tell you now
which
uh i think makes the history of the raf
imperishable though most raf people
don't know about it
the midnight of the century
as we old comrades call it
the midnight of the century is the
hitler-style impact
the worst moment in the history of
civilization the handshake between
molotov and ribbentrop the raising of
the swastika flag over moscow airport
the singing of the horse vessel lead on
moscow radio
uh the embrace of the two dictators the
crushing of poland
between them the destruction of the
baltic uh abolition really of the
boarding states and the preparation for
a ghastly war well mr mortoff was back
in berlin because the alliance went on
well into the 40s as you know on one
balmy night
in late 1940 early 1941 and he had to
take shelter
with his ghastly nazi hosts because the
raf
had arrived on a rather poultry raid but
it was enough to send the nazis and
their guests rather embarrassed down
into the shelter and while molotov was
there with his nazi friends he said i
thought you told me this could not
happen i don't think the pilots knew
how brilliantly they had performed
on this occasion but if you allow
yourself to think about this rather
magnificent moment where it's britain's
airmen against hitler and stalin
combined
bring mantle's the
english cheek with a great blush of
pride
uh
then you reflect on you have to you are
obliged to reflect on the following
two years before a group of germans who
when we are known we we know them by
their
some of them by their individual names
uh some of them by their um collective
name the kreizer group
a group of very important german
soldiers and diplomats and officers and
civilian politicians
grouped around the heroic i think
especially heroic
general helmut von mulker
ludwig beck was another member of it and
canaris was briefly a member i believe
at my old college in oxford we had an
annual commemoration for adam von saltz
who was a another member of it later to
give his life hideously the uh the plot
to kill hitler in 1944 they weren't they
sent an envoy to neville chamberlain
and said if you and your foreign
minister mr halifax if you will
guarantee that you will stand by
czechoslovakia in other words if you
will say that in moving to
czechoslovakia means war
we can decapitate the nazi regime and
tell the german people we have saved
them not just from
the foul dictator
but from war as well that we have struck
for peace as well as for democracy but
we need your guarantee
that you will fight for czechoslovakia
before we connect
the risk these gentlemen took in making
this move
is something that's very difficult to
imagine as a matter of quality
and bravery and they were told forget it
we like the present situation in germany
we hope rather to make an alliance with
it
against
stalin against communism
and as trotsky was the first to point
out once they made that pact in munich
with hitler ignoring
the opposition in germany
they made the hitler-style impact
inevitable
so that the whole might of britain
and air
navy and military which was exerted on
hitler's side in 1938
should later be used to bomb and destroy
uh german civilians
is a conclusion that's inescapable very
slowly pointed out and if you like
impossible to live with
and to make it worse we find
within a few years of this that the
obliteration of the city of dresden
one of the most extraordinary
achievements of european civilization
the entire obliteration of it and most
of its people
is being justified
for one reason one reason alone
if we do it it will impress joseph
stalin whose forces are pressing in
on the other end now i think if you're
going to destroy
a cultural treasure treasure house
and and ignite a firestorm that is
designed to consume
all of the people in it
you had better have a better reason than
it might bring a smile to joseph
stalin's face
and this is not part of our official
history this is not what we're taught in
school
ladies and gentlemen in england my
dominant heart i can assure you
now
how to confront these uh
i hope i've connected them for you
these multiple imbricated
crimes and ironies and
tragedies how to make sense of it the
way i propose to do it is this
by imagining myself not as an englishman
or an angry american but as a german
which i'd be proud to be in in fact on
my mother's side through
the city of breslau going back quite a
long way now i'm i am
um i was brought up in the immediate
aftermath of the second world war in
plymouth
and portsmouth i remember being told not
to play on the bomb sites i remember
seeing
the ruins uh the smell that still went
on actually of the young the un
dug out uh collapsed buildings and so i
remember i remember the devastation was
it was the scene of my upbringing i also
remember the
little island of malta where i was
partly brought up to which is almost
totally destroyed its beautiful capital
valletta almost completely destroyed by
the air forces of
hitler and mussolini especially remember
the awful wreckage of the of the royal
opera house in the center of the city
but
and my father was a member of the royal
navy and had a very tough time indeed
in the north atlantic and elsewhere on
boxing day if you care uh
1942 his ship sank the scharnhorst um
which was about to
undertake a terrible campaign against
civilian shipping in the north sea it's
a better day's work than i've ever done
i mentioned it just in cases of interest
but in my heart and sinew
i feel german about this
and if i can
commit the embarrassment
of mentioning
the following names not in the same
breath of as my own of course
i hope i'll make my point i'm thinking
of thomas mann
i'm thinking of pastor niemoller and
deutsche bonhoeffer the great catholic
the great excuse the great protestant
resisters of france jaegerstadter who
was executed rather than
uh join hitler's army as a catholic he
was an austrian i'm mentioning austrians
to ernst fisher who broadcast from
moscow against the advances of the
vermont uh in russia
um chancellors of willie brandt and
bruno kreiske who left their own
countries and joined the uh armed forces
of others rather than surrender
uh to fascism kurt schumacher
uh some of you will know some of these
names all of them i think should be uh
made imperishable in our history as well
as that of germany
and austria and these of course are
heroes i'm talking about but how many
heroes do you think
that might have been who will whose
names we'll never know in say hamburg a
city that had always withstood the
national socialists
that had always remained as it were red
and democratic
how many people who carried within
themselves the seeds of a future germany
and better germany
were destroyed by the raf we used to
have
a question a rather smug one in england
after the war where were all the good
germans all this time well one answer to
that i'm very sorry to say as many of
them were buried and burned alive by the
royal air force
and the fact
has to be faced but
uh
now look at it the other way
um we got
billy wilder
albert einstein
theodore dorno
marlena dietrich
sigmund freud and the germans got julius
striker
in exchange for the uh the collapse of
civilization that was undertaken by
nazism and i now come to another name
that of victor klemperer could i just
get an idea of how many of you in the
room know who i'm talking about
oh that's admirable well
for those on c-span then if i can uh
media conscious hitchens um
victor klemper the cousin i think of the
famous conductor otto was a german jew
convert to uh protestantism married to a
german protestant woman professor of
french
language and literature at the
university of dresden and on the first
day of the third reich he decided to
keep a diary and he kept it every single
day
until 1933 he's the only man whom we can
read of every single day of the third
reich
it's called i will bear witness don't
start reading it late at night would be
my advice
do not start reading it later tonight
because you know what's coming and he
doesn't
so when they take away his cat
because aryan cats are not allowed to
live in partly jewish homes seriously
when they take away his job when they
take away his russian book when they
make him wear the star when they say you
can't now use the tram you can't now use
the bus
all this humiliation
uh you know it's gonna get only steadily
worse
and you're only encouraged by the fact
that almost every day he reports that a
member of the german working class comes
up to him and says
cheer up nate these bastards will soon
be gone
don't worry we're with you the
scoundrels can't last much longer uh the
way he listens to the radio the way he
looks at the newspapers uh the way he
he disproves if you like the daniel
jonah goldhagen thesis which i regard as
a defamation of the german people
and of their history the the the vile
collectivization of guilt that's
involved in the willing executioner but
the for all the friendship he's shown
the machine grinds on and on
and finally it's come time to deport the
last element to the east the ones who
have aryan wives german wives or
husbands the last ones they get around
to and he's moved into a holding camp in
the middle of president
on i think the night of the 12th of
february
with his wife and the next day it's on
the train
but that night the heavens open
anyone who's reading account of what
happened in dresden that night doesn't
need any
words from me
the terrible thing according to
frederick taylor's book is the climatic
conditions were even better than they
had hoped it succeeded too well it
wasn't just a firestorm it was i think
it's justifiable to use the term
holocaust which many people object to
because it means the total destruction
of something by fire i do not believe it
should be called a final solution or an
endless song as the germans would say
that would be quite untrue but yes a
massive destruction by fire and in the
morning there's no authority in dresden
anymore
and there's no one to take him to the
train with his wife
and they peel off their yellow stars
she's made to wear one too and they set
off for their home and start looking for
the red army it's over it's completely
over there's no one to give orders and
there's no one who will take them
anymore
the only thing i think in our collective
experience and imagination that one
could call upon is general sherman's
decision to lay waste to the confederacy
to make sure that not one brick is piled
upon another until it is understood who
is master now and who has lost and to
make that conclusive
i think it would have been better if
anthony had dealt in his book with the
psychological effect of the years of the
thousand year right
it had to be utterly disproved
that there was a leader who was
all-powerful and all-knowing
as so many were willing to believe
it had to be conclusively shown that
when they said we will never allow
bomber in our own skies that they were
completely wrong do i have a minute to
read something from thomas mann yeah
thomas mann wasn't jewish
thomas and i was not jewish
as you know but he decided he couldn't
live in germany under these conditions
and in
his great novel i think dr faustus
was published i think first in 1947 he
he plays the part of a german watching
what's happening he says describing the
the finnish germany of the us
aaf and the raf he says this
earthshaking
plummeting havoc has come breathtakingly
close to my refuge several times now the
dreadful bombardment of the city of dura
and vilabel kirkheimer was no longer
some distant event
and as the last judgment fell upon
munich as well i sat here in my study
turning ashen
shaking like the walls
and doors of my house
its famous publishing district is i
sadly hear only a heap of rubble and an
immeasurable wealth of literary and
educational material is now the spoil of
destruction a loss not only for us
germans
but also for a whole world that cares
about culture
that world however is apparently willing
to take the loss into the bargain
granted he says the destruction of our
cities from the air has long since
turned germany into an arena of war and
yet we find it inconceivable
impermissible to think
that germany should ever again sorry
could ever become could ever become such
an arena in the true sense
and our propaganda has a curious way of
warning the foe
against incursion upon our soil our
sacred german soil as if that would be
some grizzly atrocity our sacred german
soil
as if anything was still sacred about it
as if it had not long ago been
desecrated again and again
by the immensity of our rape of justice
and did not lie naked
both morally and in fact before the
power of divine judgment let it come
says man
and then he says when he thinks about
wurzburg and all the beautiful gem-like
cities of germany being turned into
powder and ash this is terrible he said
but i but i cannot allow myself to
forget
that
terrible though german defeat is it is
nothing compared to the thought the
horror of german victory
he's willing to come to terms with he
seems almost to invite something that is
a judgment against which no appeal can
ever be made
it's finished there's going to be no
myth this time that we could have won if
we'd hung on a couple more years
that we were stabbed in the back by the
jews they certainly weren't by then
that the the the crescenous homosexuals
and communists and uh pacifists
undermine german morale no no no no
excuses this time it's over you have
conclusively lost and
we can now begin to reconstruct german
democracy and culture and civilization
which we did don't let it be
forgotten sebald in his book which i
greatly admire refers to a war of
annihilation i think he should have not
deployed that word did not annihilate
germany
british and american soldiers did not
commit atrocities against german
civilians hitler's former allies in the
red army committed the most appalling
atrocities on german civilians but if
you lie down with the devil in that way
this is what you have to expect
uh we have everything to be proud of it
seems to me
in the resilience of the german people
who re-emerged from the rubble very
quickly
uh without self-pity uh without
resentment without conspiracy theories
to begin in this task of reconstructing
not only
germany but also a europeanized germany
and a democratic europe in which germany
still has
pride place
uh as a centerpiece
in economics in in
culture in publishing and democracy
and it's something of which we're all
all of us consider ourselves friends of
the german people
rightly proud justified be proud
i do not myself believe that without
i won't call it a war of annihilation
but without an annihilating conclusive
incontestable utter victory of the kind
that sherman imposed on slavery that
when the slaves were freed from the
camps that when the clemers could walk
again in the street without the
yellowstone there wasn't that dead
feeling of liberation
heinrich burl in his closing letter to
his sons the one he wanted them to read
after he died his
posthumous letter to his sons
one of the greatest german authors of
all time i think says my boys
you will as you grow up always know
what to think of any of your fellow
countrymen according as to whether they
describe
april 1945 as the month of german
liberation or german defeat
never forget this
neither should we
now in closing
i've got to say
two things about anthony's book that
gravely disappointed me that he didn't
mention himself one
i think that he should not have said
that it would have been right for the
air crews of the american and british
air forces to refuse to obey these
orders
i think it is of the first importance in
the time of warfare
uh when the when civilian and democratic
government is not just in command but at
stake where its existence is at stake
that the civilian and elected
governments have the right
to assume that they know the larger
strategic picture
and that their order their orders will
be obeyed
and i think the suggestion that there
should have been a mutiny in the middle
of a war against the third reich
is an immoral one and i think you should
withdraw it
i think it was entirely right for those
orders to be made whatever the doubts
may have been because it was it is not
the place of officers to take to take
the place
of uh members of parliament
and the british cabinet
and then i'm going to have to read
a chapter which excuse me a paragraph
that i think disfigures the book
uh and i'll just quickly do this and i
think then it really will be time for me
to end my
hostage taking of this audience um
anthony says
a surprise attack on a civilian
population aimed at causing maximum hurt
shock disruption and terror
that comes to see very little difference
in principle between the raf's operation
gomorrah
or the usaf's atom bomb attacks on
hiroshima and nagasaki and the
destruction of the world trade center in
new york by terrorists on the 11th of
september 2001.
and this latter
prescinding from differences in scale
and the drama of the target is no
different in turn
from terrorist bombings carried out in
madrid by basque separatists or london
by the ira all these all these there's
an amalgam here
terrorist attacks are atrocities
consisting in deliberate mass murder
civilians to hurt and coerce
the society they belong to to say that
the principle underlying 911 hamburg and
hiroshima is the same as to say
that the same moral judgment applies to
all three i'm sorry i won't pass that i
won't take that
uh the the terrorist organization
which is also a criminal multinational
corporation a secret society uh a
fanatical religious cult and many are
things
run by osama bin laden is replying to no
offence committed against itself
it's not attempting to protect or defend
its own civilians
uh it can is concerned with other
people's civilians only to the extent
that only to the extent only to the
extent that casualties in their ranks
may be maximized to the greatest
possible
extent it has not even a jot or tittle
of justification on any strategic
matter i think it's quite indecent to
mention these things
in the same breath i think spurious
moral equivalence is the thing that must
at all costs be avoided in this argument
and i do hope that that sentence isn't
in the book when it's published
in germany very well thank you very much
comrades and thank you anthony for
putting up with me
[Applause]
which are these workings
oh i see oh i see this one
oh yeah okay okay so i can hold this
like that
am i gonna use this next
carrying voice
there you go
is that okay is it is it echoing is it
okay rich i'm sorry okay
well i i think it would be only fair to
start this the next section of this by
by offering the floor back to anthony if
you would like to respond to
um the last couple of points that
christopher made um and then i have a
question that i wanted to ask both of
you and then and then we certainly can
open it up to questions from the floor
well there are a number of things in
that that very rich and eloquent uh um
presentation by um hitch there that i
that i'd love to respond to but i'll
pick out two uh which i think uh
perhaps the most significant the first
is um
on the question of the
annihilating attack the the definitive
defeat of germany the fact that
the the germans must know that they've
been you know
smashed and they've got to start
absolutely from from scratch
um
one one thing that struck me as i was
working on the book was the fact that
roosevelt and churchill had signed only
very shortly afterwards to rescind
a plan that had been put forward by the
secretary of the treasury here in the
united states in roosevelt's
administration a man called
henry morgenthau this is known as the
morgenthau plan
and this plan was devised against the
background of much discussion most of it
which went on here in in the us about
what to do about germany after the war
and these discussions were of
all kinds they ranged from very extreme
um ideas that uh
you know the german people should be
sterilized so there won't be any more of
them in the future
to let's take all the german children
out of germany put them into australia
and places where they could learn
crickets and when they went back to
england they were you know back to
germany they behaved themselves uh the
idea was to try and extirpate prussian
militarism to try to get rid of the
culture that had twice plunged the world
into war in a single generation
morgethau's idea was that germany should
be de-industrialized the war should be
handed over to france and
the netherlands and luxembourg and so on
and it should be divided into two purely
aggrega agrarian countries purely
agricultural countries
roosevelt and and um churchill signed
this but they were told by their
respective foreign secretaries henry
stinson and anthony eden what a very
very bad idea this was eden pointed out
to churchill that a reconstructed
germany was going to be vital for europe
it was going to be vital as a bulwark
against the soviet union because that
was going to be the next big threat
and it was vital as a trading partner
anyway for britain itself
and so the the idea was torn up
but the fact that it was put forward at
all the fact that it got as far as it
did in the debate
is
speaks volumes really about a whole
background of opinion that had its
influence indirectly on the conduct of
the bombing campaigns
now just before i get to the the second
point that uh i need to address
the
remember this that we're talking here
about one aspect of the bombing campaign
well it happened to be more than fifty
percent of what the raf did and that is
area bombing deliberate attacks on
civilians to massacre and terrorize
civilians
that aspect of the bombing campaign
was fueled by the sense
that when you bomb a city
you don't only bomb the people in it but
you bomb the schools the libraries the
concert halls the archives the monuments
the art galleries the places where they
make violins places where they record
music
in other words you bomb the culture
in the book i call it culture side the
idea that you could exterminate
the
uh
the culture as well as the people in
order
to smash it and and start afresh
and this ties in very much with with
them hitches idea about an annihilating
defeat that would make it possible for
them to to start refresh and to do it
right and i think as many people did
during the war itself meant in the seed
of chaos that wonderful pamphlet that
britain wrote she makes the point that
there are plenty of people in germany
who weren't supporters of the nazis you
know such says the the the city of
hamburg had been the center of
opposition to nazism and yet it suffered
the first
very
big attack annihilating attack that our
obama command had mounted and so what
was happening was that the people who
were going to be needed and the
resources that were going to be needed
the clinics and schools and books and
music halls that were going to be needed
in the reconstruction effort afterwards
were being destroyed in the process and
so one has to one has to put a question
mark over that that's the first point
the second point i must take up the
direct challenge about my 9 11 analogy
i was trying there very carefully by
making the point about prescinding from
from other uh considerations on which by
the way i agree absolutely with hitch
there's a very big difference between
the british and the raf that was
carrying out that policy uh in in
1943 1944 45 and osama bin laden and his
um
criminal
fraternity um carrying out the 9 11
attack of course there is that goes with
that saying but the point that i wanted
to make was this that if you think it is
a bad thing that anybody should try to
kill and terrorize civilians
non-combatants in order to coerce their
government or to do harm to their polity
by carrying out an attack of that kind
then you've got to be consistent and
you've got to recognize that that on
that particular point there is a
comparability between
deliberately and systematically
attacking civilians in cities
uh as we did in germany and japan during
the war so i'm going to stick with that
argument
christopher do you want to
follow on that very
quickly yes if if the bombing
or indeed if the war aim in general
because it would have been consistent
with precision bombing as well
had been to impose the morgenthau plan i
don't think it would possibly be
defensible
um
so i
simply in way once a signal agreement
with anthony about that except that it
was not the policy it was very i think
it was actually disowned before the
intervention of surrounding eden and
others because in my memory of reading
the churchill
roosevelt correspondence in of their
meeting in quebec and so anyone can
check this if they wish it's the quebec
meeting
it's discussed roosevelt
says this is what morgenthau thinks what
do you think churchill says sounds like
a good idea to me they go on rather
uneasily
and i think it's it reads to me like a
competition which is which of them is
going to be the first to say actually
did we just agree to that
or not churchill is at any rate the
first he says it sounds to me
i remember his words he says immoral and
unchristian i don't see what's
unchristian about mass murder i have to
say but um
but there you go that's how some people
talk
um
anyway it it would not would have been
also by the way a very very much stiffer
and wider
opposition in britain and america
to this politically and for the
excellent reason that what it really is
the morgan plan is a replay of the west
side treaty
the attempt to humiliate germany and
crush and squeeze its economy about
which lord cain's very famously written
his economic consequences of the peace
and uh indeed an outcome for which many
people
partly rightly
blame the rise of nazism in the first
place
so i think any attempt to repeat that
blunder would have been met with a very
stern and public and democratic
opposition
but as it happens we didn't have to
worry about that
um i'll just have to repeat a little
more sternly i think the point about uh
and you didn't take me up on mutually
but maybe you didn't want to oh mutiny
on telling them
our guys should have disabilities oh
right yeah okay i'll respond i just said
i have a point because i can't believe
that you would play a slide yeah but on
the um on the second point um
uh
which was
i had it done 911
yes look um
the
the action of a non-state actor
who's announced in who's announced
policy
is not the rebellion against an empire
however crudely conducted which is the
case in your analogy with the irish
republican army or the basque
eta
uh fighting however criminally in their
tactics for the
for what they conceive of as the
sufferings and losses of their people
but rather announced in advance by al
qaeda and its supporters as the attempt
to impose an empire
in fact to do worse than that to
rediscover and restore a lost and
vanished empire the caliphate on
everyone in the world to install a
universal dictatorship and to show that
its means and its ends are exactly
symmetrical because it cares nothing for
the life of anyone who isn't a true
believer this is not comparable to
anything that the royal air force did
it's just not to be mentioned in the
same breath
and i've i've totally run out of
patience with all the liberal and left
excuses for this stuff
people who think that osama bin laden is
some uh voice of the oppressed
or cry of the unheard that's all balls
okay
uh he wants east timor given back to
indonesia
a country a little country already
almost suffered genocide that indonesian
muslim hands he wants to give him back
uh he his people blew up the un
ambassador to iraq because he the great
international civil servant
sergio dimelio had overseen the
independence of east timor in his
transition they murdered him for that
as an infidel
look what they did to afghanistan
we're looking fascism in the face with
this guy and yes i think his defeat
should be obliterating total final and
humiliating too and i'd like a bit of
applause for that please just for the
audience on tv thanks
not enough applause sorry this is
washington
it is it's very very interesting what
hitch has done he said he he he thinks
that it was a good thing that the defeat
of germany was an annihilating defeat um
i agree with that i think that the
defeat needed to be complete and
definitive we've seen in recent history
that if you don't finish the job then it
just comes back to haunt you and makes
things worse later so so he's right
about that we're not actually
disagreeing on ends here but we're
talking about means and in fact in the
doctrine of just war all the way back to
aquinas and hugo gracias and all the
other people in our tradition have
written about these things there is this
concept of proportionality if the aim is
to defeat the enemy then
let's try and do it if you're going to
be as civilized and reflective about it
as you can be
even though war is a dirty business and
we've granted from marks i made earlier
on that there have to be limits even in
war then you've got to try and do it in
a way which is consistent with that idea
of proportion what i mean by it is this
if you have a toothache you can cure it
by chopping off your head but that's a
bit extreme you try and cure it by a
means that leaves the rest of you intact
if you can and so so something some you
know considered way of of doing these
things is obviously the preferred option
on the point about the so i'm drawing an
analogy here between the idea of an
annihilating defeat and using any means
available to you to get that defeat in
order to make sure that uh the monster
isn't going to rise up again and on that
we're absolutely agreed but
what i want to try to do is to
discriminate in the literal sense of
that term is to look at a central fact
about something i ask ourselves the
question uh you've set yourself a
certain aim
is it a legitimate means to that end to
um pick a civilian population
to attack it to kill as many of them as
you can to frighten everybody else by
that terrifying attack on them is that
ever justified now there might be
circumstances there might be very very
extreme circumstances where the great
and and sometimes worthwhile fig leaf of
the
idea of collateral damage comes into
play here the idea that
there are very very regrettable
sincerely regrettable but unavoidable
casualties
of non-competence of innocence of people
who aren't engaged when a legitimate
target is attacked but i think one has
to be very careful about that one has to
say that has got to be the rare occasion
you've got to make a jolly good case for
claiming that it was unavoidable that
those people were hurt
and if you're doing something very
different from that if you're actually
targeting
civilians in order to kill and terrorize
that in itself the intrinsic quality of
that act no matter whether you think
you've got a declared war no matter
whether it's states that are the actors
in the case in other words a terrorist
organization
has to be wrong if you think 911 was
wrong and it was it was an atrocity then
you've got to think that systematically
and deliberately attempting to massacre
civilians in any circumstance is an
atrocity so i'm going to stick with that
point now i must pick up a hitch on the
on the um oh thank you though
so
the the the the point about mutiny okay
um i i think with great respect hitch
misreads me that i didn't think that the
raf should should mutiny i quote in the
book the uh um phrase in the vermacht
playbook which said that if you think
you've been given an illegal order you
can disobed
and that it actually happened that's
where marked soldiers i don't think very
many ss so just did but some exempted
themselves from actions that they didn't
agree with
and survived
um now in in the case of the the royal
air force uh personnel the usaf
personnel i say that in an ideal world i
say preface that don't i say in an ideal
situation
if these uh airmen were asked
will you go in for area bombing bombing
civilian populations or will you go for
uh tactical targets important military
industrial targets that they should have
opted for the latter i didn't say they
should mutiny certainly not
and i grant also a number of things i
grant that they really believed with
with great justification that they were
engaged in a just war that they have the
support of the majority of their
populations these were young men putting
their lives on the line it it moves me
to think that 55 000
very very young men died in the sky over
germany in the royal air force from from
britain and the british empire uh 45 000
united states army air force personnel
died in the air a terrifying awful death
and i have to comment because it is one
of the awful ironies of war it's the
sort of thing that each would appreciate
maybe
that those 55 000 royal air force
personnel died
in the process of killing 350 000
germans
german children and women and elderly
people and people who are
not directly engaged in active combat
a ratio of seven to one
what general would uh send his troops
into battle if he thought those were the
odds
okay i think i've got you i mean unless
okay you can write me down uh ladies and
gentlemen if you like but
you have that version now well it isn't
preface actually it's i'm not quibbling
but you you phrase the question like
this
under hard questions should everyone
have refused to carry out area bombing
raids yes
then the there's then as you say your
reasoning follows but it's not you don't
preface it with that yes means yes it
seems to me um and i think
i would not have said it i mean
commander hitchens of blessed memory
i can promise you did not join the royal
navy and sail around the world um for
his majesty the king in order to end up
running guns to stalin which he ended up
doing over the hump of moments in
archangel uh when the scandinavian coast
was entirely controlled by the um
luftwaffe and the seas largely
controlled by the u-birds very
unpleasant job he thought it was
outrageous to be helping the stalin
regime to go but he did not i think
think well this is so much against my
conscience i can't do it how could i
have impeached him if he had
well these might be questions for
another day i i think i'm glad on the
whole
that people decided that the british
government was a decent enough one to
have its orders obeyed even if
questionable things were being done and
i could instance a whole number of other
episodes in the
second world war possibly the sinking of
the french fleet at anchor when it was
not in aggressive mode that british did
that were also to be a question that
would make an excellent moral exercise
um let me stop you just for a second
because i want to make sure that there
is time okay but i just have to say this
it's extending my point
precision bombing would have done an
awful lot of damage to the german war
effort in dresden there's no question
about it
and probably more arguably more than
area bombing did but the next day
precision bombing would have left the
same people in charge of dresden i'm
sorry to say and victor clamper would
have got on that
[ __ ] cattle track
the same because the order wouldn't have
been destroyed there wouldn't have been
total chaos the the utter destruction of
the state system and it's uh
now
anyone who's seen the pictures of those
even in german camps camps on german
soil relatively lenient i'm at book
buchenwald in jakarta the condition of
the people who as they were found
uh by vibration american soldiers can
see this people only got a few more days
to live at best
they're they're all dying in fact
another few months of this war and they
would all have time as so many of them
did in poland and hungary and elsewhere
this also has to be born in mining
considering the japanese empire and its
hideous god king
uh every day that that country didn't
surrender i personally opposed to
hiroshima and nagasaki
i can tell you something that uh dr
edward teller once told me that it was
his view that there should have been a
demonstration bomb dropped and not the
use of it on civilian cities but urgent
question to let off upon
because every day the japanese empire
goes on
thousands of its slaves are dying and we
have the right and the duty to save them
it seems to me
so
um
i am sorry if that's not too much but i
i thought i could not say that this is
urgent
and it's a terrible utilitarian calculus
shall you kill more germans to rescue
their slaves and their victims well
you could i suppose the you can compose
it by saying
if i if i pray this is what i would say
i don't but
i would say well thank god we thank god
we didn't start this could i trespass
everybody's patience because there's a
point not not to disagree with it this
time but just a point to uh cognate what
he's just said there which is that on
the 28th of march 1945 churchill sent a
memo to manchester charles portal who is
the head of the raf uh to say to him
the terror bombing of the german cities
that's his phrase the terror bombing
must now stop
he said the uh the bombing of dresden is
a serious query against raf behavior
it's very very interesting that he wrote
this this memo because at
certain points during the war he came
out tremendous speeches about you know
flattening the german cities and on
other occasions he had
horrible fits of of conscience about it
one occasion when he leapt to his feet
watching footage of bombing of the rue
valley which was a heavily
industrialized area of germany and said
are we animals what are we doing why are
we doing this this is right in the
middle of the war
and that memo that he sent the 28th of
march was returned to him by sir charles
portal with a note saying you can't
write to me like this and you're in fact
accusing me of a war crime you can't say
this about us you've got to rewrite this
in milder terms which churchill did but
the original memo was kept on fire and
was published by the official historians
of bomber command in 1960 webster and
franklin both of whom had had their very
serious doubts about the banning uh the
bombing campaign but what's interesting
about it is this at the end of march
churchill's anxieties which i suspect
had been fueled certainly by by anthony
eden but also by senior army officers
who were going to and fro between uh
conquered parts of germany and back to
london and they were saying my god you
ought to see what's what's happened
there and what you know what we've done
and all those anxieties and in fact
hitch mentioned um just that sort of
reaction uh on the part of uh of dryback
um but then within two weeks the first
of the concentration camps was liberated
by allied troops now in ghana
bergen-belsen
dachau
buchenwald
and the
footage the newsreel footage coming out
of germany showing british tommies and
bulldozers moving huge piles of
emaciated bodies into mass graves that
so horrified the world quite rightly so
the whole world was so disgusted and
enraged by what we were seeing coming
out of germany that the debate
about the bombing was of course and i
think properly dwarfed by it it's one
reason why it's taken so long really for
for for people to be able to get enough
perspective to separate things out you
know like that game of pickup sticks you
get all the different separate them out
and just look at the that part of the
bombing campaign the area bombing
campaign just by itself and to examine
it in our own consciences about it
march 45 is a funny time for churchill
to develop scruples especially if what i
said about the final solution
and i believe i'm writing saying that
nowhere in any one of his histories any
one volume of this multivitamin history
of the second world war is the final
solution mentioned
i had a feeling i rather larger mission
from churchill and historiography
i had a feeling i wouldn't have to do a
whole lot up here to get the
conversation going um so i'm not i won't
ask any questions but but i open the
floor up to anyone in the audience um
can we start right there
and then we'll come down to the front
row right here
and then we'll go and then we'll go over
to this side right here so those will be
the first three and then we'll keep
going please mr hedges
yes
apart from the morality of it
do you think that terrorizing civilian
populations works
um
well i think this was liberating the
civilian population in
part i mean i don't we don't know how
terrorized people were we know that the
nazis kept a constant watch on people
who appeared to be celebrating or
fraternizing with advancing western
russian troops hang them from the
lampposts some of you may have seen the
extraordinary film uh
downfall
recently made in germany
downfall
extraordinary
the regime kept on acting
pornographically till the very very end
and once can't overlook the facts it's
mentioned the word terrorizing that
hitler's intention was not to terrorize
the german people but if possible to
have them destroyed as unworthy of
national socialism he wanted a holocaust
if you like for the germans
uh that seems to me it can't be left out
of the moral account i don't believe we
were trying to terrorize the population
i think we're making it clear that the
hitler had brought them into a trap
from which there was no escape
and that that the revenge upon this this
maniac this monster
would be something that the world would
never ever ever forget
anthony um i take the burden of your
question to be about the
whether or not
the bombing had the effect really of of
buckling morale and um it's a sort of an
oddity in a way given the fact that the
morale of the british people was uh um
stiffened uh in fact as well as in
propaganda but by the bombing um that
the conductors of the raf bombing
campaign are other harris in particular
i shouldn't have realized that there
might be a you know sort of
counterproductive effect
um
and it's it's really quite interesting
to see
that that in fact happened in germany it
certainly played into joseph goebbels
hands because he was able to use
the uh the area bombing campaign
as a as an argument to the german people
for resisting saying you know they're
acting in this barbaric way you can see
they've no hold bars no holes as far as
they're concerned they're going to do
anything to us so we've really got to
hang in there he was cheered in the
streets of berlin this is joseph
goebbels being cheered in the streets of
berlin and you know
berliner schnauzer and all the rest of
they weren't very happy about the nazis
nazis either
until
harris's so-called battle of berlin
which started in late 1943 went through
to the early spring of 1944 um
in attempting to break the spirit of the
berliners and it did anything but
so um your question is uh is a very
interesting one the hope that it would
force the the german population to turn
on its government and tell them to sue
for peace was uh was an empty one
next question is here can i just suggest
that that you'd address questions to
both of them and i'm sure both of them
will pick up on them
this is particularly to professor
grayling
with regard to
the question of hiroshima and nakasanka
namely
no the argument one hears
which is i find at least partially
persuasive
is that
these uh use of atomic bombs
could be justified in reducing the
casualties
for in
in the war against japan because
they uh shortened the war i mean it
certainly seems clear they did shorten
the war the u.s was was be getting
prepared for a mass invasion with an
anticipating you know perhaps a hundred
thousand casualties and who money who
knows how many japanese casualties so
what would you say about the calcu the
moral calculus in that decision
obviously
you know all together maybe a hundred
thousand were killed in the two bombings
but
is that still dying too
i still died still dying yeah but for
that just
i mean can when
make the case that that
preempted you know maybe half a million
being killed
well i would in order to accept that
point we'd have to accept the premise
that uh the japanese weren't ready to
make peace
on the morning of the 6th of august
before the first bomb went off and that
now
there's a very very wide consensus now
that's just not the case but for months
beforehand they've been making overtures
for discussions about peace and uh that
there were other motives on the american
side for not agreeing to talks they
wanted i mean there seems to be a
counter argument to the point about
saving lives to keep the war going until
the bombs were ready you ask yourself
the question why did they drop two bombs
i mean one might have been enough well
the answer is they were two different
kinds of bombs
they've kept cities relatively unbombed
in order to see what the effect would be
turn down the idea of doing a
demonstration and also for months
beforehand you know solitary b-29s were
sent over japanese cities very very high
up 30 000 feet 25 000 feet to drone
around a little bit over the city and
then go away again so that the japanese
population would get used to having
these solitary what they thought
reconnaissance aircraft overhead in fact
the japanese called the mrb
it's a harmless bombers that came
overhead and then went away so that on
the morning of the 6th of august and
there was a solitary droning b-29 above
hiroshima nobody took any nations nobody
was in an airway shelter or anything
else when that bomb went off and there
is a chilling description by by hersh i
think talking about seeing a line of
soldiers with their hands on the
shoulder of the soldier in front
all blind because they'd all been
looking up at the bomber when the flash
happened and their eyes were turned
to liquid and ran down their cheeks like
tears christians see your point um would
be met by a demonstration bomb of the
kind that the famous dr edward teller
told me he would he had favored the same
effect could have been produced on the
5th of august or earlier
if other things being equal the only
reason i can think and i've never heard
a justification for nagasaki as a matter
of fact
um is this because the the argument that
it shortened the war was never made in
1945
in any cabinet discussion we have all
the papers now nobody said let's do it
to shorten the war
some appear to have said let's do it to
impress joseph stalin which hey it's the
reason we've destroyed dresden already
stalin seems to require a lot of
immolated cities for his
self-satisfaction um
the the other is possibly to uh
deter the soviet union um advancing into
japanese islands
but i think not until 1948 does anyone
come up with the excuse well it
shortened the war so all of you who are
out of the pacific theater should be
grateful you've got home early it's it's
a bogus argument unfortunately
um
the only the other thing one can say is
well it's it's completely annihilating
there's going to be no one in the
japanese office according after the
surrender saying ah but
perhaps you know we could have a
comeback one day
the
the impossible rise again they know they
know that's it you really have lost this
time again this is an argument that i
find myself very uncomfortable
even rehearsing because i'll quantify
will and possibly wicked but
these are psychological effects we take
for granted that we didn't have in our
arsenal the time
finally
not in the arsenal of the raf or usaf
were rocket bombs
v1s and v2s which started falling on
london to a considerable extent
in 1945 and in fact it's universally
agreed the british morale at that point
was likely to crack because people
thought it was nearly over and they
couldn't stand the thought it was
starting again and this time not bombers
that could be shot down but rocket bombs
exploding without warning i read steven
spender's diaries of being a fireman in
london at that point and elsewhere all
that stuff about british pluck and so on
i mean i'm wedded to it okay and believe
me
but it's very very overdone the people
were really really flaking
now at that point you say well what else
look we know the nazis are trying for
horror weapons what's on the next damn
rocket
what do we know is coming
maybe it'll be gas
maybe it'll be germs we don't know what
we do know is we're going to flatten
anywhere which can launch one of those
those damn rockets
and we're entitled to anything
that's how people are going to think if
they're fought in this way this was
germany not germany but hitler
urging suicide on his people let me add
a couple of things to what hits you just
said that um maybe right this point
about the shortening the war thing was
the post factory justification it did
happen though that truman wrote a letter
on the 9th of august the day of the
second bomb in which he said
we will take all measures necessary to
you know reduce the number of our own
military casualties so that that point
was put that early in a letter which in
other respects is full of weasel
expressions like i'm doing my utmost to
ensure that there are no you know we
minimize civilian casualties and so on
this was written on the 9th of august so
so there is that point um which is right
you know the the the germans didn't
build big bombers what they did was they
concentrated their efforts on building
guided missiles it was terror adorno one
of the
one of the pluses on our side in this
exchange absolutely who said um
you can tell that the human race has got
cleverer over time but not wiser because
of the development from the spear into
the guided missile well the first guided
missile was
was fired off in the summer of 1944 was
kept in reserve for when the invasion
happened and then there was this summer
campaign summer and into the early
autumn of 1944 that the v1s and v2s were
coming over and causing devastation in
in london particularly and one or two
other places
the v1 the doodlebug you could hear it
and then when the engine cut out you
knew it was going to form everybody held
their breaths but the v2 you couldn't
hear you didn't know it was coming until
it exploded and the old lady lives
across the road for me and i talk in my
book about the bomb site across the road
from my house and right next to it is a
lady now in her um late 80s who was in
that house one day when the v1 fell a v2
rather fell a couple of blocks away and
she tells this story about how she was
standing at the window um at the kitchen
sink looking through the window and her
little son was playing on the lawn
outside and this terrific explosion went
off as you realize it was a v2 so she
ran out to
see if her son was okay and he was
absolutely fine but she wasn't because
the window had been blown in she was
streaming blood and her little son was
traumatized by the vision of this woman
streaming blood screaming at him and
running like this with her arms held
wide so you can just imagine how
absolutely awful it is but the v
attack had peated out more or less by
the autumn of 1944 partly because it was
interdicted there were attacks on the
launch sites but also because the just
the number that the germans had of them
wasn't very great and it's an
interesting fact that in the autumn of
1944 arthur harris got back command of
bomber command it had been under
eisenhower's uh charge since before the
d-day uh landings and had done a
fantastic job which harris always
claimed he could never do of tactical
bombing of of uh um supplies and the
german army and france and rail heads
and bridges and so on and he got it back
and between the autumn of 1944 and the
25th of april 1945 when the bombing
campaign was stood down
arthur harris dropped more bombs on
germany than in the whole of the war
beforehand and he had a list of cities
and they included gems like fort simon
hildesheim and wurzburg and others that
were bombed than the people who lived
and just could not understand why
because he could
because he could that's exactly the
point yeah the next question is this
gentleman here in the white shirt and
then we're going to go up to the back
for a question after that
i'd like to make two brief factual
points first one both of you mentioned
that hamburg was the center of the
german working class the implication
being that a lot of good people died in
the fire bombing of hamburg i think it's
worth mentioning in this connection that
hamburg also was the home of police
battalion 101 which is described by
christopher browning in this herring
description of how the mass killing of
jews took place the killing of women
children
by mass shootings thousands of
of victims being shot by these good
people from hamburg every day now the
second point is more important uh
according to the man in charge of german
war production spare
uh there was a degrading effect as a
result of the
area bombing of german cities and spare
gives
figures that so many more planes could
have been produced and so many more
tanks could have been produced and so
forth
i'm not prepared to argue that this is
decisive that this is a matter of and
justifying means and so forth
but i think it should become part of the
moral calculus and therefore it is wrong
simply to say
the
area bombing was
at no utility at all possibly was even
counterproductive and so forth the facts
are it had some effect and that should
be taken into account
anthony um on that second point i i
think as
you know when spear was in prison in
prison before the the nuremberg trials
he was invited by um
an allied commission to come and talk to
them about production during the war and
he astonished them
by saying that until the end of 1944
production was on the up
he made the point to an audience that
wanted to hear it that um it wouldn't it
wasn't rising as fast as he would like
yes that takes account of that point but
the fact of the matter is that it was
rising he complained that hitler never
allowed him to put the economy on a
total war footing because hitler had
this anxiety about what had happened in
1919 when the german economy couldn't
provide cigarettes and flower pots and
things like that to the german
people who were annoyed about it because
lots of shortages occur because of this
transfer of productive capacity to other
ends and so he never allowed it and it
turned out never to be necessary anyway
because of the enormous resources that
were available and it was the bottleneck
things the oil the the coal uh that the
transport that uh in the end scuppered
it and it was in january 1945 that
shipyar wrote hitler and said the war is
over from the production point of view
because i just now can't get the
resources together to do it
i'm in in the book by the way i quote uh
how the germans dealt with with bombing
damage i talked in particular about the
thousand bomber raid on cologne in 942
and how many millions of cigarettes and
sheets and pints of milk and loaves of
bread were on the autobahns going into
cologne within days of the of the
bombing rate how short of time it took
to re-house people partly because the
germans knew that since they were going
to start the war they made preparations
for it very early beginning 1935 or 36
but also because they had these massive
manpower resources that never affected
their their military capacity on the day
that the war ended in europe the day
that berlin fell there were 10 million
men of military age in the wehrmacht
between the ages of 18 and 35 all with
boots on and all with guns in their
hands
but you do say
it's i mean i've actually personally
regarded alberto as a
pathological liar
he was always trying to please different
audiences but he did say after the
bombing of hamburg he said another half
dozen such raids would [ __ ] germany's
war production that's what he thought
then for this subjective he later
discovers that's not true so he could
have been panicked it might have been
worth trying to stampede a few other
people
a mention of these uh staunch fellows in
their jackals though it compels me to
say again shapiro's empire
of production which included i think i'm
writing saying the factories that built
the rocket weapons and other places was
a slave empire these were not germans
working
they were slaves from russia and poland
and yugoslavia and greece and elsewhere
i'm in favor of the liberation of slaves
okay whatever it takes
and i think you may it can be something
you have to undertake in a hurry you're
certainly morally obliged to undertake
it
and those whose manpower and well-being
all the cigarettes you can get so depend
upon slavery have made a pact which
they'll upon which they may be called to
witness
sorry to sound like a preacher but their
their their bloody well is those slaves
were liberated before they could be
exterminated or before they could be
worked to death and i think this really
must be part of
what you call the calculus sir
so i'm alerted by if i may i'm terribly
sorry uh alerted by a phrase we're dying
of politeness
[Laughter]
um whatever it takes that phrase that
it's uses there
you know we agree any means necessary as
the traditional slogan yeah by any means
by any means necessary um
and also by any means effective i've got
to say because um somebody sent me an
email shortly after my book came out in
the uk a professor of economics and
andrews university and he said to me uh
i found your book incredibly interesting
i'd just like to let you know that uh
you know there's quite a bit of
discussion about um what would have
happened if the whole bombing effort of
the royal air force and the united
states army air force had been focused
on industrial and military targets if
the raf had really backed up the united
states army air force on this one he
said the war could have been two years
shorter if they'd done that that's a
fantastic thought if if correct you know
but of course it's supposed to surmise
about it but it suggests something which
is that the area bombing the attacks on
civilian populations were not part of
what was necessary they were not
necessary to winning the war and that in
a way if it's you know if any sense
attaches to the idea of potentiating the
degree of of moral criminality of an act
it just makes things worse that they
weren't it wasn't really having any
that it was marginal and yet it caused
this huge number of casualties
i want to go up in the back um
way up in the back on the left
in fact we scuppered a gentleman here
because i i i interrupted him so sorry
this gentleman here with the beard well
we'll come we'll come right back we'll
come back to him next but go up go up
there yeah
uh yes the veterans history project of
the library congress houses uh a
somewhat incredible collection of at
this point 40 000 oral histories
and more than half of those are world
war ii veterans
and i have yet to
hear a testimony or read a letter or a
manuscript
that has any compunction
about the dropping of the atomic bomb
to a man every veteran sees this as
bringing a war to an end and i think it
is quite interesting
to seem to have discounted that from all
of our discussions it's one thing to
look at the documents and to look at the
leaders it's quite another thing to look
at the opinions of the men who are
expected to put their lives on the line
and to actually execute that war
okay but it's not unlike the huge
population explosion of jews in france
in during the second world war
i mean i mean by that to say
i'm sure you've had the same experience
ever been to a french farmhouse that
didn't shelter at least six jews
i have not
there must have been a gigantic growth
of jewish population under vichy it
seems to me likewise i hate to say this
i have never met
an american serviceman who is anywhere
near the pacific theater who has not
told me
that on the 7th of august 1945 his
regiment was scheduled to go
into the home islands of japan they all
seem to believe it
now i wasn't there and i i'm not one to
want to quarrel with
um the guys in uniform but it can't be
true
and the argument was not made to them at
the time hey we've shortened the wall
you can go home this is why we've done
it it was not made so 1947 where at i
believe it was very useful as was the
opening of bookendville and dakao
and nungama instilling any conscience
that people might have had about what
they've done ah well then now i see
why it was necessary
i think it's um i think one has to
distrust this stuff
very much
can i tell you that just before i came
across the pond um i on the same day
received a telephone call
message on my answer phone and a letter
and the telephone call was from an
elderly gentleman who said
i'm phoning to say i just finished your
book i was an air crewman i was a
sergeant navigator in world air force
bomber command
and ever since the war i've
i've suffered in silence
the sense of terrible guilt of what we
did i felt it then i felt it ever since
i've never really been able to
articulate it and here it is being
articulated and i'm just phoning to
thank you and i mean to get a message
like that when you've written a book is
it's very moving
and i i've brushed the tear from my eye
and i opened the letter that was lying
on my desk and it said you bastard how
do you say this about our brave man who
did this
that wasn't the only letter i got but uh
there are always two sides to the story
and sometimes i
and then i think to myself why is it
that um that the person who wrote the
letter
who was angry with me for having written
the book
and who's all therefore ever since the
war the woman in question was an 82 year
old ex-woman's auxiliary air force um
officer in fact she had seen the pains
going off and some of them not coming
back and that's one reason why she was
so angry because she saw she witnessed
the the you know
the sacrifice from from the british side
of the story um
why she never had to say anything
was never called upon to justify what
she was part of or or what had happened
because there was a consensus about it
whereas he felt
we'd won a victory with defeated a
terrible enemy who had to be defeated i
was part of that but at the same time
you know you read those accounts of
airmen who could feel the heat from
hamburg and from berlin and dresden in
their aircraft from 20 000 feet and see
the glow from hundreds of miles away as
they flew back again afterwards who
never said anything because they felt
that to do it would be some kind of
betrayal even of themselves and that's
one reason for silence
anyway we have group captain leonard
cheshire
and many many other veterans who took a
different view even at the time as well
since so
um it's not in fact a perfect
correlation between being a combatant
and being a an enthusiastic supporter of
um area bombing we're coming up on nine
o'clock um and uh and and i want to give
time for people to you know either buy
books outside and and talk so um uh let
me take two more questions and and ask
that they be brief and ask that the
responses be brief but you will have a
chance to talk to each of them
afterwards so if we don't get to your
questions if you have a receipt yeah
that's america well done
um here and here
yes yeah okay right sorry
thanks a lot you made a compelling uh
contextual arguments against the bombing
tactic um and i wanted to play devil's
advocate real quick if germany and japan
had come across a similar capacity to do
civilian bombings to the us and the uk
uh wouldn't be a handicap to not be able
to use the same tactic against germany
and japan prior to them actually doing
it to the us and the uk so if
your opponent can sucker punch you
wouldn't it be wrong to not be able to
sucker punch them before they did to you
well i i think it the there's something
that lies behind the question that i
that i have to take issue with which is
that um
if the point in question were trying to
preempt their capacity to do that to you
to do an arrow bombing campaign against
you that the right thing to do would be
to
attack that capacity to attack their
aircraft and airfields and bomb-making
factories and so on but to attack their
civilians in their cities would have
been entirely the wrong strategy because
it would have left that affected their
ability to do it to you so
so that's my response
ian foster wrote a great essay it's
reprinted in two cheers for democracy it
was actually delivered as a bbc
broadcast
in the early days of the struggle saying
um
he was very anti-militarist but he said
before we consider what germany might do
to us we should consider what is already
done to germany
the wreckage of german culture the the
smashing of the universities
the emigration of the genius germany not
not by any means all of the jewish but a
lot of it which very probably meant uh
that they hugely [ __ ] their ability
to use physics for warfare
but we knew that they were working on it
and it's the only reason that men like
einstein would never have dreamt of
prostituting his talent in this way
and meals were willing to work on it too
was because of the dread that they might
get it first well now if you're in a
situation where you don't know
you know you know heisenberg is still in
germany you you know he's a great
physicist you don't know how much
resources he has
well you may you you have to consider
yourself entitled to try anything it
seems to me
it would be irresponsible be impeachable
not to do so
we don't know how close they came not
very
they were defeated products they were
fascists
fascism is irrational and
self-destructive we can be grateful for
that like bin laden
sir uh the problem i'm having with the
moral position on this is that when you
take the moral position it's very
difficult to
attack it with logic
when one deals with uh it's regrettable
because
uh it's regardless because we were
enraged it's regrettable because we
wanted to send a message of revenge
it's regrettable because we wanted to
make stalin think twice uh it's a very
utilitarian argument
it seems to me to posit the moral
position
which is
you know either with it or you're not
is that the deliberate targeting of
civilians
whether from the air or from the ground
or for torture
or
holding them incommunicado for years or
whatever
suspension of habeas corpus and all of
these things
can be done for utilitarian reasons but
it seems to me
that when you take those positions and
you use them you are sailing from the
shores of civilization
and there's no return
that it's very hard then to draw those
lines
so you can't think of any circumstances
in which pacifism would be an immoral
position
well in fact i can but when i do that
i realize that i am creating a hole in
in a wall i'm breaching the logic i'm
taking a position that may in fact be
immoral
for some other reason that i believe it
overrides
the situation
anthony do you want it oh i just make a
tangential point uh
which is that the point of raising the
moral
issue at all even if it's post-facto and
even if it's a long time afterwards
seems to me that
actually pack much more of a punch than
people realize i mean i wonder whether
it isn't the case that some military
commander somewhere or much more to the
point some politician making a decision
about going to war or doing something
during the course of a war
doesn't reflect what will happen in 30
or 40 years time when some meddling
philosopher comes along and says what
you did was bad you know and ruins his
reputation and that might be it probably
isn't that it might be a constraint on
some people sometimes and you know the
hope the struggle is you know here we
all are we're in the in the raging seas
of uh controversy and history and we're
trying to hold the candle the lighted
candle up as high as possible and and
that's the point you know having the
debate at all is one way of trying to
save something back from uh our uh great
endeavor to be civilized and even in
times of emergency and having it at the
time in london in the press in
parliament in the churches and that's
not terrible
it would be nice if the germans were
able to read that discussion would be
very nice they all have it themselves
alas
wasn't the nature of the enemy that we
were confronting
you have been a terrific audience um
thank you for your patience um i trust
those positions well
i trust that's because you found it
interesting and thought provoking and
and and uh and engaging which i
certainly did as well um thank you all
for coming um both anthony and
christopher will be outside afterwards
if you'd like to speak to them further
and appreciate your being here
[Applause]
ac grayling is a philosophy professor at
burbeck college university of london and
a fellow at the world economic forum his
book is among the dead cities
for more information visit his website
acgrayling.com
e-school at maryland's capital city
hosts the fourth annual annapolis book
festival
and book tv takes you there now for five
and a half hours of live coverage up
first christopher hitchens the vanity
fair contributing editor will discuss
his latest work a biography of thomas
jefferson
you're watching live coverage of the
annapolis book festival here on book tv
on c-span too
hope so we can only help
it is my distinct honor and pleasure to
be introducing christopher hitchens this
morning for not only is he a fellow
expatriate he was also born in
portsmouth england as as was i
and just now i figured out that we
actually we were born in the same
building
[Music]
educated at oxford and anointed by the
british newspaper the guardian as one of
the top 100 intellects mr hitchens has
written prolifically both in books and
for numerous magazines led by the nation
and vanity fair on subjects as
wide-ranging as mother teresa ronald
reagan and michael moore
recently he published his latest book on
thomas jefferson
once a darling of the left he now issues
his socialist past
although he still seems to hold some
affection for marxism
however he's forsaken his erstwhile
liberal friends describing him as too
righteous boring and herbiferous
his views then cannot be pigeonholed
perhaps that word contrarian best
describes him ladies and gentlemen
please welcome christopher hitchens
well first of all thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen for coming and
thank you
paul for that very handsome introduction
nice to meet someone from whom i could
have been separated at birth
um
i'm told ladies and gentlemen that we
only have uh three quarters of an hour
together and so
it's an hour that's good all right well
i was going to say that i take it that
people like yourselves come to events
like this
in order to speak as well as to be
spoken to so i'll i'll try and
be as sparing with my share of the time
as i can be but
bear in mind that mr jefferson was in
power almost continuously one way or
another for a quarter of a century it's
quite a difficult life to compress into
one book and certainly into one
talk i thought i'd speak about him under
four uh headings four chief headings
uh enlightenment
uh war and revolution
uh nation
and uh slavery
um
jefferson was slightly prone to
self-pity he would often say the burdens
of office were too great
the appreciation of his uh
efforts was insufficient the bitterness
of politics was to foul he would
constantly say i'd much rather be back
on my farm in monticello
he would now have said in order to spend
more time with my family and we would be
able to add now from what we know more
time with his two families
but as it happens he could easily have
elected to do something other than
politics and have been
perhaps not as well known but equally uh
successful
in the chosen field he could
have been an excellent lawyer he was a
very good lawyer
it took some quite early cases also
about emancipation
uh he could have been an extremely good
librarian
his private library became the core of
what is now the library of congress in
washington
uh he designed a plow
which uh dug a deeper furrow
in the soil he could have been was a
very good farmer he wouldn't have been a
very good
uh wine grower he never got virginia
wines up to snuff in fact they still
rather lag though i think they're better
than the connecticut chardonnay
um
he
when he had to settle a minor point in a
question about the rights of whaling
uh whalers in the moby dick sense um
between his country our country and
others he decided he'd have to write a
special treaties on it
to study the whole matter properly
before he gave his report he was a
genuine
polymath and the
city of um
philadelphia in that time while it might
not have been the equivalent of say the
fifth century athens
was becoming had become a magnet city
for that kind of talent scientific
uh medical
um philosophical and so forth of
obviously the best known
to us of this pantheon is benjamin
franklin who has a reasonable claim to
have discovered at least the workings of
electricity and its connection to
lightning but
um for example when joseph priestly
who we can i think rightly call the
discoverer of oxygen even though he
believed in the phlogiston theory for
most of his life
uh was a brilliant scientist and after
his laboratory in birmingham in england
had been smashed
broken up by a mob shouting for the
church and the king these are the
supporters of edmund burke not all of
them were as polite
or as polished as mr burke was
mr priestley decided to take his
remaining instruments and his knowledge
into across the atlantic and bring them
to philadelphia where he knew he'd be
welcome
there one could have met people like dr
benjamin rush a very distinguished
physician also one of the founders of
the american anti-slavery society
thomas paine came across there with a
letter indeed of introduction from
benjamin franklin
not just in order to exert his fantastic
skills as a polemicist and public
speaker
but also in the hope of designing which
what had never been tried before an iron
bridge a bridge that would span
uh water and connect distant places and
survive the winter wouldn't crack and
and splinter as wood would do bridge
building couldn't be
a better definition of an enlightenment
project bridges are dialectical by
definition they don't go only one way
an ideal occupation for mr payne
jefferson was absolutely in his element
um in this world
and i think there are two um
achievements that we can that we can um
attribute to this enlightenment
atmosphere to the sort of authors and
writers who they discussed in france in
italy
uh cesari bakaria for example whose book
on crimes and punishments had begun to
revolutionize
thinking in europe up until then
executions and torture the most barbaric
kind had been very commonplace
uh when jefferson became governor of the
state of virginia
he produced an almost model statute on
crime and punishment didn't actually
succeed in abolishing the death penalty
i'm sorry to say
but in
attempting a
less retributive and more rehabilitating
more humane and more scientific
penal system
that would be one
what i would call enlightenment
achievement and one that set a precedent
across the united states but the most
important one i believe um
and probably the major subject of
conversation in philadelphia at that
time was this or is this
once people had begun to realize that
the world was not flat
uh that the
sun did not revolve around it
the diseases were not caused by devils
or by sin
um and various other quite
striking
disclosures of the kind
they began also to think as it were
inevitably that well there might be
another explanation
than creation uh for the way the world
was um
and though there might be a designer
deism was very common among this group
people who believed in the fact that
the order of nature showed there must
have been a god or at least a starter
but it didn't look as if this person or
force took any direct interest in human
affairs did not intervene did not answer
or listen to prayers uh was uninfluenced
by sect or anything anything
as backward as that
that it was probably necessary to have a
separation in society and in government
between the church and the state no
other
government before all since has ever
deliberated on this point um and
resolved it in this way
extremely revolutionary at the time
probably
the fact that the british crown had had
its own private church the anglican
church sometimes called the church of
england or the episcopal church
which obviously was going to be
disestablished in america the crown
wasn't going to have its own church
anymore may have made it easier but it
was proposed i'm talking again now about
the deliberations in the virginia
assembly by patrick henry and others
will let us instead have the government
support not one church but all churches
everyone should be tithed for the
support of all churches there was to
that proposition in the context only one
reply which was that the government
should support
no church
and together mr jefferson and his close
lifelong friend mr madison involved the
virginia
statute on religious freedom how many
people have here have been to
charlottesville to monticello to see the
house well that's excellent well then
you know that on the but just for those
who are watching us
and wishing they were as knowledgeable
as we were
um
you will you may those of you at home
ladies and gentlemen may not know that
when mr jefferson designed his own
memorial which takes no religious form
by the way there's no cross or anything
like that he didn't have an attending
priest at his deathbed either which was
long foreseen
he only mentions a very small number of
achievements he thought he only should
be remembered as
founder of the university of virginia
author of the declaration
of independence and author of the
virginia statute on religious freedom
i didn't think it worth mentioning that
he'd been president
twice and vice president and secretary
of state and ambassador to france or
minister to france
uh so we can we can well see the
salience that he put on this
and though because he was in france
he wasn't present at the deliberations
in philadelphia that resulted in the
constitutional convention
i think it's obvious when you look at it
the virginia statute on religious
freedom is the embryo of the first
amendment to the constitution which is
my opinion the amendment that
outranks if you like all the others
which makes a clear separation between
church and state and guarantees
religious freedom by the only means by
which it can be guaranteed which is to
say a secular state
and also guarantees the right of free
expression um and free assembly
uh the the
the extraordinary luck of having
somebody who could
out of that intellectual ferment
of philadelphia
take it into politics and then into the
law and then into a drafting committee
and finally into our constitution is
something that i think
would be well certainly
has made a book in itself
um so that's not all i want to say about
enlightenment but
i've come back to it by another route
but the second area where he was
preeminent
was that of
war and revolution in the first place he
drafts the manifesto of the revolution
most of it at any rate um
fails to get a clause
condemning slavery from being adopted
fails to get it sorry fails to get it
adopted
probably because of the pressure of the
carolinas and georgia delegations but
also because of the number of slave
traders not holders
also in new york
but with that terrible initial defeat
conceded he he announces if you like the
first democratic revolution
until that time
the word democratical or democratic was
generally used as an insult
as as the greeks might have said
octocratic or mobbish or mob rule to be
accused of being a democrat was to be
accused of favoring essentially mob rule
john adams would i think have continued
using it in that way
uh for most of his life um
the word democracy evolves as a
non-pejorative as a positive word really
out of the work of of thomas jefferson
and in my opinion the unacknowledged uh
draft of the declaration thomas paine
was the subject of my
next book the unacknowledged founding
father but that the crucial thing is
popular sovereignty and the for the
first time
the idea that rights are innate uh in
humans not in monarchs
not in bishops
and not derived
from
the heavens
though a creator is mentioned it's not
specified
that they are
common property any human can claim and
this is this idea
which i believe is still the most
revolutionary idea was at that time
extraordinarily so
um when mr jefferson finally becomes uh
president
the very first thing he does is to
declare war
and he does it without consulting
congress
and he sends the american fleet with the
marine corps
way out too far from land and in too far
gone in time for when
for them to be recalled when he finally
does tell congress he sent them
um this is because he wanted to make
absolutely sure that this war was a
success
the war he declared
is known to us as the barbary war
and largely forgotten i think now in our
history but of
extreme importance not just as america's
first war
but as a war of uh liberation the war
was against um what as i say vaguely
called the barbary states these are
more properly described as the
states of the ottoman empire
uh in north africa
what we would now call algeria morocco
tripoli excuse me tunisia and libya
uh tripoli would have been libya tripoli
that then would be libya now in other
words they were the ottoman states they
commanded the
entrance to the mediterranean from the
atlantic the straits of gibraltar the
pillars of hercules
they were in an extraordinary position
to impose their will
on navigation and it's calculated now by
the best historians this is a lot of
this is quite recent work
that between 1750 say about 1750 and
about 1820
about a million and a half europeans and
americans were kidnapped by these powers
taken from their ships the ships were
taken to and pressed into slavery
uh you could you could avoid this if you
paid a tribute to the relevant
potentate the bay or
um
sultan
which most european powers tended to do
there was there was a tariff for it and
but the united states
was in a weak position at that point to
be paying the tribute and
uh the british crown which had up until
then been guaranteeing american shipping
was rather vindictive um and probably in
fact made bargains
with the barbary states in order that
they would particularly pick upon
american shipping showing them
what they lost by losing the protection
of the union jack so the situation was
pretty
uh desperate uh these ships were you
know very powerful too they they it's
recorded that almost the entire
i'm not making this is a local pitch
because i'm in
annapolis but the entire town of
baltimore in ireland
was carried off the entire population in
one night by arab slavers
and never seen again they ranged that
far north and all the way down into the
atlantic
jefferson had tried very hard to
negotiate with the um
barbary ambassador mr abdulrahman he
went to london to see him and said by
what right do you do this to american
shipping we did not take part in the
crusades
we did not take part in the
um reconquest of andalusia
we are not a christian country there is
a treaty still extend still is the law
of the land
in this country the treaty of tripoli
which among other things states and has
the full support of congress in the
senate in stating the united states is
in no description a christian country
worth remembering by the way when you
hear some of today's blow hearts
but abdul rahman replied that this was
irrelevant uh that that any non-muslim
could be taken into slavery according to
the to the quran and all non-muslims and
other infidels were to be punished
and if they didn't want to pay the
special tax they could they could expect
uh to be treated as chattel well it was
decided not to be spoken to in this turn
of voice and the fleet set sail and
after a fairly prolonged bombardment i
won't tell you the whole story and some
very heroic operations now associated
with the names of stephen decatur in
particular
uh a change of policy was imposed uh
they the
the uh
the practice was given up of of piracy
and enslavement and the uh it's the
reason why the first line of the marine
anthem
from the halls of montezuma to the
shores of tripoli is the line that it is
because that's the first time the
the american flag was planted in war uh
on another
country soil
this was a very very brisk start
to mr jefferson's presidential uh life
and he he meant it i think to well i
know
i argued strongly in my book to show
that the american revolution was not for
americans alone
that the ideas that it embodied
were he hoped capable of universal
emulation he hoped that they would
spread he he believed they had spread to
france he'd been
disappointed by the defeat of his friend
the marquis de lafayette in the
fracture side within the french
revolution but nonetheless he believed
that slowly by degrees the american
revolution would export itself
and could be exported by violence if
necessary or if negated
and i mention it because among other
things we can say
that at least partially it cancels the
shame of the exclusion of the
anti-slavery clause from the declaration
of 1776
at least mr jefferson in his lifetime
did put down one slave trade but i'm
coming back to that subject too it's one
revolution none for now
um sketchily i admit the enlightenment
nation building
in order for the united states to be
a revolution that could be emulated and
exported and fought for overseas
it had to be a serious continental power
this is jefferson's main preoccupation
throughout his life
he had various principles sometimes
federalists sometimes anti-federalists
sometimes republicans sometimes
democratic any of these principles he
would sacrifice if it
gained territory
or trade or power or influence for the
united states when this country began
we were gathered today in annapolis
which was briefly its capital
would
still be in it if it
remained the way it was but the way it
was was
to this continent the northern american
continent what uh chile is to the other
side of the south american continent a
long
ribbon-like country trapped between the
ocean and the mountains
chile very charming 13 colonies very
charming too but you see
how easily they might again have fallen
prey to any renewal of violence between
britain spain and france it was a very
tenuous existence
for jefferson the absolutely critical
thing was to gain control of the
mississippi thought if we can do that
um
we can become a real continental power
the term united states of america
originally coined i think
this is disputed but i think it's true
by thomas payne
uh weighed with him very much and he
thought there should be more states
and he was always looking for expansion
first in the northwest
but above all towards the mississippi
and the chance came
in the early part of the last century
when
despite the fact that he had always been
in favor
of uh the french revolution and even its
bone partisan expression against the
british empire he was never really
neutral as between britain and france
i had undertaken immense political risks
to be identified with the pro-french
faction he wrote to the french
government and said
we want you to sell us
new orleans we must have it in the
mississippi
at all costs we understand you're
willing to sell the game the idea had
been given him by thomas payne
he said i think they're so broke now
said payne that they would they would
sell us louisiana
jefferson said if you don't do it if you
don't accept our offer um in order to
gain control of the mississippi i'm
willing to make a naval and military
alliance with great britain something
that would have been unthinkable for him
to say under any other circumstances
and mr otalia wrong uh napoleon's chief
politician
had to admit that they were so broke and
so much in highway that that he would
give them more than they'd asked for
they'd given every french territory in
north america
he wasn't even quite sure of the full
extent of it but they could have the lot
for a given price which comes down to
if you take henry adams's beautiful
formulation
doubling the size of the united states
in one day
at the cost of 10 cents an acre
the most extraordinary land deal
in history almost makes you believe in
manifest destiny
um
well especially when you think like just
a digression but only a few years later
mr lincoln's secretary of state mr
seward is talking to his russian
counterpart who says we've got this
boring extension of siberia on your side
of the straits
called alaska it's no use to man or
beast you know do you fancy buying and
he said well okay i'll see what i've got
on me something
oh
maybe god is on the side of the united
states after all anyway
for jefferson this was the absolutely
critical thing and
this is the bit that i like and i make
it i make it a crux point in my in my
book i don't believe in numinous dates
or anything
like that even though mr jefferson and i
actually have the same birthday
but the birthday of the united states uh
the fourth of july is also the date on
which the louisiana purchase is
announced in the gazette
in washington and happier still
later in the afternoon of that day lewis
and clark receive their instructions to
depart from pittsburgh and go west
and to and jefferson is able to tell
them he's already told them you will
have to meet with and treat with many
indian nations and their leaders
he urges on them always to treat them
with the greatest of respect
ask them to
enter into negotiations with washington
but he's able to tell them
lewis and clark what they can now tell
these indian leaders which is
gentlemen you already live in the united
states of america
the reign of the emperor of france is
over and will never come back the
spanish are not coming back either you
are americans already
and so with on that fourth of july he's
able to send off the greatest
enlightenment expedition
ever
founded this is a word for orientalism
for the way that napoleon but around the
same time
sent all kinds of artists and
scientists and geographers and
seismologists and botanists and
anthropologists to egypt that we call
that orientalism
occidentalism is what mr jefferson was
practicing
he made sure that lewis and clark went
to philadelphia the great city of the
enlightenment for a long course in uh
astronomy how to guide themselves by the
stars stellar navigation
uh in the uh
curing of
cholera the treatment of car excuse me
not a cholera of smallpox i i
beg your pardon
um
not irrelevant digression here
um jefferson vaccinated everyone on his
estate at monticello including the
people who wears property
against
smallpox he was a great partisan of dr
jenner's invention
he even discovered a method by which it
could be kept cool and not lose its
force when it was being transported
there was a problem with it losing its
potency he discovered that by keeping it
cold
with water or ice
it could it could be
taken quite a long distance
he taught arranged for
uh lewis and clark to be taught how to
administer
smallpox injections to indians which is
a small compensation for the terrible
damage done
to their culture by the smallpox that
was brought to the new world by the
colonists
um
timothy dwight famous divine of the time
uh
well known as the founder of yale still
took the view that um
vaccination against smallpox was an
interference with god's design shouldn't
be practiced i suppose he would have to
be right since it would have to have
been god who designed smallpox in the
first place but this is the trap you dig
for yourself as a creationist
so
in all these other ways the these
version club became very very highly
educated people trained in
all these matters and navigation
agriculture they would take
given seeds and plants to take with them
they were given instructions on how to
keep cuttings and bring back
specimens of of botany
on their return it was a genuinely
scientific expedition and of course by
the time it was over
it could be safely said
that the united states would one day
extend
as far as california and oregon
um
which of course it eventually did though
mr lincoln's greatest ambition was to
go to california and even he as
president never managed to do it nor of
course did mr jefferson but
by the time the jefferson presidency is
over we know that there's going to be
a major country called the united states
of america and everyone else in the
world knows this country
cannot be messed around with militarily
and that it has a revolutionary uh
manifesto somewhere about its person in
the form of a declaration and now a
constitution so
the whole wheel of history effectively
turns
enormously in the jefferson years so i
left slavery to the last because i
because i had to but because also it
touches all the other things i've
mentioned it's a consistent thread
throughout the whole thing
jefferson tried when he was a young
member of the virginia house of burgess
is under british rule to have at least
the right for
the right of manumission as it was
called
the right of um
a slave owner that's to say to to
liberate another slave that was not the
thing you were allowed to do
in polite society it was wasn't you
weren't able to set that bad example he
fought for that he fought during the
declaration as you know
to have a clause included that uh would
ban not just the the trade but the the
trade-in slaves but also the holding of
slaves
didn't get that written in
wasn't at the constitutional
convention did succeed in having slavery
prevented in the northwest territories
in that ordinance or tried his best to
do so past the past the relevant
legislation
in his notes on the state of virginia
which i strongly recommend that you read
uh
writes such good abolitionist prose that
you don't really need after you've read
that to read even frederick douglass of
maryland
um all the arguments against slavery
are in there already
not just the degrading effect that it
has upon
the slaves themselves which is
so to be taken for granted but the
the extremely degrading and dehumanizing
effect that it has on those who profit
from it and who hold other people's
properties it's
probably not been put any better or more
tersely
um and we can add with pride that um
the slave trade of the barbary states is
put down by american force
good but
when the united states is doubled in
size by the louisiana persians
and when a whole new
world and another chance for another
whole new start is presented
thomas payne and joel barlow two of his
closest friends go to the president say
look mr president we can start again
do not have any slavery in the new
territory don't bring any slaves into
louisiana don't unload anyone at new
orleans that has to stop go and get some
good thrifty german immigrants and
settlers and get them settled on the
land
and allow freed slaves from other states
to come and be given land grants in
louisiana we can start again
and jefferson said no
because he was afraid of what had
happened in haiti he was afraid of the
haitian revolution
which again negates his general support
for
revolutionary activity if it wasn't for
the haitian revolution there wouldn't be
the united states because if it wasn't
for the haitian revolution to which
we are in an unacknowledged debt
it wasn't for the heroic slave rebellion
of tucson liberty napoleon wouldn't have
lost his army in the west indies
wouldn't have gone bankrupt wouldn't
have needed to sell louisiana never
forget this
but jefferson didn't like the idea of a
black rebellion he didn't want to see
that spreading to the carolinas that's
the first thing and second
uh
the crucial thing for louisiana was the
sugar crop
and the sugar crop
i'm getting near to half an hour i
should stop in a second
well yes but i mean you've got to be
spelled by 45 minutes and if
and if you're spellbinding you don't
need 45 minutes so but thank you all the
same i'm glad to see no one's yet
stirred or that it's it's i don't mind
them looking at their wages i hate it
when they start shaking
um so two points here on technique you
see the enlightenment uh the discovery
of wonderful new techniques isn't always
progressive it isn't always
revolutionary it isn't always
emancipating mr eli whitney's cotton gin
is a wonderful discovery
it really is but unfortunately it makes
cotton a lot more profitable
and cotton is never going to stop being
labor intensive so there's a wonderful
new invention that actually doesn't
emancipate people it rather continues to
hold them
in slavery well the cotton interested
dominated that far but now the sugar
interest takes over and if the sugar
harvest isn't cut and brought in quickly
then the caribbean islands still outside
the american orbit they'll dominate the
trade instead so
jefferson decides to capitulate and the
chance of a second new start is
is uh lost
consciously lost because he had the
advice and the pleas of payne and barlow
not to do it
and because of the enormous size
of the louisiana purchase it means it's
going to be carving and cloning into new
states all the time and already begun to
do so
and it means that by the end of this
process
uh in other words the vast edition of
territory and the huge extension of
slavery that very very soon
in fact pretty nearly by the time of
jefferson's death it would be the case
that the number of slave states and the
number of free states would be
approximately equal
a state of affairs which is later echoed
in a
very momentous speech by
abraham lincoln who says that he doesn't
think the union can long endure our
slave in half free well an admirer of
jefferson has to concede
that this was the state of affairs
gifted to mr lincoln passed on to him by
mr jefferson and this is a a terrible
irony for those of us who believe in the
in the american ideal um
well i think that that's now the the
body hand of time is on the prick of
noon
um as i believe mercutio says um someone
will correct me if i'm wrong um and i
think i
have sketched for you why jefferson is
so fascinating
why so paradoxical and why as i close my
book in saying
i believe that he illustrates that
history is not a
morality tale but a tragedy
it's been nice having you as my
prisoners and i'm now happy to be your
hostage ladies and gentlemen thank you
for coming have questions ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
if you have questions ladies and
gentlemen please go to the microphone in
the middle of the room to ask them
thank you for your talk
this one
it's not amplified okay
uh thank you sir um
i recently heard that in the declaration
the first line jefferson had written we
hold these truths to be sacred and
unalterable and then franklin revised it
to say we hold these truths to be
self-evident so i'm wondering
i mean jefferson's original formulation
doesn't sound as enlightenment
um as franklin's and i'm wondering if
you have any thoughts about that i mean
i mean words are kind of symbolic of our
underlying experiences so it does i
think it's a distinction with a
difference
you know we had had sacred and inaudible
and said self-evident thanks
you're quite right um
though sacred it doesn't necessarily
have to have a non-secular meaning
you'll certainly write to the best of my
knowledge i think it's in
i have a feeling it's in jerry
weinberg's excellent new book on
benjamin franklin
but anyway the term self-evident
is his i mean remember this is quite an
impressive drafting committee they've
got there they they have they have
franklin and
jefferson um and several other gifted
people they also have the collected
works of john locke which if you look at
and then compare
with the final document is an
extraordinarily def bit of plagiarism
word for word almost is the bit
for example which says that people are
likely
often will
put up with a tremendous amount of
oppression and inconvenience if they see
no other way
of
living that you can load them with more
and more
taxes and chains and so forth but uh
when a long train of abuses and
usurpations and so forth
culminates then they'll rebel and that's
almost word for word from loch's
treaties on civil government
um
if franklin had been the
uh chief drafter instead of just one of
the committee there might even have been
a joke in the declaration
but with jefferson you could be
absolutely sure that would not be one of
the sad things about writing about him
is to discover that really had no sense
of humor at
all and the proof of this is he thought
tristram shandy was a hilarious book
and would read it aloud to his wife and
have him her martha
sally's half-sister uh read it to him on
the long winter evenings now you just
have to picture that for a laugh fest
i've greatly enjoyed your
exposing the various issues that your
book
has and the little details that you've
given us
and aside from your birthday july 4th
what was the primary interest or
stimulus for you to tackle or study and
then write about jefferson
um jefferson isn't born on the fourth of
july neither am i so i may have run
those two things together
in fact though i was born on april 13th
and so was he he was actually born on
april the
20th something he was born under the old
calendar
i often wondered what the astrologers
did the horoscope artists
did when everyone had to shift over a
zodiac or two but jefferson would have
stayed in aries i think by his day but
on his tombstone it gives both dates
um
why was i interested in him well i would
never have dared propose writing a book
about him i don't think but when i was
approached and asked to do so
i thought
yes almost immediately because
everything one writes if about america
is in some way writing about jefferson
as i say
washington is a necessary presidency to
study there are several others i'd say
were necessary obviously lincoln
certainly roseville these are quite
short intervals of time jefferson's
right there from the beginning
um the declaration
prior to that the preparation for the
revolution the committees of
correspondence the final appeal to king
george
the vindication of the rights of north
americans um
then paris uh where he helps to draft
the declaration of the rights of man
first time ever such director has ever
been made in french soil and comes
universal declaration
um
then secretary of state then
vice president then pres the alien
sedition act uh contest um all of this
then the war with the barbary states
then the attempt to use international
sanctions for the first time ever as a
means of preventing war is the reason
why a second term is such a
disappointment
because he thinks that the economic
warfare
argument that the boycott will embargo
will bring an end to the war between
britain and france and the
constant raids on american shipping and
i actually do think if it had been given
a bit more time it might have worked
but it's the first time anyone's tried
that
as let alone as a superpower
and then
in
retirement writing
more papers than most people could could
read in a lifetime
designing a wonderful library helping
out the library of congress after the
burning of 1812.
the university of virginia
and the jefferson bible
which i also recommend everyone should
get hold of a copy of you can usually i
think the unitarian church has published
a good edition edited by forest church
uh jefferson took
the bible in one hand and a pair of
scissors no a razor blade in the other
and cut out all the bits that were mad
or immoral
or mythical or self-contradictory or
other otherwise wicked or absurd leaving
him with as you can imagine an extremely
short book
but but quite terse and this this was
his contribution to enlightenment
thinking he didn't dare publish in his
lifetime but it was one of his that was
just one of his retirement jobs and he
could do it in all relevant languages as
well it's a parallel text
so
that's why i wanted to write about it
thank you very much it's been
enlightening um
i'm wondering if another reason for your
writing this might have something to do
with past being prologue
for the future i heard you say that
that jefferson
was in favor of
of exporting democracy through violence
starting a preemptive war
overseas without consulting congress
his attitude towards religion these
strike me as uh vaguely familiar
concepts today
um i'm wondering what what you think
jefferson's attitude might be towards
the current political
frame of mind thank you
well
i'm glad i didn't trail that coat in
vain
[Laughter]
first
well the thing about it is as you know
this pastor's prologue stuff is all very
well but it's very very difficult to
ask what anyone would do
um much beyond their own lifetime i mean
freaks i read a book about george orwell
once and i said he died in 1951 but i
said from what he what he wrote and
about from the topics he'd written on
i disagreed with mary mccarthy and
others who thought he would have
supported the vietnam war if he'd still
been alive and i thought i could prove
it because of what he'd written about
indochina and because of what his
attitude to empire
as well as to communism was i thought i
had a reasonable shot of saying that
that's only extending matters by a
couple of
decades really um
what he would have thought much beyond
1984 as it were is pretty important with
jefferson
therefore it's not very much harder if
he was to come back
the things that would astonish him would
be
most of all i think um what we call
mixed i think it's a silly term marriage
in other words he would be amazed to see
how many descendants he and sally had
um where they were living and with whom
and how many of them had been living on
the white side of the color line
since at least the census of 1820 all
his children by sally and she were
registered as white in that um
in that uh head count for example but
the extent of that would amaze him as
with the personality of american
womanhood there's something amazing
about his indifference on this point he
never says anything about the rights of
women doesn't seem to interest him at
all he thought they were great and he
thought they were doing perfectly well
exactly where they were
that would he would be astounded by
american
girls shall we say
the girls these days
and he would be appalled that we had not
yet conquered canada
[Laughter]
that's that would have really
you mean to say
that the the british flag still flies
over north
no i mean how have the young men of
america been asleep where is their honor
whereas their fire which is a
disgraceful state of effect
uh what he would have said about our
current difficulty i i really don't know
i mean therefore
he certainly he had had a warning from
ambassador abdulrahman of tripoli in the
meeting they had with john adams in
london of the menace of
radical islam and he'd been told in
terms now the koran gives us the right
to make you slaves or to kill you and we
claim it as a religious right that
uh on behalf of our kings i mean the
combination of the two would have been
very powerfully nauseating to him
obviously and so
it's yes one can extrapolate to that
i think use the term preemptive war
well you see as with iraq since they've
been fighting going on all this time
anyway never stopped
it wasn't even really a ceasefire in
1991. uh which the word preemptive may
be the wrong one i mean if a million and
a half europeans and americans have been
enslaved by this country it's been going
on as a regular business
stopping it by a surprise naval attack
isn't really preemptive in fact you
should be impeached if you don't do it
you have to be able to know who your
country's enemies are and deal with them
by force and with brio
um and that's what he did
um
but i know that that spirit is not the
current one
people don't have any stomach for that
many people in fact
rather as the greeks used to call they
were so frightened of the furies
that they wouldn't name them they
wouldn't say the furies they'd say the
humanities the kindly ones
call them that they might
make nice
or you know it's under the breath it's
like voldemort
people now say people call
mr zakawi with his plan for
an ultimate caliphate
based on the pitiless imposition of
taliban law and with the intention of
annexing and overcoming all of its
neighbors
and who uses the methods of beheading
and torture and sectarian
warfare and sabotage of schools and
hospitals and and even mosques
in pursuit people call him an insurgent
are trying to make nice with someone
with whom that's pointless so
i mean they're they're trying to hope
that we don't have to fight these people
because they're scared of them well this
is contemptible
and i i don't think i need to
uh jefferson's authority to say that
well maybe she wants to do it for
sitting down i don't mind
our friends from c-span need you to hear
you unless you go
sorry about that
just very briefly could you elaborate on
your knowledge of his poetry writing
when he started and over his lifetime
i don't know
i don't know any jefferson poetry
i mean i know that he had a great com he
had a great command of it
he'd be able to quote a lot of it from
um
from latin and greek as well but if he
wrote any i feel limitably ignorant of
the fact
he doesn't seem to me to have been the
poetic type i have to say
there is a sort of there is a ghastly
little
sort of sampler verse very near the end
of his life
i think it's inverse
it's a sort of very sickly
thing about about his dead children
being angels or you i can't even bear to
uh
think about it actually so
it's written to try and cheer up his
younger daughter about about her dead
sisters
um is the product of a weak moment
sorry i can't believe anymore
hi just curious about um what happened
to those million and a half people that
ended up in uh north africa did they
blend in with the population are they
some of them still enslaved
um
so we know what's happening with the
blacks here in this country what
happened to the whites that ended up
there
uh well there are a number of memoirs of
them
um because some escaped
and um unlike those africans who were
unlucky enough to be taken into the
middle passage and then to america
uh
dying in huge numbers on the way
and never seeing africa again um
these people could be ransomed a huge
amount of activity
in a town like this at about that time
there would have been at every sunday
service
a short talk about what was happening
and a
request for money to try and redeem or
ransom people because it was partly a
racket
it was partly a protection racket as
well you could you could pay not to be
enslaved if you were you could pay to be
ransomed but so some of them uh were
ransomed and we have extraordinary
memoirs of them
um off my the top of my head i should be
able to recommend at least one book
there's a book called captives
by a very good english historian called
linda colley who's greatly enhanced our
knowledge of this period i think that
that's gives the best account many of
them were put to work in the desert and
elsewhere and um
were
died as slaves i mean were worked to
death
um many died in jail where they were
held as possible objects of bargaining
and ransom they were kept in a cellar
until someone would raise the money for
them often they died for the
maltreatment there
some of them the young ones were sold
into into prostitution
uh into child brothels in the in the
ports along the north africa coast
and uh that's the story it's rather i'm
afraid as you would expect
there are i've noticed quite a lot of
very light-skinned people
especially in morocco and it's
conceivable that there's a certain
amount of that because there would be no
no prohibition of any kind
on intermarriage well not that there
really was in in america either in that
there was no at least no prohibition on
inter
i hate to say i won't use the word
racial because i don't believe that our
species is subdivided into race but you
know what i mean black white sex was not
illegal at any rate
at least not in one direction if you
follow me don't have to draw your
picture
uh there may have been some of that too
and with many we just don't know they
vanished they vanished
they vanish from history too until
recently
none are enslaved today is that so no
there is still slavery in uh in north
africa um
as before it's almost always
licensed by the koran um there's some in
chad
there's a good deal in sudan of course
uh i don't think it's i'm sure it's not
still legal in morocco or algeria
or uh
um libya or tunisia no but in the
the sort of saharan belt there is there
is a more than just people trafficking
there's natural indentured slavery yet
and those people would be the
descendants of the of the same
profiteers
oh well we know the names of the people
who became rich in west africa by
selling their kinsmen we know we know
what the family fortunes are
in west africa in a lot of cases in
particular cases of um the case of benin
for example um
so that if the reparations argument
which some people want to reopen which i
consider very interesting argument is
ever reopened there's a question of who
should be paid will be of course very
hard hard but possible to decide but who
should pay would be interesting too and
we we would know in some cases
which african potentates and which great
fortunes should be made to
to uh cough up some conscience money
so i say bring it on because it's it's
very educational in the unless i'm
mistaken most people in this room don't
know this already
my general experience is people don't
well it's true so it's worth knowing
um and i think it would it would
instruct our children in in what the
past of all this was
sir i'm curious to hear your your views
on uh the thing that uh was probably the
most popular uh thing that jefferson did
in his lifetime and enrich in retrospect
still doesn't seem like a terribly
bright idea and that was his embargoes
well i did mention embargoes a bit um
saying it was the first time that
anyone trying to use economic diplomacy
instead of warfare as a composition of a
dispute the the problem with it well
the problem with it really is the united
states has a coastline and a border
that's far too long
at least did then
um including with
the awful fact of canada that jefferson
resented so much but if you're if you're
in say
upstate vermont
and you someone comes around from the
excise man's office and said you can't
trade
this way anymore
because the president wants to get a
peace agreement between
britain and france and the united states
they're going to say well i'm just
waiting till you leave you know it's not
popular at all
um
he jefferson thought that okay that will
happen of course and people will resent
it which they really really really did
especially along this coast
uh the maryland coast but he thought no
never mind it will have a long run
effect people will start
going for what we would now call import
substitution they'll instead of
importing things they'll start to try
and manufacture them for themselves and
there was in fact quite a lot of
import substitution done people did
begin to to invest in the idea of making
it in america instead of importing it
an argument still goes on of course
but in the end the congress just lost
patience
uh it was too unpopular and we'll we'll
never know if it would have worked
the french the bonaparte side was
weakening at that point considerably
you know
payne and jefferson also discussed
setting up something like the united
nations
an international confederation to put
down
things like piracy
um
but also to avoid war
uh to mutually reduce the size of navies
to avoid wasteful top competition
and to try and open up spanish america
by getting spain to loosen its hold on
the
southern cone but
that didn't come to any come to anything
in their lifetimes either
please what do you think jefferson would
think about the iraq adventure that
we're in now
well would you
would let me see i'll have to submit
myself to the
safe keeping of others in the audience
would you ladies and gentlemen not say
it already i had already answered that
question
i'm relieved sir
pay attention in the back
does anything surprise you uh in doing
your research writing this book about
jefferson
any surprises yes
uh
i thought i'd knew
about the sally hemmings relationship as
more or less everybody now does there's
a small group that holds out that says
that the dna evidence isn't completely
conclusive because it could have been
another male jefferson at around the
same time around the same place
that's
may not even be technically true but if
it if it is
i don't think that it can
possibly
uh cancel the argument that my friend
annette gordon reed made in her
brilliant book which i strongly
recommend
it's just called thomas jefferson and
sally hemings
an american
story
is the subtitle
uh before she did all this work before
the dna test was run
and when you know that
sally was not just his property but his
wife's half-sister in other words sally
hemmings and martha jefferson have the
same father and grandfather both of them
english
white at any rate um
anglo
that she was a privileged house servant
who was in the room when martha died and
heard jefferson say
to his wife promise he'd never marry
again
that she's taken that they meet on
french soil
where slavery is illegal and though he
doesn't need any extra staff at the
american embassy he asks if she'd like
to stay and perhaps join his staff
and then his letters show
expenses for clothing for her and for a
separate place for her to live so i
don't think
i need to draw you one of those pictures
i keep mentioning
um the critical thing to know i think
and that annette discovers so
brilliantly is
uh when jefferson's little daughter died
he he couldn't stand it
um it had been so much death and he was
he said you must have the remaining one
brought him
in paris where the older one already was
he said he must send her over i i can't
bear any more of this i want to have
them with me
and he sends this to his cousins the
epsos who and he says you might send old
misses and he mentions some old slave
woman who's a stout respectable
person to bring the child across but
while the letter is in transit he
doesn't know
that this old this not old but older
woman has become pregnant again she
can't make the trip so he doesn't
without consulting him his cousins say
well the only girl we can think of on
the strength the only slave we've got
who could do it who's smart and bright
and so on and reliable is sally we'll
give her give the child a sally and go
across together jefferson meets them
not knowing who
is going to be escorting his daughter
and the plan had been for the other
slave woman to go home on the next boat
having delivered the kid he doesn't let
sally hemmings go home he asks her to
stay
and
though i defend him to the last ditch as
a secularist i here's what i think i
think that when he saw sally
getting off that boat he thought oh
maybe there is a god after all
that's what i think he said um
it couldn't really be any plainer
well you know so none of this really is
you asked for a surprise okay
so i felt i knew all that but what i
realized as i went through it and with
the help of annette gordon reed and her
extraordinary scholarship on this
is that we we're accustomed to argue it
like this would jefferson have done this
could he have done it so all that
partly with the rather awful implication
that
he wouldn't have lowered himself with
either a black person or a slave
depending on what attitude to jefferson
you take it would have been as it were
beneath him
um
gary wills his story and i normally
admire
um i have learned a lot from makes the
outrageous suggestion that sally
hemmings was a prostitute that she would
sleep with anyone on the estate
for money for which there's no evidence
at all there's nothing to support such
an appropriate charge
um
but what if as annette proposes what if
sally hemmings had a say in this
what if she thought here i am in paris
he's asked me to stay
slavery isn't legal here my brother's
here working as a cook
being taught to
do french dishes
um
it's a lot nicer than a mountain top in
album elk county virginia
the guy's obviously under pressure he's
a widower but he's you know still
as it were
he's still a man
i could do worse
it's an upgrade
and what she may well have said to him
is
okay
but if i have any children
they're not going to be slaves mr
jefferson sir
because that seems to be what the
bargain was because all her children
were free
his children by her were free and no
other slaves were and so was she
um and in law you can you may not say
that acting as if you've made a bargain
proves that you made one but you can
address it as evidence that a bargain
was made and if you look at it like that
and if you imagine her as a partner in
it which i think it's only fair to do
since she was obviously a very smart and
tough and brave girl
then you think well and this is what i
propose in my book well why not consider
her not as a buried scandal or as an
object of shame or disgust
but as one of america's founding mothers
now buried under the
under the
hampton inn i think it is a courtyard or
a modern courtyard in charlottesville
under its parking lot
uh but that maybe we could do something
about that
and the just cl in closing um
lucian truscott iii who's a direct
descendant through the coolidge family
of
thomas jefferson a senior member of the
jefferson family association meets every
other monticello he refuses now to go to
any more of the family reunion
events because they won't allow sally's
children to be buried in the family
graveyard on the mountain side
um they still won't but he has produced
with annette's help a book wonderful
book
of photographs of all of the descendants
uh all right across the country several
dozen of them we can trace
and um that's the perfect refutation
that book of jefferson's belief that
though the slaves should be freed they'd
have to depart from the united states
once they were free they couldn't stay
on once they've been treated there
couldn't be free black people living in
in the united states
it's the perfect refutation in practice
of the pessimism that poisoned his um
his life and that's such a blot on his
record
sorry for a long answer but a lot of
that was new to me as i hope and believe
it maybe to you and i thought it was
worth uh worth the speculation
mr higgins thank you so much for your
insights ah it's been a pleasure thank
you
[Applause]
for the next half hour signing his book
thank you
[Music]
no faith
[Music]
is
let's go
[Music]
christopher hitchens the first of five
authors will bring you today from the
annapolis book festival starting shortly
don van netta new york time african
troops are scheduled to leave darfur at
the end of the month and sudan's
government has resisted u.n troops at
c-spanscapitalnews.org our poll of the
day asks should the u.s take the lead in
trying to get international peacekeepers
into sudan's darfur region cast your
vote and see the results online and get
the latest from capitol hill the white
house and national politics capital
news.org a news service from c-span
sunday was the 219th anniversary of the
signing of the u.s constitution to mark
the occasion the claremont institute
hosted a conference which included a
panel entitled september 11 2001 five
years later participants include writer
christopher hitchens and william crystal
of the weekly standard
second panel of ours going
after a few brief introductions
good afternoon my name is brian kennedy
and i'm president of the claremont
institute
that last panel of ours was rather
depressing on the future of conservatism
i didn't think it would be the panel on
the war on terrorism that would provide
the
humor relief for today
on september 11 2001
america awoke from those lush times that
had been
the end of the cold war
the menace of soviet communism became
the threat of islamic fascism
of course the threat of islamic fascism
had been an all-too-real sideshow for
much of the cold war
but few in america seemed to take notice
whether we wanted to or not we had to
take notice on september 11th
president bush committed this country
to fight the threat of radical islam
and although we may be critical at times
of exactly how that has been
accomplished
there is the very important fact
that we have not been attacked here in
the united states
since that awful day five years ago
but we see from these terrorists that
they are patient
and current victories are no promises of
future success
and so we as a free people examine
current policies
especially as they relate to the
long-term security of this country
and wonder if the course we are
currently on will last in the future
just this week we see the debate over
how we treat enemy combatants
the republicans in the senate
led by john mccain wish
with every good intention to treat enemy
combatants
the same way we would have our own
soldiers treated
call it the golden rule of war if you
will
but the golden rule tends to only work
with civilized people
and when one looks at the radical
islamic world you see that it might be
hard to expect good treatment of our
soldiers
our american soldiers
men who are of the christian and jewish
faith
it might be hard to expect good
treatment of them
by their islamic captors
who when they are not mutilating little
girls
or sponsoring suicide bombers in israel
or celebrating the killing of americans
both on september 11th and today as we
fight for
the stability of iraq
which is to say we have an enemy
today that is yet to be defeated
the purpose of this panel is to both
consider
america five years after september 11th
and consider what is yet to be done
the members of this distinguished panel
are well known to the washington
policy community and so i won't spend a
long time
introducing them i will introduce them
as a group and then ask them to make
their remarks from the podium
we have with us first mr mark halperin
he is a senior fellow of the claremont
institute and the author of a series of
essays in the claremont review of books
and the wall street journal
about strategic affairs both before and
after september 11th
next will be william crystal
dr crystal is the editor of the weekly
standard
he is my favorite washington editor
charles kessler is my favorite editor
of our claremont review of books but
bill crystal is my favorite washington
editor
uh and there in the weekly standard he
has presented a most incisive defense of
the war on terrorism uh but also
constructive criticism were due
concluding will be christopher hitchens
mr hitchens is a prolific writer and
essayist whose work on the war on
terrorism has been nothing if not a
spirited defense of the west
demonstrating to many observers
that whatever our political differences
there is something at stake in the war
against islamic fascism
that should unite both the left and the
right in america
to begin this conversation this
afternoon i would like to invite to the
podium mr mark halperin
[Music]
how is it
possible
in 10 minutes
to address a war that has been fought
for three and a half years not only on
the battlefield but in every form of
debate
a war so bedeviling
that its supporters and opponents fight
among themselves more than they combat
the opposite tendency
a war that by the account of those who
think
that we are winning it
will also last forever
and a war that has divided the country
into more factions and variations for
and against than there are different
kinds of latte
well i can start
by pointing out that it is fortunate
that no one was able to convince
adolf hitler
to ramp up his industrial capacity
before he struck
to abandon his war against the jews to
treat occupied nations
kindly
and
to refrain from attacking the soviet
union by the same token it is
unfortunate
that no one has been able to dissuade
the united states
from adopting
uh
less than peacetime levels of military
expenditure while it is fighting a war
that it is losing
with forces that are proudly and always
kept at a minimum
with the political subtlety
of michael moore and on a good day the
rhetoric of lawrence
welk and with
ever-changing
and highly befuddled war aims that
finally settled
pachinko-like
upon the
the hallucinatory
and impossible project of transforming
by means of 130 000 americans who do not
speak its language
the political culture and thus the
religious law
of the most stubborn unchanging
and
and
fanatical billion people the world has
ever seen
i like the valley girl reaction to
something like this which would be like
hello
thus far
we have been relatively unscathed
because we enjoy the protection of a
shield which is the accretion
of
centuries of virtue and labor
this massive inheritance allows us
many
many careless errors and indiscretions
but it can be worn away from the outside
and from the inside
and even now
its many fissures and channels
permit penetration on a minor scale
by those
who have weapons potentially on a major
scale
if we merely
survive
on the mass of this inheritance
and loot the shield
it will shatter
the government
the administration
the opposition indeed
the entire this entire generation has
squandered the common inheritance
by foregoing
um
by foregoing
decisive
intelligent
firm disciplined action
in favor of half measures
procrastination for varication
and simple cowardice
they have moved us slowly and steadily
ever closer
to the line of fire
what what is our policy in regard to the
islamic war that has been repeatedly
declared against us
to the proliferation of atomic weapons
to the rise of china
to the
newly emergent pathogens
what is our policy in every case it is
weak
insufficient ineffective
blind unconscious
and confused
the west has strengths unparalleled in
history but now apparently neither the
heart nor the mind to use them well
this
is a
general and i think charitable
assessment
the specifics are far more damning and
yet i'm i'm still an optimist because i
know what we have and i know what we can
do with it
and that's all thank you
[Applause]
well if that was a charitable assessment
i
i don't
i don't want mark reviewing anything i
ever write
it's good to be here and i
pay tribute to the claremont institute
one of my favorite
west coast institutions one of my
favorite institutions in general um
in america and and it's honored to be on
a panel with
christopher and mark this is a very well
balanced panel
hawkish very hawkish and really really
really hawkish
actually i was going to say pro-war
pro-war and even more pro-war but i i
think i describe myself as being pro-war
at some point on tv at some some show or
other and then i got an email from a
pretty prominent uh republican
politician and a good guy and an ally on
almost every issue saying just a piece
of political advice you shouldn't call
yourself or call us by extension i
suppose pro-war miss the american people
are anti-war you don't want to be the
pro-war party you should be the
pro-peace through strength party
and i thought you know there's some
truth to that obviously no one really is
pro-war i mean and so i stopped using it
for
yeah well right
and i thought most of us aren't and i
stopped using it for a few days and
actually then i did start i used it
again and i just thought you know
there's something a little silly about
um being so punctilious and and we if we
are in a war it is not a ridiculous way
to describe the party that wants to
fight the realizes we're at war that
wants to fight the war aggressively and
wants to win the war and whose
criticisms of the current administration
tend to be for not fighting the war as
aggressively or as confidently in some
ways as they should as opposed to the
criticisms from the dovish side
it's not ridiculous to call oneself for
a war so i'm back i'm back on the pro
war bandwagon after uh a week of being
slightly deterred by this email um
and i don't actually think the american
people are fine with this and you know
one of the most stunning things of the
last four and a half years is the degree
to which the american people have been
more grown up about the situation we
face
than our uh political leaders who in
turn are infinitely more grown up and
serious that our media elites are
needless to say are academic elites uh
intellectual elites uh and the like and
um
what hopes as is often the case in
america eventually the uh some of the
elites at least will catch up with the
people and get a little more serious
about fighting
and winning this this war i'm not quite
as pessimistic as mark um but i'll give
you quickly my
my take on things um
i would say this
911 really was
is was and is a big moment uh it's
obvious thing to say but i remember on
september 11th five years ago
being here one block away at our office
i'd come in earlier that morning i was
actually having breakfast in this hotel
with someone when gary schmidt my
colleague from the project for the new
american century came down and uh and
told me i should get back i think this
must have been i don't know if this was
exactly pre-cell phone or maybe my cell
phone wasn't on i don't know why i
didn't call me but i walked over one
block and said you probably you might
come back to the office
something pretty amazing is is happening
sorry i remember that vividly and i
remember later that day talking
with my friend and a former boss bill
bennett on the phone who was also here
in town and i remember if we had sort of
a slightly bizarre conversation the way
one does when there's in a way nothing
to do you're all just watching tv and
calling other people to compare notes i
remember saying i mean is this real
obviously it was a big deal it was
terrible and it was we were going to be
a war that was clear to me right from
the beginning certainly with with al
qaeda and probably more broadly i
remember asking bill i mean is it really
a big moment i mean you know it could be
a big deal it would have real
consequences in the world you'd have to
go to afghanistan and get rid of al
qaeda it would change our defense
spending our foreign policy in some ways
but you know two four six years later
you'd look back and it would be fading a
little bit it would just be another you
know sort of big event that starts to
recede
into history the way 99
of the events in our lives private lives
public lives do recede and i remember
bill who's extremely shrewd about this
and many other things saying to me no no
this is really different this is one of
those very rare events rare in one's
personal life i would say in rare in
one's public civic life that will get
bigger
as we move away from it that the
implications and consequences of it will
only become clear
months or years later and it will look
even more sort of massive as a moment
a few years from now that it that it
does today and i i've often thought back
to that conversation because i do think
that's true it really was the end of one
era the end of
the 90s which in turn followed the cold
war era and the beginning of a new era
and we're five years into that era and
we've had some successes and some
failures or partial failures and and
some a lot of confusion and a lot of
fighting among ourselves and uh and a
lot of
unpredictable developments which is what
happens instantly at the beginning of a
new era that would be the one way in
which i'd be more charitable
than mark is i mean think of the early
years of the cold war i mean in
retrospect it looks
uh you know we admire truman for rising
to the occasion we admire marshall
atchison uh you know people rallied the
country marshall plant berlin airlift uh
maybe korea even because at the time it
was total chaos they were late in
responding to many of these things they
made huge mistakes
which led which had terrible
consequences um they thought they had
dealt with europe and they kind of
relaxed in 48 and then china goes
communist to 49
and uh uh anderson gives a speech sort
of suggesting that south korea would of
course not be a vital interest of ours
in 1950 and the north invades
i believe when north korea invaded on
what was it june 25th 1950 i think um
the uh the floor of the u.s senate was
debating the defense budget defense
appropriations and i as i recall um some
republicans in congress wanted to
increase truman's proposal from like 15
and a half billion to 16 billion dollars
for defense and there was a bitter
partisan fight going on with veto
threats and all this one year later we
had hundreds of thousands of troops in
korea a place no one had ever heard of
and defense spending had tripled and
this was five years after the beginning
four years five years after the
beginning of the cold war so
it's not unprecedented certainly in the
case of the us and in the case of others
that
we sort of
awake to a threat often a little bit
late
react to it with an odd mixture of sort
of impressive
achievements and total blind spots
have bitter infighting at home god knows
that was characteristic of this country
from you know 45 to about 52. um and
in that case at least end up adequately
confronting the threat i mean they're
real damage done by the obviously the
loss of china and the stalemate in korea
and other mistakes that might have been
made if china was a mistake but leaving
that aside
or whether that was preventable but um
real mistakes that were made early on
but
it's not unheard of to go through the
kind of difficulties we've had in the
last few years and i think it's pretty
comparable as a kind of historical model
and i think bush has mostly risen to the
occasion as truman mostly did and as
truman did has had odd blind spots and
incredible stubbornness about certain
tactical uh
choices and decisions and hasn't
adjusted to some situations especially
in iraq the way one i would have
not only would have urged them to but
have urged them to throughout but
um we are where we are and um
i mean i'm reasonably optimistic about
where we are i would say 9 11 was big in
two ways it was a wake-up call as
everyone says and there's some truth to
that and that's itself a big deal you
know a country that's awakened is very
different from a country that's
sleepwalking a lot of us i think
everyone on this panel really had in
diff slightly different ways
urged this awakening in the 90s
bob kagan and i edited a book
along with gary schmidt called present
dangers that came out in october 2000
warning that we were frittering away the
opportunity in the 90s to shape
a more
freer and more peaceful and more secure
world order mark wrote a lot about
defense issues in china which something
we also focused on christopher on the
balkans and other issues and the
islamist
islamic fascist threat to use his term
so um
i think in that respect it was a wake-up
call and the country got to where it
would have been nice if it had been
earlier
but it wasn't just a wake-up call 911
itself sort of unleashed a series of
events
that
continue to
move an unpredictable and
sort of billiard ball hitting other
billiard balls sort of ways and that
again is very characteristic of what are
these early historical eras one thing
happens it leads to another thing at
least another thing and suddenly you
look up three years later and you're in
a totally fairly well not totally but
quite a different situation in the world
than one had thought one was in in 2000
2001 and that really one was it in 2000
2001 was you then look back of course
and the sophisticated take on this is
well it was always that way the
europeans were always different from us
they were already post-modern
post-christian post-nationalist
post-military militarist military
militarist or whatever and we're
different and so that was inevitably
going to come out but it didn't really
come out much in the 90s in truth and it
only came out once this big event
happened and suddenly one is looking at
a 21st century in which europe is not an
important historical player i don't
think and not a key ally of the united
states well unfortunately in this
global war um and so you know our
relationship with india becomes arguably
more important than our relationship
with europe and suddenly once thinking
about these sort of big questions of
europe's future and islam's future all
these things that were not visible
uh in in in 2000
i don't think prior to 9 11 uh prior to
2001. so it's not those who say 911 was
big because it was a wake-up call or
right to a point but i think that
understates the significance of the sort
of sequence of unpredictable and
volatile events that were unleashed by
9 11 and which continue to be
unleashed as one thing happens after
another
this has something to do with the nature
of the enemy which is a jihadist
movement that is very
um aggressive
young in a sense
not like president of soviet union which
was not unproblematic incidentally as an
enemy either but where that was this 50
year old ideological movement that had
been in possession of a state for a long
time and had some entrenched interests
and bureaucracies and had reacted
against its own more vehement more
aggressive more reckless youthful days
but this is not the situation we now
face i think with the jihadists this is
much more in that respect it is more
like 30s it is a very
young aggressive enthusiastic movement
that feeds on success
and that can escalate or snowball or
whatever metaphor you want
much faster i think than people realize
and people who have lived through and
this would be true of me who lived
through and been involved a little bit
in public life in the late cold war
years and in the 90s are not well
prepared to think about what this kind
of threat is like how fast things can
change how one event can trigger other
events which can trigger other events
and you could end up two years in just
two years you know in a wildly different
situation than you thought you were in
time most of much of american history
much of world history you know things
are pretty stable there are these bumps
up and down but then you sort of regress
to the mean you regress to stability at
other times in world history of course
this is true in life in general at other
times a minority of times you get in the
opposite situation where one thing leads
to another a pebble leads to a bigger
rock coming down and suddenly you're in
a snowball effect and you end up very
very far away from where you started i
think this is that latter kind of moment
and it's not
most of us have not really lived i don't
think in that world or if we've you know
parts of the world have had that
character we've managed to keep them at
some arm's length and manage to you know
the big picture us
great power relationships u.s europe
relationships even u.s china
relationship in some ways in the last 25
years we haven't really had to confront
this kind of world and that is the world
we live in
the world of jihadism the world of
nuclear proliferation the intersection
of those two uh to say nothing of many
other things that are going on
so it's really
it's difficult to actually come to grips
with it it's not predictable
one can't sort of think it out as many
steps as one would like to in a way for
me that makes it even more imperative to
get back to basics and to say that being
strong is much more effective than being
weak the one thing we know about these
kinds of movements is they react to
strength they they pull back from
strength and they feed on weakness and
that's why i think
some of the
elements of weakness in our policy have
been so dangerous especially in the last
year and a half
my sort of 30-second summary of where
we've been is we were doing i thought i
think better than i think mark thinks we
were doing for the first
bush term basically there was some
progress dictators deposed i would say
the better forces in the middle east
emboldened and strengthened that
probably culminated in the cedar
revolution and the radical is not
strengthened so of course one can tell
somewhat back on their heels both al
qaeda itself but even the states that
sponsored terror and the states that
were
the one that were toying with jihadism
or funding it or in some cases uh
semi-jihadists themselves like iran
in the last year and a half for reasons
i don't fully understand
some of it's just i suppose the you know
cyclical nature of these things
i'd say we've been on the defensive and
if anything have been losing a little
bit and the jihadists are winning and
that is extremely dangerous and i'll
just close with this point i mean it's
iran
a regime like iran from iran is now
probably the center of gravity for the
next two three years no one says that
and of course in this kind of situation
pakistan could be a center of gravity
you know two weeks from now so but from
where from where we're standing now it
looks to me as if
how to deal with the iranian regime is
is the center of gravity and what's so
dangerous is not just that they may and
will get nuclear weapons unless
something changes in the next few years
but what happens as they progress
towards this
successfully over the next months and
years because every week every month
that our warnings look ineffectual that
our threats
are weak that are that we say we're just
using diplomacy no no no possibility of
force that their allies get away with
things and we restrain ours
in some cases um every time we exceed
them that has its own dynamic in the
region and beyond the region but
throughout the world and we see this
clearly in africa and you know east asia
even within the sort of the fight within
islam
letting so so the price that we pay for
weakness is not just that we end up five
years from now in a bad situation is
that we have five years of cascading
potentially bad and dangerous events and
some of them can be quite far away from
iran itself some of them could be quite
near like in iraq so
it's it's i'm very worried actually at
the current moment um i don't know quite
what happened there you know in early 05
that made
the administration
sort of change it what was i think
basically
uh an acceptably winning strategy and go
on the defensive uh when it was not
necessary when bush had won reelection
and there was plenty of support for
staying on the offensive to the degree
we were i don't know i very much agree
with mark on the issue of the underlying
issue of the military buildup and the
size of the military where it's simply
unaccountable to me how we can unexplain
inexplicable to me how we can try to
conduct a post-9 11 foreign policy with
the pre-911 size military and to some
degree free 911 uh intelligence
capability p911 diplomatic capabilities
etc etc were always slow to change but
in this case the early years of the cold
war were better the change was
the need for change was glimpsed a
little more clearly i think
and
and so that's worrisome but as i say
it's particularly the dynamic of a
radical jihadist movement thinking it's
successful thinking it's victorious that
i think is really the short term and
being seen to be successful and
victorious by others and by other fence
sitters and by you know movements in
different countries that's most
worrisome to me in this respect i think
the danish cartoons
uh
uh in brolio and now the fight over the
pope's speech are two will end up being
two very important markers
and very bad markers i'm afraid of a way
in which
um you know perfectly
easy tests frankly for the west to meet
which i'm very afraid that we're failing
to meet and sending signals throughout
the world that the uh the we're in
retreat and the jihadists are on the
offensive and that's not a happy
situation
[Applause]
i once um i once tried to add up how
long we had lived in the
post-cold war post-ideological combat
utopia
that came upon us in 1989
put an end to the long
nuclear and ideological standoff under
which i
and many of you had grown up
appeared to inaugurate an era bodied
forth principally by frank fukuyama
in which liberalism and democracy and
pluralism
and a version of the market economy
would be
not just the regnant but in effect the
only
model for societies there was talk of a
peace dividend if you recall
i'm sure someone must have said the
swords and plowshares that i don't
actually remember it
um of turning our attention to the
sufferings of our brothers and sisters
in africa particularly long neglected or
subordinated to what appeared during the
epoch to be larger concerns anyway
some of you will remember that euphoria
i calculated that if you date it date
it's beginning from
an episode that i witnessed which was
the overthrow
of the nikolai chauschesku regime
in romania
at between christmas and new year of
1989.
if you date that as the end of one man
rule and one party rule
in europe
um
then the
period of euphoria and the new utopia
lasted for about 111 days
after which um slovak milosevic invaded
bosnia
and attempted to annex it to a greater
serbia
and saddam hussein did not invade kuwait
as is often said but and next the state
of kuwait an independent state a member
of the united nations of the non-aligned
movement of the arab league
of the conference of islamic governments
annexed it to be the 19th province
of iraq at a time when we now know he
had the choice
of either developing his bomb before
invading kuwait or invading kuwait and
then
getting additional financing for the
bomb that he had underway he we didn't
know it but we were living in the hollow
of his hand we were also living at the
pleasure of people like salvador
milosevic
um while all this was going on
coming up on the inside track as it
might be said in afghanistan and barely
noticed by us
uh was a fusion of the idea of the
one-man rule and the one-party rule with
the one god rule
that makes this
this uh dictatorship even more iron and
inflexible and menacing because
like the others it leads to failure
state failure and like the other state
failures it will not blame itself for
its failure but will export this
violence and blame conspiracies of
others for
its own collapse and for me the special
symbol of that also took place in
1989 when the theocratic head of a
foreign state who just lost a war with
saddam hussein
the ayatollah khamenei offered money
in his own name
for the purpose of the subordinate of
murder
of writer of fiction living in london
who is not an iranian citizen a friend
of mine by by chance
very radical challenge i thought to
every possible value that's represented
by the western
uh enlightenment into a free expression
um
but what it seems to me that the
kind of muscle and sinew
that people are going to need to have
acquired
to combat the new form of
totalitarianism is the sort that some of
us gradually
rather randomly and haphazardly but
gradually did acquire in
realizing that the recruit essence of
ethnic fashion fascism in europe had to
be stopped
uh realizing that saddam hussein could
not be allowed to get away with the
destruction of another country and that
in the long run the existence of his
regime
the coexistence with it perhaps i should
say was impossible
and undesirable for the united states
and for the rest of the civilized world
to realize that
that the challenge from islamism was
mounting and becoming more and more bold
and promiscuous and being mounted much
more in the streets and squares of our
own societies v-day the fat were
promulgated in london and paris and new
york against salman
rushdie and this was the kind of
of
as i say fiber one
now i look back on it perhaps had to
acquire to realize
what was meant by the horror
of the challenge of september the 11th
and it's nice to be in a room for once
where people don't mind using the word
war even if elegantly shaded and nuanced
as by bill
because where most of the time i have to
spend my life is in places where people
have been war weary
since the late afternoon of tuesday
september 11th 2001.
now what i don't think anyone is quite
conveyed i'm going to have a shot at it
what was the quality of that shock
look
if you've been in sarajevo as i've been
if you've been in the scene of something
of the kuwait war the war in northern
iraq and kurdistan and so forth i had
done
some of that by then frankly the site of
seeing someone jumping in flames from a
building
isn't all that terrifying the fact that
it happens in america i think it's
narcissistic to stress
that kind of thing happens in a war has
to be expected if you're in a war you're
going to lose a building and a plane and
maybe a small town in a school room you
should reckon about once every week get
ready for it
that wasn't the shock to me the shock to
me was this
the president went missing
for a whole day
and crept back to washington and made a
craven speech written by karen hughes
that he should have retracted by now
that we were left under open skies by
norad
that we were betrayed by our
intelligence agencies the cia and the
fbi who hadn't bothered
to realize that incubated in our own
society was the deadliest
of enemies that these enemies were
further incubated by two state systems
that that of saudi arabia and pakistan
we've been educated by our elite to
consider as friends as moderates
a giant a gigantic betrayal on a on a
historic and colossal scale accompanied
by the most appalling impotence
i i can't i can't forget how helpless
the country felt that day
and how abandoned it was and i never
shall and i
don't think anyone ought to
be able to or be allowed to
uh you've all of you i'm sure read mr
woodward's book on um
two books on the uh origins of the war
and the consequences of it you where he
uh relies very heavily on mr george
tenet of the central intelligence agency
i'll make this my encapsulating anecdote
if you like um
you can always tell who's helped bob
because if if you're described as the
aspirant tough-minded son of hard
scrabble greek immigrants
you're one of his
sources that's the case with george
tenet in this case and um there are
other reasons why he gets
uh good treatment and why his quotations
are put in quotation marks quite a rare
privilege from wood wardiana well we
know what the first amount made by the
director of our central intelligence was
in the immediate post-9 11
epoch the first few seconds of it
actually because we know what he said
when the men run in men ran in to tell
him mr director you better leave this
meeting with senator boren
and it wasn't because he was late for
his next one and he had to watch on the
television what had happened and his
first from our first remark made by our
intelligence establishment in this era
we're now in was the following
ji said mr senate i hope it's nothing to
do with those guys in the flight schools
in the midwest
does this man deserve a medal of freedom
do you think on his retirement should he
not rather have been impeached
should he not have at least been
dismissed should he not in fact probably
have been prosecuted for criminal
negligence no
because it must not be admitted and
therefore it's left for us to face the
fact
that this is an army uh a fight that's
going to need volunteers we cannot in
fact delegate this
to our leaders or complain when they get
it
wrong it's going to call upon us and the
moment
i want to reach is this
is when in the arab press you start to
read worried articles saying do you
realize that our extremist policies of
terrorism and so are creating huge
forces of resistance in the west
we've really driven them now to a point
where they're ready to fight
people all over the united states are
signing up saying what can i do how can
i push back against jihad now look what
we've done with our intervention in
their internal affairs that's when i'll
know that we've turned this round and do
you feel any of you any sign of any of
this mentality
or self-respect or dignity in our
society i don't
but that's what i think we have to learn
how to fight for and we know who the
enemy is i'm not going to waste much
time on that
the vile combination of in islam of
self-righteousness and self-hatred and
self-pity
it's trinity that we see
every day
it's wrong for the president it was
wrong then for him to call it an attack
on america
uh to say that we were either with us
the americans or with the terrorists so
80 nations represented in those towers
that day
several hundred of my fellow countrymen
among them i refused to go to a ceremony
especially for
people of english descent because i
didn't want to go to anyone's
national or ethnic celebration it was an
attack on civilization itself that
should be very plain
and we should be very careful i'm sorry
sir to correct you slightly of saying we
have not been attacked since because if
we take that stand of civilization we
have been attacked almost every single
day since then
either in the form of our
servicemen and women in afghanistan and
iraq whose performance i think is beyond
praise
or the the attack on the uh
the resort of bali in indonesia tackled
holiday makers there the regular attacks
on jewish
institutions and places of worship
ancient synagogues in tunisia
in turkey
in morocco all of these countries with
governments that opposed the
interventions in afghanistan
and in iraq by the way
of the attempt to blow up the london
underground
a facility used by many americans every
day if you care to put it like that and
in my opinion most of all i'm touched on
was glad to see by bill
the attempt
in the fall of 2001 very underreported
in our press to blow up with a huge
series of truck bombs the parliament of
india the lok sabha in new delhi
that represents if you ever go and look
at it
in lawless splendor that the true
parliamentary consummation
of a genuine multi-ethnic multicultural
multi-religious uh democracy based like
ours on the rule of law
the english language
regular elections in the free market are
are in my opinion i submit future
closest
ally and a country with which we have a
great duty of solidarity every now and
then if you're like me and you go on the
air and you debate with some whining
self-righteous self-hating self-pitying
muslim
and you tell him what you think of his
quran and his prophet and so he said you
have offended a billion muslims you
noticed this you noticed that there's a
slight tone of moral blackmail here i
sometimes think
look if it was a matter of defending the
right of somebody to hold it in the
ridge's opinion i would defend the right
of a muslim if there were only three of
them
the idea of a billion is clearly
intended as a threat
it's a there's a menace to that you've
upset a billion of us you should watch
out
that's what it means and we're going to
try and move in
to your city and your country too and
we're going to raise more and more
demands that's what's meant by it but
what about billion hindus
what about bill and hindus who've been
declared anathema
who have been declared fit for slaughter
at any time at any place they're not
even monotheist
look what happened for example to the
nepalese guest workers
in iraq did anybody see that unbearable
video of the mass slaughter and throat
cutting of this hindus you have to see
it to believe it and the commentary that
goes with it too
and india is not just um
hindu there are more muslims living in
india
in a democracy in a in a serious
multicultural society than live in
pakistan we shouldn't despair we have
allies who prove themselves ready to
fight
now i mustn't trespass on the time i've
decided to borrow from the extreme
terseness of my two comrades here but i
just wanted to say
that uh those of us who thought it would
change everything were obviously wrong
for most of our countrymen it has not
done anything of the kind they want
reassurance they even take part in
opinion polls saying i want a politician
who makes me feel safer can anything be
more contemptible than this exercise
and we suffer like the sugar in the
in the kidneys of a diabetic as
as uh rebecca west called the
moral atmosphere of the chamberlain
government
uh from two very widespread illusions
first that we ourselves are the cause of
terrorism
senator harry reid i give you not at
right now i don't pick at random some
extremists like michael moore or ramsey
clark the the leader of the democratic
party in the senate says that yes it's
true that al qaeda is in iraq
the only time on which now it's
obviously there and has gone to all the
trouble of calling itself al-qaeda and
mesopotamia it's no longer deny that
it's there you notice
but it's only there because we are there
says the sound he said in in a reply to
a presidential broadcast it was not an
ill-considered
or off-the-cuff remark a prepared
statement yes
al-qaeda's forces are in iraq but they
are only there because of us
defeating the mind surrender
capitulation as well as a completely
false statement of the case as we well
know mr zakawi and many of his
associates
were in iraq long before the first
coalition
soldiers set foot there or an
alternative argument made recently by
maureen dowd in the new york times
that the problem is that we are an
occupation of what she called muslim
land
denominating territory by religion
clearing the ground on the new york
times op-ed page for the caliphate to
come well this is a
this is a pretty
dire state of moral surrender as well
and or
we're told that if when we could drop
the jewish state off the back of the
sled
they'd leave us alone
sometimes this is phrased as that israel
palestine is the crucial question of the
solution etc etc well
everyone should know and probably does
in this room but i'll say briefly
al-qaeda is an outfit that begins in
asia not in the middle east
it starts with trying to develop
uh by tearing out the territory of the
philippines
an independent muslim state in the
philippine archipelago it goes on to
demand the return of east timor
uh which was nearly destroyed as a
people
by indonesian occupation to muslim
indonesia
it blew up sergio villa de meleo the
great brazilian un envoy in baghdad
murdered him on his first week on duty
for in in revenge as stated by al-qaeda
for his role in overseeing the
independence of east timor in the
election that brought into
self-government
it wants to wrench kashmir away from the
indian union with the help of pakistani
subversion
if that was allowed to happen the
resulting bloodbath in the subcontinent
would dwarf absolutely dwarf what we
remember of the bloodletting of the
partition of 1947
48 and would wreck and destroy
the other great multicultural democracy
in and ally of ours in the world
it's quite a lot of concessions in other
words that we're going to be asked to
make
uh in order to appease these people and
to make sure they don't harbor any more
evil thoughts
against us in my opinion
half of palestine won't quite satisfy
them
and in my in my other opinion which i'll
share with you uh nobody blows
themselves up
in a jewish old people's home
on passover in natanya on the
mediterranean coast of israel proper not
in a settlement not against the wall not
an occupied country nobody does that in
order to bring about a compromise
it's just an instinct i have
i have the feeling that they won't be
happy until there are no more jews in
what we used to be mandate palestine
that's certainly what they say they want
i'm in favor of taking the enemy
seriously
to that extent
and
on this question of let's not provoke
and we're the cause of their reaction
let us just examine this for one more
second
all it takes
in order to get
the diplomatic immunity of a small
northern european democracy violated its
diplomats shot at its embassies burned
by crowds in this capital cities of
countries that do not normally allow
demonstrations
uh it's trade ruined its its economy
sabotaged its nationals and the
nationals of other scandinavian
countries threatened and killed randomly
around the world all that it takes
is the refusal of the elected prime
minister of denmark
to agree waited upon as he was by a
delegation of 20 arab ambassadors to
break his own country's law
and tell an afternoon newspaper in
copenhagen they couldn't publish certain
cartoons
that's all it takes to bring about
jihadism now that's the threshold of
provocation
now you have to be i think a real
masochist
to say well then we must avoid doing
this kind of thing because all they're
asking is that we change everything that
makes our way of life different from us
and then it's true i suppose there would
be very little to fight about
but in the meanwhile i think that we
have to face the fact that it's a clash
of civilization of course and about
civilization
and within a civilization it does
represent also where
i think it's nice to be able to know
a war within islam too where we don't
know how lucky we are
that fighting on our side are forces of
the northern alliance in afghanistan
and of the patriotic union of kurdistan
in iraq whose emblem i'm proud to wear
my lapel people who are fighting against
the dharma for us and taking heavy
casualties when we thought his regime
was a matter of indifference and these
people are just as muslim and have just
as good a right to claim
that they observe that faith is due
anyone else we should never forget our
duty of solidarity to them
and they are our brothers and sisters in
arms
and with the other victims of bin
ladenism and this horrifying cult
of death
and murder and suicide that says that it
loves itself
and it's cult more than we love life
much depends then ladies and gentlemen
brothers and sisters comrades
friends much depends on the multiple
ways in which we can disprove
that assertion and assert the power
of life and pluralism over over the
morbid
sordid a medieval enemy that we're now
faced with thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll take questions from the audience
and when you do ask a question if you
could do it from that microphone in the
center
that would be much appreciated i'd like
to start though and ask my colleague
mark halperin
if he would explain to us
what should have been done differently
and what
should we do differently from here on
out
as a way of
maybe trying to expand on your pessimism
well
what should have been done differently
starts
decades ago
and the the first thing is that
immediately upon the first terrorist
provocation
that struck us and you can go back to
the 70s for example the the murder by uh
fatah of our diplomats in the in the
sudan cleo noel and another one whose
name unfortunately i've forgotten
we should have responded strongly and we
should have responded strongly to every
subsequent provocation whether it was
the murder of robbie stethem
in in beirut or
anything that happened and we didn't
because we thought we could manage
terrorism it was clear then
it was very clear even if we couldn't
understand it we could have referenced
israel's experience
and and human experience it's very clear
that you cannot manage terrorism even if
the number of casualties
are minuscule compared to the
populations that are affected
but our statesmen in quotation
looked and they made a cost-benefit
analysis and they said well we only lose
50 60 people a year therefore this is a
manageable problem and we we lose more
people
choking on m ms than we lose in
terrorism so so it's no big deal but
they were blind to the fact that unlike
choking on m m's terrorism can grow
exponentially and that it represented
something
that was far more far more dangerous
than they thought which was the the
upward trend of this tendency in a
civilization islamic civilization
which
which had had was dormant really because
this war started a long long time ago
it's never ended
they think that it has never ended we
imagined that it had well the the
uh
recreation of it began
you could argue with the uh founding of
the muslim brotherhood
uh and and has has progressed ever since
we failed
multiply to to address
the
the attacks upon us to to uh hit
terrorist camps etc etc the second thing
is the question of of the
military
and its standing in our society we had
the peace dividend after the call was a
big it was a big mistake you had to cut
back someone
but not to the extent that we did
because when we did we simply asked for
it now if you speak to someone in the
pentagon they will tell you now um
because it's all top down and they and
they're watching their careers
no no no no
we have more than we possibly need we're
the strongest country in the world by
far we spend more and et cetera et
cetera but notice that we did not have
enough troops
to uh
contribute to the to the contingent uh
in in southern lebanon of um
in response to hezbollah uh we we simply
couldn't we don't have the sea lift we
don't have the airlift we you everyone
is familiar with the deficiencies that
the the the army itself has faced in
iraq and the fact that we only have 130
to 150 000 troops depending in varies
in iraq when clearly
more were needed to begin with both to
both to
strike the
morale of the arab world
in a quick uh sort of like putting out
an oil fire decisive move
and and and we didn't and because we
didn't
they uh they they learned the lesson
that they could oppose us
uh and and successfully
we don't have enough troops there we
don't have enough to cover our
responsibilities in the other parts of
the world which is why iran uh has
embarked upon the policy openly and
defiantly that is embarked upon now
which is why
north korea and by the way i think at
the behest of china
is what has been making a great deal of
trouble for us and even hugo chavez uh
in in venezuela
we we simply are overwhelmed because we
did not invest in what was thought to be
an unnecessary old-fashioned uh military
establishment
and
if you look by the way at the at the
claim
that
and the journal made this claim uh years
ago at the beginning with the first i
think disastrously wrong decisions on
policy in this war at the claim that
well you always make mistakes in the war
and let's look back at other wars and
see what mistakes we've made
that's true we made mistakes in world
war ii for example but we did win it
and that's a there's a big difference
there
and if you compare our efforts now with
for example the efforts in world war ii
look we have now as a proportion of gnp
we're spending
and of course the the left
and liberals and to some extent people
in the center object to this but we're
spending 3.89 percent of our gnp
on defense now
in 1945 we spent almost 40 percent of
our gnp in today's in today's dollars
that would be of four four five five
trillion dollars on defense instead of a
less than 500 billion dollars
uh from 1940 to 2000 the average
spending on defense as a proportion of
gnp was 8.2 percent in the peacetime
years not in the years of buildup but in
the peacetime years we spent 5.7 percent
of gnp
now with the war build up such as it is
we're spending 3.89
and if we had spent what we spent in the
peacetime years now we'd have a defense
budget of over 700 billion dollars now
you say what's the difference 150
billion dollars here or there but over
10 years that would be a billion and a
trillion and a half dollars which would
give us far more options
many more options in dealing with with
this with this problem
when people ask me well what would you
do now i feel very much like the surgeon
who is presented with a dead patient
it's too late the the patient not for
the war
in in general but for iraq it's gone
it's just totally gone
nonetheless even when confronted with a
corpse
a cadaver you have to have some idea of
what to do because you have to continue
and this is what i would say
first of all
we we must attend to the basic
weaknesses that we have that we have
imposed upon ourselves
by having a clintonian view of the of
military spending
we do need to give the armed forces what
they need in excess you see rumsfeld is
a businessman
and the pentagon is run according to the
business model the business model
is is based on the fact that you can do
what you do with as little as possible
and there that's how you get your your
your profit and that's how you're
rewarded and that's a good thing you you
use as few resources as possible to get
done what you have to do you can't do
that in war because you need huge
margins because of the uncertainty
the other business model is that you
want to keep your enterprise going
but you want to stop a war you want to
end it you want to win it
keeping it going is not something for
which you should be rewarded
well we should attend to that
the president should have gone to the
congress on september 12th and said i am
the commander-in-chief give me what i
need and the congress and the american
people would have given him whatever he
needed so we would have adequate
adequate levels of expenditure at this
point and and and even then
uh we have to correct that number two
we have to uh
have to instigate measures of
self-defense which are more inconvenient
and more expensive than those that we
have
i was in the israeli army in 1972 as a
as a soldier in the israeli army with
military identification and in uniform i
flew on el al from tel aviv to new york
when i got to the airport there were
army girls who were doing the
inspections
and i could speak with them in military
hebrew you know idiomatic army hebrew i
had my identification i had my uniform
there i was
and they pried off the heels of my shoes
because they didn't fool themselves into
thinking that you you can pick and
choose among the holes that you plug
right now
our airlines are vulnerable in a million
ways i mean for example with the new
thing about liquids
i'm flying to
paris tomorrow
and i read in the tsa
handout that i can take up to four
ounces of contact lens solution
because people
were agitated about it that's a lot of
liquid you can't take a tube of
neosporin but you can take four ounces
of contact lens solution
if i were a woman and i wore a gel bra i
could take that too
and that's because they think that of
course terrorists would never use
contact lens solution and terrorist
females would never wear a gel bra we're
completely completely irresponsible in
terms of that but in in more important
terms uh we we have to attend to the
civil defense in terms of pandemics
in in in terms of protecting uh various
facilities and closing the borders etc
etc which we have not done because
simply because it's too expensive and
yet and yet we have a gnp of 13 trillion
dollars
we have a a per capita gnp of over 30 of
the 32 thousand dollars per person the
people that we are fighting which i
which i think of as
the arab islamic world
and of course some some states are
more or less uh against this or on our
side just as our allies in europe are
more or less with us or not with us but
if you consider morocco algeria tunisia
libya egypt
syria
yemen saudi arabia the gulf states
iraq and iran even though it's not arab
that mass which is where
everything is in terms of this war
has a population of 340 million as
opposed to the population of the west of
more than a billion their gnp is less
than a trillion dollars ours
collectively is 32 trillion dollars and
you can go through these measures again
and again and again and what you see is
that we far overwhelm them it's only a
question of will
it's really just a question of will and
we we have been we have been noticeably
remiss in simply standing up for our own
self-defense
that we must do we must correct the
deficiencies and we must take the
trouble and the risk and then and then
move forward from there because
up until now it has not been handled
well
thanks mark
would anybody else on the panel like to
respond to that or should we turn it
open to the audience
okay yes sir
i have a question on will to kind of
follow up with that my name is chuck
devore i'm a california state
assemblyman and a lieutenant colonel in
the army national guard
and about a month ago we had a code pink
resolution
before the california state legislature
to request the withdrawal of national
guard troops
basically from every theater of
operation in the world
although ostensibly it was aimed at iraq
we defeated the resolution i think
mainly because the majority didn't want
it on the floor to embarrass all of
their candidates but what i noticed
was that the people behind it were the
same people that were fighting as tooth
and nail during the cold war and what i
find to be unusual and perhaps we can
get some commentary on this is that
those people of course had an
ideological common cause with the old
soviet union going back to the 30s
what i find interesting is what sort of
common cause do these people have with
the islamofascists
uh is it simply that they both hate
america and what we stand for
and because of that divergence in the
background
uh as far as what the islamic fascists
stand for and what the old mine
you know pro
soviet uh anti-cold war people had
does that give you any degree of hope
that perhaps the the opposition to this
war can't be sustained and therefore we
can discourage the jihadist by by having
better national willpower uh or do you
think that somehow we're in worse shape
than they were than we were during the
cold war can i answer that briefly and
then i'll pass to you
i uh
i i think that the the the answer to
that uh as
as always lies in
our behavior and our leadership
i think that it would be a completely
different situation
uh for example um between september 11th
and the invasion of iraq 18 months
passed
in that period in that 18 months the
entire arab world was able to mobilize
and the the left throughout the world
was able to mobilize and they they did
they had demonstrations before
even anyone knew the character of our
response or if there would be one they
were preempting uh us and trying to to
shut down any response that might come
and this was not accounted for or
responded to by our leadership if the
leadership is inadequate then you then
you simply uh don't have uh
the kind of reaction that you that you
need from the people it's all there it's
everything is there the uh
it can be turned around on a dime if you
had
a president who could marshal arguments
uh with with uh honesty and and good
rhetoric and was not stuck
parroting phrases
um
i'm
slowly becoming a world expert on on the
question that you asked um
i think i've by now debated
almost all of the
principal left
opposition types to the war not just in
this country but in in the united
kingdom um
in france in
brazil recently uh and in
germany not long ago and i can tell you
that
there are two or three strains in in the
argument and in the makeup of this
so deformed ideological alliance between
a certain kind of leftist and the
jihadists
that can be distinguished by strain if
you like there is
there is a group of people that's
frankly nostalgic
not just for the brezhnev period but for
the stalin era
um they're not that many of them but
they're they're surprisingly influential
in point of some
some individuals um
i suppose that instance ramsey clark
uh former attorney general of these
united states um
who was sorry
there's a lady in the front in some
distressed do we have a
oh it's all right
okay thanks sorry i didn't mean to be so
callous as to
talk over
an episode um
ramsay clark is it
kept going by a group called the um
i know the feeling
well if it doesn't seem unfeeling with
me i'll um
he's kept going by group called the
workers world party which um
split from the orthodox trotskyist party
in the united states because it they
thought that trotskyism shouldn't have
criticized the soviet invasion of
hungary that's to give you an idea of
where this party comes from um mr clark
has spoken up for north korea
he volunteered to defend the genocide
defendants in rwanda
um he is now one of saddam hussein's
lawyers and i was at least pleased to
see that
when saddam hussein was charged with the
massacre of the villages of
jail
jail
outside baghdad a few years ago ramsey
clock instead of saying he wasn't guilty
as charged said he was guilty as charged
and was justified in having killed them
because they were sympathizers of iran
in the in the war that saddam hussein
had started with that country
so you have a really really deep sort of
ideological backwardness and primitivism
of a very recognizable kind
and then you have people like george
galloway the british member of
parliament who was on the take from
saddam hussein's oil for food
program who's another soviet nostalgist
says it's the
it's the um
was the worst day of his life he said
was when the soviet union collapsed he's
been looking for a socialist fatherland
ever since
having lost the iraqi bath party now
turns up in in syria
uh and says that the hafez al-assad
regime is now the savior of humanity but
he made a most suggestive speech the
other day saying that
that the young muslim lump and
proletariat of the world were now the
great revolutionary force in other words
the working class having disappointed
him the prototype having disappointed
him and others
they found a substitute in this in this
force of um
what i think bill correctly described as
very predominantly youthful
um
resentful uh unemployed uncultured
uneducated people and those who
manipulate them so there is again a
direct line of contact there and then i
think i should just before stop to say
that
a more common and and slightly less
nasty trope is met but you can meet it
among many naive young americans on
college campuses
somehow to them the figure of bin laden
and people like him
have something to do with the third
world with with people who are oppressed
who live in
very poor countries
have brown or black
skin it goes to this feeling that they
must in some way be poor because we are
rich
uh it goes to a slight bad conscience
about the state of affairs in the in the
third world it doesn't know anything
about bin laden's role as a corrupt
multinational corporation which is what
he has been for many years they don't
know that about him they think who spoke
with the poor there may be some
borrowing when they when they allow for
his very very virulent islamic rhetoric
which condemns all their favorite things
such as gay rights and so forth
um a feeling of perhaps a displaced
liberation theology a cry for help
this is this stuff is a little harder to
oppose i find
um when i when i meet it but there's no
there's no question that it it does
it does represent um
the final gasp of the old left and it's
negation
and in my opinion it's it's mutation
into something that it would once have
had the morale
to recognize was its enemy
say a word i mean i i think the problem
is less sympathy for
the jihadists and more
complacency
self-delusion
uh appeasement really i mean appeasement
the more i've thought about this the
last three or four years i'm sure
there's been much better things written
about this than than i've uh that i know
of and i haven't gone back and really
looked at the studies of the thirties as
much as i should have david galerto
wrote an excellent piece for us though
on the church of england in the 30s and
then chamberlain and the degree to which
these were not you know most of these
people we're not sympathizers god knows
of of hitler or of nazism and many of
them actually quite the contrary but
fear you know i mean a combination of
complacency self delusion and fear can
do an awful lot of damage to a country
and it doesn't mean people
you know approve of terror or or or
think it's the right thing to do or
aren't personally decent human beings in
their life or don't aren't in favor of
domestic policies incidentally that many
people in this room would approve of i
think one thing we could see over the
next few years we've seen a little bit
of it but it's been somewhat suppressed
because of bush's position as leader of
the republican party and therefore in
some sense of the conservative movement
in the u.s
is conservative appeasement i mean
chamberlain it is worth there were
plenty of pieces on the left but it is
worth remembering that the chamberlain
government was a tory government in in
great britain and um
i i'm i don't think that's out of the
question either and that won't come out
of any sympathy for for the jihadists
but out of uh say a combination of
wishful thinking self-delusion
complacency but i think so much of that
underneath it all it sounds so
simple-minded to say well no one
actually likes to say this but a lot of
it is just fear not not personal fear or
a lack of personal courage by any means
or necessarily but a kind of fear of
really coming to grips with this
phenomenon and what it might imply that
one would have to do
the responsibilities the burdens one
would have to assume
not to the us and other nations as well
over the next years and conceivably
decades i think that's really um a large
part of the of the problem it's partly
an intellectual problem and partly a
moral problem you know and then they can
go together in a complicated and a
complicated way the other point i'd make
just and let's think thinking about
these remarks
i i myself is about analogies and i'll
just make it quickly i've used myself i
believe here already analogies to the
30s an analogy to the early years of the
cold war and you can't think without
using historical analogies but i'm
worried that
we could be just i mean i say this by
myself too that we're probably now
overusing analogies i do think
radical islam islamic jihadism is
something new and it's not something new
in the world obviously but as
the threat we now confront one of the
major for now the major threat and and
at the center of a
bunch of somewhat related threats that
we now confront um it is different from
communism
which was a modern rationalist you know
utopian
uh kind of a justification for tyranny
and murder it is different from
fascism uh which
was with which it has something more in
common i think in its extreme
aggressiveness and sort of uh
willingness to
kill and and to be killed in some ways
the kind of apocalyptic character of it
um certainly with that german national
socialism but even there that was
nationalist it was a it was pagan in
some bizarre sense um the real the
combination of islam the particular
religion of islam
and modern nihilism or fascism or
whatever we're going to call it now
which came together and you can really
trace the intellectual roots of this in
the early 20th century in various actual
thinkers and actual
people who who studied typically in
france for some reason and uh went back
you know the founder of the both party
the uh um and others and went back to
the to the middle east and uh were
inspired by uh romania himself of course
inspired by various um sort of
existentialist nihilist specialistic
thinkers i mean that combination of
islam and let's just call it modern
idolism
i mean no one's quite come to live with
this before at least not as a major
threat and i don't know that
i'm happy the analogies are important
and obviously it's stupid to rule them
out but i think it really does require
some fresh thinking about what its
character is what its weaknesses and
vulnerabilities are from strategic point
of view uh they may not be the same as
the ways in which the ways in which we
end up defeating this enemy may not be i
mean strength is necessary no matter
what no matter what enemy it is whether
it's a
communist dictatorship a nazi
dictatorship a chinese autocracy that
may have its own ambitions
a jihadist movement so there are certain
things that one knows one has to do and
i very much agree with mark on this it's
just as a matter of common sense and
prudence and building up one's own
capabilities and having an excess rather
than trying to do everything on the
cheap but but
as an analytical matter thinking through
the nature of this enemy and its
weaknesses uh and where it's likely to
go
that i think is a new challenge for us
yes sir
um
a lot of the questions i had in mind
have been answered to a certain extent
but let me try and push this further the
new york times had an editorial two days
ago
practically ordering the pope to
apologize if you read it
i read the new york times i come from
new york every day
but i i was totally amazed by it it's as
if they were in fear
if the pope didn't apologize immediately
and if i remember correctly the times
didn't
publish any of the
cartoons
and
in general in terms of will in terms of
will
internally in this country
it would seem
that among the leading institutions in
this country
there is a a a tremendous sense of
defensiveness
uh vis-a-vis
the islamic world
and the threat thereof and and part of
it this is i guess the question for mr
crystal and mr hitchens is
that is this simply going to be the case
for the forever in the sense that
it's a reflection of the you know
self-criticism that one finds in the
west and in our history and our
tradition and that in fact
given the kinds of
technology we have now
we are going to have to fight this
battle
with our hands tied behind our back in
other words there's no way franklin
roosevelt given
the bbc in instant communication could
ever ever have conducted world war ii in
the way uh he did in the way in which
the country uh won if
you get my point good question
bill
well it just uh i mean if we didn't get
into world war ii to rather late and
that had something to do with our own
blindness to what was going on and in
fact in the british case it's quite
relevant i mean the the british
um were the force
the leading establishment institutions
in britain were incredibly strong
proponents of appeasement and it took an
awful lot for them finally to be
discredited at least for for a while i
mean i think as a practical matter the
good news about the us is that it is a
very vigorous pluralistic democracy and
if elite institutions end up um
misunderstanding reality eventually uh
enough people get mugged by reality to
not to coin a phrase uh that other
institutions emerge and they don't
become they're not as powerful as they
once were the new york times and so i i
mean i believe me i i don't even read it
since it was just you know i saved
myself a lot of annoyance but um no one
has to know sometimes what they're
saying but um you know just so you can
find out what democratic politicians
democratic party politicians will be
saying later in the day but um but i i
wouldn't
i mean they are a problem but i wouldn't
overstate i guess the way i would put it
is i wouldn't overstate that as the
problem there is a majority in this
country i think that that if properly
led rallied and led is willing to do
what it takes is not going to shirk
our responsibilities in this in this
confrontation and
if the new york times is an obstacle
smart politicians will figure out how to
get around the new york times and and
there i think in some ways technology is
on our side in terms of the uh falling
declining power of the major media for
example
finally a bright spot in the
conversation
um well i'd unlike um bill i suspect i i
read the new york times partly if not
exclusively to find out what other
people think is going on
and where the reigning illusions are
coming from and i also check it's part
of the way i check my policy in the
morning does it still annoy me that it
says all the news that's fit to print on
the front page
yes it still annoys me every day just
then i turn to the washington post make
sure they're still publishing horoscopes
and i'm pissed off all over again i'm
set for the day
um and though it's true the times did
not um
publish those cartoons i think the honor
of doing that in the united states falls
to the weekly standard
uh
they did not uh denounce the cartoons as
blasphemous which was the line taken by
the vatican and by the bishop of rome
sometimes called the pope but by those
who presumably who are roman catholics
of which i'm not one
given the opportunity to condem
mayhem and violence against danes and
danish diplomatic missions and the
sabotage of the danish economy the
vatican took the opportunity to condemn
the cartoons as inflammatory and i could
have told you long before that new york
times editorial came out exactly what
would have happened about ratzinger's
speech in the regensburg university
first
someone would have to ask what on earth
possessed him
in addressing the muslim world to decide
to do so from the standpoint of a 14th
century byzantine
uh who was a death struggle with uh
jihadists in on the walls of
constantinople
who did what did he think would happen
if he decided to remind the muslim world
essentially the era of the crusades
who was advising him to bring up this
nonsensical dialogue we don't even know
whether or where or when it even took
place
where this emperor manuel harang some
innocent persian
i knew what would happen next there
would be a fatwa
or two
there would be
a blowing up a vocational church the
first one to go was a byzantine orthodox
one i was interested to see but no okay
and then there'd be more and more
threats and of course a random nun
murdered in somalia and then there would
be apologies first from the observatory
romano
then from lower officials and finally
from his illness himself and that would
be another great day for ecumenical
dialogue
i think i think the man has done a
gigantic disservice
he's made the muslim world feel
justified in his outrage by the crudity
and ignorance and philistineism with
which he spoke and he devoted the rest
of his speech to telling us to despise
reason
and science and the individual
conscience
in in preference to faith and revelation
science reason of the individual
conscience are the only things we have
left in this dark time so it was a lousy
day's work there is no way to fight off
one form of fanaticism
and blind faith with another
and this is as good a time as any to
point that out what what we're fighting
for is the defense of secularism and
that's that's the
seems to be the scene
of this as a cultural and intellectual
and civilizational struggle
i'm personally not fighting for the
defense of secularism but this lady has
a final question and we're going to take
that well it's fighting for your defense
then
i guarantee you those men and women in
iraq
do so believing in god and the truth
that that we've been a free people for a
long time not the ones i know and also
also i know a lot of determined atheists
in many folks also you cannot stop this
clash between islam and christianity in
which you have a billion adherents in
each one what what happened with the
pope may have been
may have been ill-considered but it's
the kind of thing that's going to happen
more and more
and and it and it has to do with
fundamental forces that go way beyond a
simple misspeaking or or attacklessness
and and you can see it growing
it will grow very fast and it will not
stop even if the pope becomes the most
tactful person in the world which i
always thought he was
this lady was very patient so i'm going
to give her the final question
um is it
a mistake to have tried so very hard to
make surgical strikes not harming many
civilians in iraq
i'm not sure we've got much credit for
it
perhaps it was the right thing to do
anyway but how much of a military
disadvantage did it put us at trying so
hard to be careful where we hit
uh uh speaking from a
i don't know much about politics but i
did a little bit about military stuff
uh i think it did not put us at a
disadvantage at all
in that if we can strike a target we
don't have to kill civilians who live
next to it
if we if we have these precision guided
weapons now and can use them to hit what
we want to hit that's fine now as far as
the the the terror war
aspect of it and intimidating
populations and making them shudder yes
it would have been
better if you can say that
had we been as ruthless as the russians
were for example in beirut when a
russian diplomat was killed and the
russian the kgb went and found the the
killers and sent their genitals back to
the parent organization
in their heads
in a box
that always does work and there's no
question that the people were fighting
respect for us but on the other hand
uh it's it's it's not a good thing to
kill innocent people what we lacked in
the in the military uh
initiative that we that we took in iraq
was a we didn't have a tripartite front
because the turks didn't allow us to
move in and this was obvious that they
weren't going to do that because the
the they wanted to get into the the uh
the eec and the and the french were
giving them messages that if you if you
let the united states go through your
territory you won't get into the ec
uh and
and and the islamic movement in turkey
also would have precluded that so so we
came in from only two directions and we
came in very very slowly uh there's
nonsense about how it was a record
advances absolute nonsense the israelis
in in less than a week and six days went
through gaza which was a highly highly
developed urban uh combat area and
through the desert against a vastly more
powerful force than what we faced uh in
in the third the time that what rumsfeld
said it was a record advance it's just
nonsense even uh
patton used to go faster than that and
trusca in in world war ii but what we
lacked was the decisive blow this the
shock and awe
that that would have done the trick of
what of flipping our enemies back into
their
fatalism and complacency which is
something that can easily be done
if you respond with enough force but
that force would not include the
unnecessary uh
death of civilians and there's no reason
why we would have to
have to abandon their precision strikes
for a wholesale bombing as in uh world
war ii it's
we wouldn't have done us any good in in
the in the military sense and and we
would have lost a great deal although
gained a little bit in a terrible way uh
overall
bill
we're running we've run out of time a
quick point from bill and we'll run in
christopher and then we'll wrap it up
um yeah i don't think the problem iraq
is we didn't kill enough iraqis is that
we didn't provide enough security for
the great majority of iraqis who
at the beginning were not interested in
fighting us and would have been happy to
have had more security against the
bathurst remnants and against the
jihadists and and now
if you don't nip these things in the
cradle they get much more difficult to
deal with after i want to say one word
about the christopher hitchens uh
brian kennedy dispute here because i
think it's actually not unimportant um
look the cold i'll now use an analogy
having said that analogies are
misleading the cold war was won by
people like john paul ii
undermining uh
the strength of the soviet union in
poland and by people like vaclav havel
undermining the strength of the soviet
union in czechoslovakia or throughout
eastern europe and throughout russia
itself it was one by socialists and
ambassador of there has to be an
alliance of secularists and
believers all of whom agree presumably
though on the fundamentals of of liberal
democracy and and human rights and
including the right of uh right of free
speech and the right of religious belief
or a lack of religious belief and it
really is i think uh i'm not even
leaving aside the distastefulness of the
squabble i mean it's not it it's very
hard analytically to even know which is
the more important frankly of those two
elements uh the good thing about america
is they seem to come together or coexist
reasonably comfortably most of the time
with some disputes on the margins that
from a historical point of view are not
really very important about you know
some first amendment kinds of issues but
i think this is really the case now
actually in this in this in this fight
i'm not just trying to be a sort of you
know nice guy who's you know reconciling
these two characters but i i think it's
important and here i will want to defend
rossinger for a minute against
christopher if you actually read the
speech it's a fairly subtle uh it's it's
doing more like what you want uh i would
say religious leaders to do he makes an
explicit appeal to reason he says reason
is something bigger than modern
scientific rationality he appeals to the
greeks he says it was a providential
fact that christianity absorbed to a
large degree the thought of the greek
philosophers and wasn't didn't go down a
different anti-rational path and the
criticism of jihad is precisely to say
that that unfortunately is something
that seems
at least some elements of islam seem not
to have succeeded in doing so i actually
think if you read rat singer's speech
it's a pretty impressive attempt to try
to say that on
secular grounds if you will a religion
that is tolerant
is
that secular should support
a religion that is tolerant against a
religion that is intolerant and that
believers should support societies that
are tolerant toward secularists against
intolerant religions i i really
recommend actually i just read it last
night i recommend ratzinger's speech
um
you kind of escape bill's attention and
i haven't kind of escaped yours just
this before it actually segues quite
well to civilian casualties that the
entire weight
of the roman catholic church in this
country and every other and in its
headquarters in rome has been deployed
against any resistance
by on the part of the united states in
the coalition to to the encroachments of
islam
just look at
the whole record since this since this
began it's invariable that the spokesman
for the church will say doesn't mean
their casual criteria for a just war
invariable the vatican has not endorsed
a just war since general franco invaded
spain at the head of at the head of a
muslim army
blessed by the vatican to overthrow the
spanish republic that's the last time
maybe they should stay out of the
business of endorsing wars
but that didn't prevent them from into
from having tariq aziz as a personal
guest of the last uh holy father to rome
on several occasions a leader of a
fascist party wanted for the state
murder of children
repeated private audiences in rome and
then taken especially to assisi
for further prayerful
uh sessions of brotherhood uh
disgraceful state of affairs these
people this this institution is not on
the side of democracy it's not on the
side of reason it's not on the side of
civilization never has been
and along with most of the christian
church along with most of the christian
churches the christian churches have
become a fifth column within our society
they have more in common with islam than
they do with us well no this got
interesting just here at the very end on
the question
now
hold on
only because only because the next panel
started 10 minutes well ago look up psy
hershey's article in the new yorker on
the decision not to blitz
mullah omar's convoy as it was leaving
kabul for kandahar the night the taliban
collapsed the whole taliban leadership
was in that convoy of suvs the pilot had
acquired the target as we say he called
centcom in florida the lawyers wouldn't
let him fire
um if that was those who care about
civilian casualties must answer the
question how many civilians have died as
a result of the failure to kill mueller
and his gang
being killed today those who care about
civilian countries must answer that
question christopher and i can agree on
that and on that we're going to end this
panel
we're going to take a uh seven minute
break and be right here uh back in here
for the next family
god
oh edmond morris on beethoven we
understand that edmund morris is going
to be playing piano during his uh
presentation
we are bringing you eight hours of
coverage live coverage of today's events
and bringing you a live talk with
pulitzer prize-winning author doris
kearns goodwin a little bit later she'll
discuss her book the team of rivals
about abraham lincoln after that dora
bush cook the sister of president george
w bush she'll be introduced by her
brother florida governor jeb bush
and today's events at miami-dade college
expected to draw hundreds of thousands
of visitors as i said 270 authors some
250 exhibitors the fair began back in
1984 drew about 25 000 people then
hundreds of thousands
are expected during this weekend
nice
all right i have richard standing right
next to me you want to put that down
give yourself some credit
you look great
all right well we got you all diane got
you all set up here
well you got a space there's more people
in here
and we're back live now preparing to
bring you a panel on writing biography
it'll feature author journalist and
critic christopher hitchens novelist and
national book award finalist francine
pros and pulitzer prize-winning
biographer edmund morris
this panel is one of many that are part
of this year's 23rd annual miami book
fair international
you wanna
um
once again we're preparing you to listen
to a biography panel with author
journalist and critic christopher
hitchens novelist and national book
award finalist francine prose and
pulitzer prize winning biographer edmund
morris a little bit later during our
live coverage of miami book fair
international we'll have pulitzer
prize-winning author doris kearns
goodwin she'll discuss abraham lincoln
and her book the team of rivals and
after that doris adaro bush cook the
sister of president george w bush she
will be introduced by her brother
florida governor jeb bush live coverage
of miami book fair international
continuing here on book tv on c-span 2.
oh
uh
so
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
i i'm very pleased to see you all here
for what's going to prove to be quite an
interesting presentation
uh while we were
organizing you saw us bring out the
piano and we hope we'll have a little
musical interlude
i want to ask you
to be sure that we don't have any
musical interlude from the audience so
please turn off your cell phones beepers
whatever else makes noise
and i hope that you've enjoyed the fair
so far
it's a
wonderful wonderful fair this is our
23rd
year i don't want to say best i just
want to say we're maturing beautifully
it is my pleasure to introduce a real
friend of the fair
james atlas of atlas books will present
our next authors
[Applause]
they're shy they'll be here in a second
i promise they've never done this before
yeah
first of all i want to say i i want to
thank
mitchell kaplan for putting together
this
astonishing
astonishing affair
we were talking before
uh all the writers who hang around
waiting to go on
in the green room about how much we love
to come here and we've all managed to
wangle invitations year after year now
uh
i told mitch i just have to come every
year until the end of eternity
and um
we get to sit around and and visit among
ourselves before going out to speak to
this very appreciative
public which always amazes me there was
an article in the herald in the miami
hero this morning i don't know if you
saw it all about the end of literature
by some very crabby guy who i hope isn't
in the audience and
who wrote for the herald for many years
about the literature is no longer
important and no longer matters but
an audience like this disproves it
and so i'm very grateful to have you
here it's hard to talk about this to
introduce this
these panelists in a regular
way with all their achievements
enumerated because
first of all if i did that we'd be here
for the better part of the hour while i
was just reciting their books
and also i know them so well i've known
them for
as long as i can remember especially
francine who published her first novel
judah the pious when she was barely out
of college and she was the first
novelist i ever knew first real novelist
and has been writing steadily ever since
disproving the
idea that you can't be but perhaps
single-handedly disproving the idea that
you can't be
a person of letters
in america because over the last
i hate to say this 30 some years
francine has written
many novels non-fiction
her most recent book just out which was
on the bestseller list called reading
like a writer
and uh
title makes it very clear what it's
about
uh and journalism essays and reviews and
i was just saying to her before she's
never
written anything
as a hack it's all excellent top flight
literary work
and she said the reason for that is that
she she refused an invitation from vice
magazine to write for them
and uh
so i also know them because
i'm the publisher of their most recent
books and i see these books arrive
at a certain point in their gray boxes
i'm always amazed these are always
professionals they turn in their books
on time
and they're excellent with edmund morris
we talked about this book on beethoven
for quite a few years as i recall
and
he is of course
famous as a presidential biographer but
he had a
great passion for music
and
had always wanted to write about
beethoven and nearly became if i'm
correct a concert pianist do you
probably regret that you ended up as a
writer instead
it's a terrible way to make a living
and uh
and uh so finally the moment came when i
invited him to write this book and he
drew upon a lifetime of
thinking about music thinking about
beethoven and wrote a really lovely book
and uh
christopher hitchens is
uh
well he's just a version
for those of you who watch tv ever or
read a magazine ever or frequent any
section of any bookstore you'll know his
work
last time i was on a panel with you
it was about saul bellow
hitch and
you got into a huge argument with
cynthia ozek about israel
so and didn't say anything about bellows
so i want you to stick to the topic
today the topic is biography
and uh
christopher has his next book coming out
should be very
bland and uncontroversial
god is not great
so we'll see that in may
if i could just say
embarrassingly a few promotional words
about this series
the eminent lives is a series of short
biographies
by distinguished writers on great
canonical
figures
in history uh religious cultural
literary political
and uh it's the sequel to the penguin
lives that i started a decade ago or so
it has emerged as a popular form
at least among
writers and actually among readers too
i'm glad to say because
while taking a break from the monolithic
works that they write
they're encouraged to write a short book
of 40 or 50 000 words that just
engages them in a very different way and
that uh that
brings that enables them to write about
uh
what i would call
an obsession of theirs it comes very
easily to them when i ran into francine
at a at a book fair somewhere when i was
just starting this series
i said who would you like to write about
it and without any hesitation she said
caravaggio
and uh it was the same with edmund and
beethoven and with
christopher as he just reminded me
i came up with the idea of
thatcher for some reason
and
he wasn't too keen on that
and
then i came up with the idea of
jefferson and that seemed to be just
right for him
uh
so
and he did a uh
marvelous book in the space of some
months i don't quite know how
uh
just if i could say one more word about
these
short biographies
it's a it's a form that emerges out of a
tradition of english literature that
begins with samuel johnson's lives of
the poets
and continues on through written
strategies eminent victorians
also the book that i was reading when i
thought up this idea when i was on page
a thousand of my own biography of
zolbello
i thought there's got to be some other
way to do this as reading a short
biography by macaulay on boswell
and it's a very
congenial form so i'd like to begin by
asking each of you
uh
what the experience was like of of
writing a short biography and
what it was that impelled you to this
subject and then we can focus on some
other issues related to biography so i'm
going to sit down and
let christopher speak further
[Music]
[Applause]
well i just wondered if it wouldn't be a
good moment to say all the things that i
had meant to say about solbello
no i said them all i can remember it no
i can remember what i fully intended to
say uh well i think it's it is in fact
uh lord byron who says of uh the span of
uh
species the span of a human life he said
is like the summer of a of a doormouse
and one of the things i find reading
most biographies um
though not in writing the one i did is
is the discovery that you're bound to
make of how few years
in most people's lives are worth
paying any attention to how many of them
are well spent
or interesting or rewarding either for
them or for
anybody else but the doormats problem
doesn't come up in the case of
our third president thomas jefferson
because and it also
this is an additional reason why it was
a very challenging project
he lived to be well over 80 as you know
um
for more than
more than 20 years nearly 25
continuously he was actually in power
once he goes off to be
our minister in paris um
until the end of his second term as
president he's almost permanently at the
very center of of power that's not true
of george washington for example
it's not true of abraham lincoln it's
not true of franklin delano roosevelt to
have this extraordinary span of time
at the head of the nation's affairs and
that's after he's
been governor of virginia
um author of the declaration
of independence and is before he does
the jefferson bible
which if you don't know
i'll just tell you consists of taking
the new testament in one hand and a
razor blade in another
and cutting out all the bits that are
either wicked or fanciful or stupid or
incredible or mythological
or absurd or contradictory leaving you
with a very slender book
which you can still get for free from
the unitarian church but which used to
be given to all members of congress as a
present the first day they showed up for
work
so it's an extraordinary life and the
the job of condensation was extremely
difficult for me
but very fascinating because the reason
i said yes to jim
as soon as he asked me was well of
course i will because whatever else one
is writing about
one is always writing about thomas
jefferson at least when you're writing
about the united states which is the
great subject for any writer you're
writing about him because of
nation-building
because of constitution writing because
of
um
their concept of america as an empire
because of american expansionism because
of the idea of democracy and of course
because of the theory and practice
of slavery and because of the wall of
separation between
church and state every anytime you are
we care to speak or choose to dilate on
any of these topics we're
we're talking about thomas jefferson and
thus i would i decided i would call the
book
or the author of america
in that america is itself a written work
in progress it's based on
written documents which are subject to
revision um and are and have been
very importantly and very dramatically
revised and that's the other reason that
why america is such a great subject
for a writer because it's it's a written
and a writerly enterprise
to begin with um i shouldn't trespass
much more on
the answers of the first question say
one thing i think maybe conceivably too
one is
last time i did a panel on this michael
corder was among was of the company he
said here's one thing a biographer must
never do
you must never say about some
contingency or some conjunction well at
this moment
so-and-so must have thought or must have
felt or never do that never make that
assumption you're not entitled to it you
don't know that
you shouldn't pretend that you do even
if you think you know more about the
subject than anybody else and i i
heartily concurred and i thought it was
completely right i'd heard the thought
before had the thought
myself except that i realized that
when thomas jefferson saw sally hemmings
not for the first time because she was a
little girl but for the second time
when she showed up in her early teens in
france
i think he thought and to himself and
said to himself possibly for the first
and only time there is a god
[Laughter]
aside from that
i think my my summary injunction would
be about the letter to the baptists of
danbury connecticut
in which the wall of separation is first
uh suggested because they wanted
protection by the way guests from whom
the baptist of danbury connecticut who
do they want protection from
the congregationalists of danbury
connecticut
that's why a secular state is necessary
to guarantee religious pluralism so i'll
just end by saying mr jefferson
build up that wall thank you
thank you
[Music]
edmund
or next
well
i must say i identify with thomas
jefferson and sally hemmings because
this morning in the elevator
meg tilly
spoke to me
and i knew without doubt that the
contrary to what christopher will be
saying in his up forthcoming book there
is a god
i fell in love with her when i first saw
the big chill
15 20 years ago and she's as beautiful
now as she was then and she's appearing
i believe at this festival at two
o'clock this afternoon
so that's made the journey worthwhile
if nothing else for me
jim passed over rather briefly that
protracted negotiations which produced
my little biography of beethoven
he indeed came to me and said you want
to write one of these short biographies
and i said yes and i'd
rather like to do one about ludwig van
beethoven
he said well it's going to be a
difficult sell you know to my backers
because books on composers don't do all
that well
and he went to talk to his backers and
surely enough
he came back and said i'm sorry they
don't want to do it.
he said do you want to do anyone else
i said oh all right
how about ingmar bergman
he said well he's kind of swedish and i
don't know
[Laughter]
sort of passe
so i said all right i'll do evil in war
what about that
i said well he's kind of english
so i walked off in a huff
and a year later he came back he said
you still want to do beethoven i said
yes please
so we hauled out this contract
for 250 dollars and um
unscrewed his fountain pen he said now
before i sign it what will the
subtitle be
i said subtitle are you kidding
beethoven needs a subtitle
he said well it's the format of the
series we've got to have a subtitle
well i needed the 250 bucks
[Laughter]
so i said all right what about beethoven
deaf but not dumb
[Laughter]
which for a moment i think he took
seriously but we compromised eventually
on beethoven the universal
composer
i called him the universal composer
because
of all the great
composers beethoven is the only one
whose popularity
uh has increased
uh right from the moment he was first
recognized as a composer of the first
quality
in vienna
in the late 18th century
beethoven's fame grew and grew and grew
through his own lifetime
he lived just 56 years
and it continued to mushroom after his
death
unlike johann sebastian bach who was
largely forgotten
after his death for half a century
unlike mozart
who was prettified by the victorians and
miniaturized
unlike all the other great composers one
can think of beethoven's reputation has
continued to increase
at a proportionate
rate
ever since his death in 1827.
last year the bbc
radio third program in britain
for the first time in its history
did a two-week
wall-to-wall uh 24-hour a day
symposium on beethoven playing all his
works
interspersing lectures and readings
and during the course of this beethoven
fortnight as they called it there
reviving the beautiful old english word
fortnite um they offered free downloads
of any beethoven symphony to any lister
around the world
and they got one and a half million
downloads
most of which came in from asia
which proves i think that beethoven
speaks loudly more loudly now than he
has ever done in the past and uh
the universal quality that speaks to us
that speaks to the chinese that speaks
to africans
um
is particularly vital now because we
live in a world which seems to be
increasingly a world
consisting of chaos
to use a phrase of even wars
it is chaos that shrieks about our ears
and in a chaotic
time such as the one we live in
beethoven's philosophy of
struggle
all his great works all his works
synthesize chaotic elements bring them
together with the superhuman strength
pull them apart
force them together again
into a resolution
at the climax of the work which seems to
be
elemental
indestructible
beethoven speaks to us
in this constructive language
more powerfully today than ever before
a case in point
even though it's somewhat dated
uh occurs in the prologue to my book
where i used an incident
um in february of 1978.
i happen to be up at harvard
um researching um my book on theodore
roosevelt when
massachusetts disappeared under the
worst blizzard in its history
they still talk about it to this day for
three or four days the entire state and
most of the northeast
was inundated
in a weight of snow the whole state was
paralyzed no light no power no food no
movement no sound
and on the third day of this paralysis
the sun
finally came out
and students emerged from the buildings
in harvard yard began to ski
across the six foot deposit of snow
and the sun was shining in the air was
bright
i stood up to my hips in snow watching
this
return of life
and some anonymous person
threw open the windows of his dorm
room
put a pair of stereo speakers on the
windowsill
and blasted out into the sunshine
the finale of beethoven's fifth symphony
[Music]
and everybody stood
transfixed
for the 10 minutes that this music
lasted
and when it ended with 48
thunderclaps of c major
quite a few of us were crying
it just seemed i don't know what
possessed this person to play that music
but nothing so perfectly expressed the
feeling we all shared
look
we have come through
we were buried we have emerged
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
edmund
i don't dispute your account of what
actually happened
you don't i can't because it's true
but the
the problem is that
it shows me
how
difficult it is to know or remember
anything about anyone or any event that
happened which is a real liability for a
biographer
and
but i'm sure but everything you did say
was was true and i've managed to allied
that into
uh
i suggested
or came to edmond and asked him who he
wanted to do and he said beethoven and
that was that and it's kind of easier
that's why i like these short
biographies you just can leave out all
the things that you forgot or that
traumatized you or that you don't want
to write about
francine
one of the reasons that i was drawn to
the form of a short biography or or to
be i guess you could say a short
biographer uh was that i have many close
friends jim included who were who are
long biographers and and i saw over the
years how they suffered
the years
it took the disenchantment the work the
doubts and and above all what i noticed
and jim
may be an exception was was how rarely
by the end of the project
their enthusiasm and their affection for
their subject had persisted through the
project um often they just
hated the person they were writing about
by the end of the biography
and i would have hated for that to
happen
for me with caravaggio because he
is and
was and
i am happy to say continues to be my
favorite painter i mean i came to the
book out of a great passion for
caravaggio's work and and also as i
noticed when i would go to see museums
here and uh churches in europe there
were always crowds in front of his
paintings and and i began to realize uh
that that passion was shared in that he
seemed to be an extremely modern painter
since edmund has told his celebrity
proximity story
i'll tell mine which was i gave a talk
about caravaggio at the metropolitan
museum
about six months ago and uh
the actor who played furio and the
sopranos
was there and came and got his book
signed and um and said that i'd done a
very good portrait of naples from where
he came and i thought that's it i can
just quit right now
the other thing about caravaggio was
that was that
he seemed to be a perfect subject for a
brief life because he had such a brief
life himself he only lived to be 39
years old
and it was a it was a life that was
perfect for a novelist to write about i
mean he was not only a genius and a
great artist but he was also
a criminal and a murderer and he was um
he committed a murder
uh several years four years before he
died and then was on the run for the
last four years of his life and his life
was
the most dramatic i mean just telling
the story of his life was was incredibly
um satisfying for a novelist uh just
i'll conclude by telling you that
a story that to me
illustrates the the extent to which my
affection for caravaggio continued to
the end and through the end of the
project
uh about a year ago i was in rome and uh
at a dinner party and it was a very long
dinner party at which many many bottles
of wine were drunk and uh and and the
other guests were all russian painters
so as you can imagine after the wine
then a bottle of vodka was suddenly
produced in tequila and so forth which
may explain why uh
at some point i found myself having a
conversation with a friend of mine a
russian painter
about which was the greater artist mel
gibson or caravaggio
[Laughter]
and my friend matfay said okay i'll give
you this he said mel gibson was a bad
artist
and caravaggio was a great artist but
they were both interested in violence
and
and i kind of got on my high horse
and i said
yes well mel gibson was in favor of care
of capital punishment and caravaggio
was not
[Laughter]
and my friend said
yes but mel gibson didn't actually kill
somebody
and caravaggio did
and i said
he did
i'd written the book i knew perfectly
well that he did i had written in detail
about the murder but by then
still my love for caravaggio was so
intense that the fact that he was a
murderer had just somehow gone out of my
mind
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
francine in regard to your comment about
how one ends up
hating one's subject if you write a very
long biography
let me just
say as as a
as a perpetrator of one of these books
that
if you spend
12 hours a day for 10 years with your
subject which is far in excess of what
you spend with even your child or your
spouse
you end up having a real problem no one
should know anyone that well it's a real
liability
but you know
one thing i want to to
discuss was
the
relationship
of the biographer
to the subject
i was talking to
edmund at the uh while we were waiting
to go on here
uh this morning
about his biography of reagan which i
think is just a fantastic book and was
praising
mightily
[Music]
and i'm i i recall that there was a
traumatic
moment when reviewers protested the fact
that edmund had put in a fictional
character to this
otherwise
incredibly vivid non-fictional
narrative
and he said
we all all biographers
put in this fictional character
only he did it explicitly
and i found that fascinating i wonder if
you could expansion on that a little bit
because what you meant of course was
that we
that the biographer has a point of view
whether it's acknowledged or not in a
very strong point of view
well the biographer does um in effect
become
[Music]
an observer of a participant in the life
of his or her subject um
as francine just um indicated sometimes
the relationship becomes
quasi-amorous
uh
not in my case
sometimes it's quite the the contrary
the the the relationship becomes so
fraught as with the example of lawrence
thompson and robert frost where during
the course of three volumes he
discovered
that this man he worshipped so much was
a monster
and the more he read frost's
letters
the more he detested him so the book
the volume the third volume becomes a
diatribe which is almost unreadable
the emotional um
question had become so high so we all
become involved in the lives of our
subjects
and the ideal biographical stance
is one of
mild affection
love is dangerous hatred is is poisonous
but some affection mild affection should
be there otherwise it's not much fun to
spend seven or 14 years
in the company of this person
also going through the letters of
interviewing the children of
studying the the life of listening to
the recordings of
this person
one becomes
almost a participant in the life
i happen to be a participant in reagan's
life in the sense that i was
able to go to the white house during his
presidency and be with him and interview
him and observe him and
follow him around and i developed a
closeness of of of of pov of the point
of view that
was so close
that i began to feel the absence of that
closeness when i went back to earlier
parts of his life when i wasn't actually
there
so i decided to
do
to make explicit what is implicit in all
biographies and that is
put my
self in the form of a fictitious
observer
into reagan's early life
a person of whom he was always unaware
as reagan tended to be of everybody
and um preserve this closeness of you
all the way through
it was a technique that i realized would
be controversial and it certainly didn't
prove to be so but i do think that um
it was an honest um device
and i'm
kind of
um encouraged to notice that other
writers have
have have
moved in similar directions since for
example
andrew motion who's the poet laureate of
great britain
uh after dutch was published came out
with a book
on thomas wainwright the romantic poet
who
was involved in a murder case and was
transported to australia and andrew
mercian wrote this very scholarly book
as an autobiography
it's written in wainwright's own voice
and the end of every chapter andrew
motion gets into a debate with his
narrator
so it's a post-modernist technique that
i think is honest and exciting and i
think it'll be followed by more such
experiments
yes you know uh peter aykroyd in his
biography of dickens where he that's
right emulates
dickens and converses with dickens and
uh
it's it's uh
another way of of approaching the
subject in some ways enviable because
you can just make it up
christopher
well i think it's um
it's not so necessary even to uh affect
uh neutrality for example
thomas carlyle when he set out to
do cromwell was
self-consciously trying to do a rescue
operation on a reputation he said
dragging him out as he put it from
underneath a
heap of dead dogs
and um carrion in order to sort of dust
him down and dispel this
terrible cloud of slander that had
accumulated and i think in isaac
deutscher's wonderful three-volume
biography of leon trotsky he i'm fairly
sure he starts by saying he wants to do
tronsky what what carlyle did for
cromwell and as long as this is openly
admitted i think that's perfectly
fine i only knew it from the opposite
standpoint because
um
one of the reasons i
said no to your proposal about thatcher
was that it
had when young had a very very brief
very unsatisfactory sexual encounter
with her
but i wasn't completely certain that
this wouldn't sort of change the whole
thing
but the other time that i had to do a
study of a of a person there's a living
one it wasn't exactly a biography but
it's an extended political profile and
and inquiry
into um
the life and indeed the crimes of henry
kissinger
and by the time i was finished with that
i felt as though i got gangrene
um i can tell you if you if you so to
speak get up in the morning with henry
and then go to bed still thinking about
him over an extended period it will make
you sick
and
when people come to me and ask me to
sign the book and say they want to read
or they have read i said did it make you
feel ill
that's my test for this but have i
passed on at least some of the feeling
of nausea and disgust and usually yes
i have managed to offload
some of it but it's written i must tell
you with a tone of perfect detachment
and neutrality
as always as with you
[Laughter]
uh
you know it uh
i didn't know about thatcher by the way
that's
uh let's tell you sometime
you know uh it it occurs to me thinking
about our
three
biographers here that that your subjects
and by the way you've also you
wrote about kissinger with distinct
antipathy but with great sympathy for
orwell and and jefferson your two other
subjects uh yes i have an answer now to
the i used to get approached by motherly
ladies
in bookstores when i did signings they
would be worried and they'd come up to
me and say we you know don't you like
anybody
as if i was so secretly unhappy and
venting no no look i've written all
these furry books about people who i
like and i think are sweet
yeah but christopher let's not
forget about mother teresa this is a guy
who did a tear down job on mother teresa
well the [ __ ] had been asking for that
for a long time
it's an easy target
i said she's an easy target
but uh
god i didn't know this was going to turn
into a sitcom here this morning
i feel like i have seinfeld up here
but uh
in any event one of the things that
interested me about your among the many
things about your biography of of
jefferson was that
you have a great
love affair with
america
and have written
many essays about that and of course you
you
view this from the perspective of
of an expatriate who has now become an
american citizen is that right
and so i always think
that that there is some
very distinct
vantage point of view
that enables one to
as it were
solve problems solve issues express
issues in your own
life without being too
freudian about it
but but francine's subject is also
very different from anything you've
written and uh edmunds emerges out of
your your lifelong passion for music it
interests me
uh that you that you chose these
subjects why why is it what is the
appeal of someone who is
so
far in a way from your own experience
and yet answers so deeply to questions
in your own life
maybe you could address that first
well
um it's true that if one's when
one believes as i do
i've come to believe that the american
revolution is the only revolution left
the only one still standing
there anyone with any life or vigor in
it the only one that could be emulated
with profit by another culture or
another people
then it is very important to understand
what the theory of that revolution was
and it's best articulated
by well by thomas jefferson and by my
next subject um thomas paine
who was a great englishman
as well as a great american
that's
that's really what fascinated me about
them and then of course you have to
try and see it from the point of view
that they uh they did which is
the first people really we know about
ever in history to be to be given a new
canvas with which to start
uh the contest due to said to thomas
jefferson that she
hugely envied him because the
revolutionaries in france had this organ
stable of misery
and poverty and hatred and repression
and exploitation that they had to clear
and the united states revolutionist
didn't have that they could begin de
novo
and that was that was the wonderful
refreshment of the american revolution
then of course
if you don't say this someone's going to
ask you well what in that case what
about slavery what about if you like the
original sin or the
the original stain and i suppose the
saddest thing for me writing about the
book writing the book writing about
jefferson i mean
because of course i knew all that
was that um bad as it was um it was much
worse than i had realized in that not
only does jefferson fail
to abolish slavery in fact he decides to
postpone the whole idea of abolition
from
reasons that must have seemed realistic
enough to him
if he more or less consciously gifts
this horrible legacy to the next
generation
um
i had thought that was roughly as bad as
it was and he he kept it going he missed
the chance to abolish it he missed the
chance to not extend it to the louisiana
territories the purchase of which was
his idea and thomas paine's idea but
what i hadn't appreciated was that he
extended
and deepened the whole of slavery as
well he made certain that it went into
the new territories over the objections
of people like payne and barlow by the
way not to get carried away with this
but the thing you're sometimes told is
you mustn't judge by contemporary
standards
biographer mustn't impose as it were our
prejudices or our wisdoms on the past i
often think that some
that's false friendship as an advice as
a piece of advice because there were
people uh like
joel barlow and thomas paine who thought
exactly about slavery as we like to
think we do and who
tried to say to jefferson don't do this
mr president we we can begin again with
louisiana without this terrible system
but by agreeing to do it he made sure
absolutely sure not just that there
would be a protracting
of the institution and the deepening an
extension of it he made certain there
would be a civil war about it and i
hadn't really appreciated
that the situation had been as grave as
that now uh
but it is but he he was
a slave owner but he was not a murderer
so
unlike caravaggio uh
who you you had to
overlook this minor character award
henry i just kind of forgot that it
happened um i mean you know one of the
in the back of my mind or the front of
my mind the whole time i was writing
about caravaggio was the kind of the
larger abstract question of of why
certain works of art endure and and how
certain works of art continued to speak
to us over time in centuries so a
particular problem writing about
caravaggio is that so little was known
about his life i mean he left no
journals he left no letters he left no
preparatory drawings and most of what we
know about caravaggio in fact comes to
us through
police reports court depositions
complaints of his neighbors and so forth
so um so really all i could do or what i
mainly did was look at the paintings and
i thought the longer i look at these
paintings and the harder i think about
these paintings um
the more i'm going to know about
caravaggio and in fact there's a very
kind of intimate communication with the
painter that that does occur
aided by the fact that he that he put
self-portraits into so many of his
paintings and when you look at at you
know the the great famous
david with the head of goliath which was
one of his final paintings and he's
holding
the young david is holding the head of
goliath and in fact it's a double
self-portrait it's the it's the young
caravaggio and the the old wounded
caravaggio and if you look at that
picture long enough i think that you do
figure out certain things about its
creator and and those were things i
tried to put into the book
yeah that uh
and edmund you also stress the sense of
of
universality
and i i wonder if
it's
it's a virtual requirement of a
biography that the subject have that
kind of range that you really are able
to express through your subject the same
kinds of universal feelings that a
painter would or or
a composer
well all men contain multitudes um i
think it's quite possible in fact it's
often been proven that you can write a
biography
of the highest
literary and scholarly quality about
somebody who is not universal somebody
who might be indeed rather minor for
example
um
aj simon's book the quest for corvo
a book which is about the pursuit of
the recovery of an almost forgotten
minor
figure in british literary history and
it turned out to be one of the most
fascinating biographies ever written
now uh
he was minor but uh
aj ackerly j.a erkely wrote my dog tulip
right he wrote a biography of his dog
so uh and and virginia woolf wrote a
fictional biography of her dog
so i guess you can write about anyone
i have been
thinking about
since our hour amazingly enough is is
nearly up yeah i know we do talk on uh
it's it's been very entertaining i was
thinking
should we have questions or should we
what is that
sentence you quoted to me before about
when words when we've spoken enough
um i was saying when people run out of
things to say they usually turn to music
because music is takes off where words
where words fail but
um personally i think music would be
inappropriate at this time why don't we
just have a few questions
oh
come on
you said it should be spontaneous
[Laughter]
well look all i will do is um
illustrate
a major theme in the book which is that
um beethoven as everybody knows
was deaf
became deaf in his late 20s
began to become deaf
and suffered excruciating from tinnitus
through his um 30s
until he became so deaf that the only
way you could communicate with him was
to write questions on paper
now the confession that he had tinnitus
made me
examine his music to see if perhaps the
the pathology of tinnitus the chiming's
uh the roarings the buzzings in his ears
might have somehow come out
to produce these very weird sound
effects you do get occasionally in
beethoven
frequently in beethoven
and i talked about this to the american
association of neurological surgeons
in new orleans a couple of years ago and
happened to mention this idea of mine
and one of the neurologists got up and
said mr morris i
have myself begun to lose my hearing and
i'm studying the phenomenon of deafness
and he said i can only tell you that the
opening bars of the ninth symphony that
long sustained hovering fifth
that throbbing is exactly what you hear
when you're beginning to lose your
hearing
so if you insist i could demonstrate at
least one passage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the slow movement of beethoven's piano
sonata
in a flat major opus 110.
i was scared there
on this huge audience
[Music]
that a that reiterated a
shrieks in his music uh he uses it i
think 75 times at the finale of the
ninth symphony
i have no proof of it but i'm quite sure
that derived from his tinnitus
another composer friedrich smetana
actually wrote a string quartet he also
went deaf in his late years
in which um in the last movement it's
suddenly interrupted by this penetrating
shrill high e
um which was directly related to the
sounds in his head so it's a theory and
what the hell
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
i can't do that
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wrapping up the author panel on
biography here at the 23rd annual miami
book fair international live pictures
from the room in chapman hall on the
campus of miami-dade university
christopher hitchens a member of the
panel we just heard from has been a
columnist at vanity fair the nation and
slate an occasional contributor to
several other publications he's attended
cambridge and oxford and among his books
thomas jefferson author of america the
trial of henry kissinger and prepared
for the worst and edmond morris is best
known for his biographies of american
presidents
his biography the rise of theodore
roosevelt won the pulitzer prize and
american book award in 1980 he was for a
short time president reagan's authorized
biographer and published the national
bestseller dutch a memoir of ronald
reagan in 1999 he has written on travel
and the arts for the new yorker the new
york times and harper's magazine
we are bringing you live coverage of
today's events all day here on book tv
and coming up shortly we'll take you to